Ganz herzlichen guten Morgen an die Frühaufsteherinnen und Frühaufsteher. Obwohl ich 10 Uhr jetzt nicht so früh finde. Ab 7 steht man drauf.
Vor allem sind meine Kinder nicht zu Hause, da verschwende ich doch die Zeit nicht mit Ausschlafen. So, das ist er, der Dezember. Das Jahr neigt sich dem Ende und für viele fühlt es sich schon an wie ein ganzes Jahrzehnt.
Tja, bist du schon geimpft?
Nein! Ich bin, also was heißt geimpft? Ich bin noch nicht mit dem Impfstoff geimpft. Ich bin aber sehr wohl mit den Appellen geimpft, mich dann wirklich impfen zu lassen, wenn ich dran bin, wo ich mich befrage, denken die Politiker eigentlich noch mal mit? Wenn 60 Prozent der Menschen sich gerne impfen wollen und auch seelig darauf warten, kann man ihnen nicht die ganze Zeit mit dem Appell kommen. Aber geh dann bitte auch hin, wenn dieses Wenn einfach nicht kommt. Soll ich mir das bis August jetzt anhören oder was?
Mich regt das unglaublich auf, mich regt unglaublich auf, wie auch auf Twitter, Instagram und sonst wo ständig irgendwelche Comedians und Moderatoren und was weiß ich noch zum hundertsten Mal eine Pointe stricken, warum Impfgegner blöde sind und warum sich doch dann jetzt mal auch, und dann kommen immer so Namen, Uwe, Klaus und Herbert impfen lassen sollen. Und dann würde ich sagen, ja, Uwe, Klaus und Herbert wollen sich fast alle impfen lassen. Nur wann wird es so sein? Also ich hoffe ja, dass wir trotz Spanien und trotz EU ganz gut durch die Krise kommen und dass wir dann doch schneller geimpft werden, als das momentan aussieht. Ich hoffe da auf internationalen Druck im Sinne von Wettbewerb, wenn da die ersten Länder schon durchgeimpft sind und wenn dann die Pharmakonzerne auch zeigen, was sie leisten können, also da bin ich fast marktradikal, möchte ich sagen, dann wird man auch in der EU vielleicht noch mal eine Schippe drauflegen und das Ganze beschleunigen. Aber ich finde, sich jetzt damit zu beschäftigen, mit jenen, die noch nicht geimpft werden wollen, die da Skrupel haben, das ist doch vollkommen irre.
Absolut. Lass doch erst mal die 60 Prozent impfen, die sich impfen lassen wollen, dann haben auch diejenigen, die noch Vorbehalte haben, Menschen im Blick und sehen, 60 Millionen Menschen sind hier nicht tot umgefallen in Deutschland. Vielleicht sollte ich mich auch mal öffnen lassen, weil ich keine Lust auf Lugentod habe. Das verstehe ich absolut nicht. Ich hoffe auch sehr auf den Wettbewerb, du hast es angesprochen. Die Zeit hat ja gestern auf ihrer Seite schon mal so eine Karte gemacht, wo man in absoluten Zahlen sieht, wie die in den Bundesländern durchgeimpft wird. Hessen stand gestern noch bei Null, ich habe es nicht verstanden. Ich frage mich ganz ehrlich, kriegen sie es hin oder nicht? Woran mangelt sie eigentlich? Dann hat unser Matthias, der ja auch diese Intro-Musik gemacht hat, mal mit Google-Tools-Hilfe eine eigene Karte gebaut, um noch mal die aktuellen Impfzahlen so auf einer Deutschlandkarte abzubilden, dass man in den Bundesländern wenigstens mal die Prozentzahl sieht, wie viele sind denn schon geimpft, weil das ist ehrlich gesagt eine traurige Zahl. Wir haben in Amerika sind jetzt zwei Millionen Menschen geimpft, das ist schon fast ein Prozent der Bevölkerung. Und hier strotzt es von 0, 00, wir hatten ja leider nur 10.000 Impfdosen, dann wurden die in Bayern noch kurz in der Kühlkette unterbrochen, dann haben sie bei BioNTech angerufen, dann haben die gesagt, wir kühlen nur zur Sicherheit auf minus 70 Grad, wahrscheinlich schafft der es auch bei minus 20. Und wenn sie die Kühlkette nur kurz unterbrochen haben, sind noch nicht die ganzen RNA-Sstränge durchgefallen. Sie können das weiter impfen, setzen sich die Landräder zusammen und entscheiden, ne wir verimpfen das nicht. Ach so, ach haben wir zu viel jetzt auf einmal, ja. Bleibt was übrig, kann man jetzt einfach entscheiden. Wir impfen das mal nicht, selbst wenn der Hersteller sagt, es war nur eine Sicherheitsmaßnahme, gut, ihr habt es kurz verkackt, aber es geht vielleicht trotzdem noch. Also es geht noch, ja es ist jetzt nicht, drei Tage lang stand es rum und die RNA-Sstränge sind zerfallen, weil die sind nun mal sehr leicht auflösbar, sondern bitte verimpft es und dann nein. Und dann diese Impfdosen werden ja so in kleinen Packungen, wo drauf steht, dass wir eine fünffache Impfdosis bitte aufteilen und dann ordentlich. Und eigentlich sitzen da ja auch Ärzte, Helge Braun zum Beispiel, unser Kanzleramtschef, hat ja sich auch schon in den Arztkittel geworfen und die ersten Impfungen selber mitgegeben.
Aber manche haben sich gedacht, mehr hilft mehr.
Und dann, dass es tatsächlich zu dem Fehler kommt, die Anweisung auf der Packung nicht zu lesen und den fünffachen, weil so verpackten Impfstoff in einen Arm reinzuspritzen, das hätte ich wirklich nicht für möglich gehalten. Also es ist auch erstaunlich wie Inkompetenz schon wieder sichtbar. Das gefällt mir überhaupt nicht, das muss ich echt mal sagen. Also ich habe wirklich die Befeuchtung, dass es länger dauert als bis August. Und das wäre ein Drama, wenn wir noch mal einen Herbst-Winter-Saison ohne Impfung hier haben.
Ja, ich bin auch erzürnt darüber. Bin fast zum Brexit-Anhänger jetzt im Dezember geworden, nachdem ich mit einem Bekannten, mit James, gesprochen habe, dessen Großeltern bereits geimpft sind. Und wenn ich sehe, was dann hier passiert, und wie sieht es eigentlich aus? Nun machen das ja gerade Ärzte. Nun sind ja solche Spritzen zu verabreichen keine Hexenkunst, sondern da könnte man ja ganz viele Leute anlernen. Also jeder Diabetiker spritzt sich, manche Leute hatten vielleicht mal eine Entzündung im Knie, die haben sich regelmäßig dann ins Bein was gespritzt. Ich weiß, es ist bei dieser Impfung ein bisschen komplizierter, aber es ist ja machbar. Man muss ja dafür nicht zehn Semester Medizin studiert haben oder ausgebildeter Krankenpfleger sein. Wird da irgendetwas gerade unternommen, dass man sagt, eigentlich können viel mehr diese Impfung verabreichen?
Nein, soweit ich weiß, ist das Impfen weiterhin den Ärzten vorbehalten, obwohl Arzthelfer und Arzthelferinnen, natürlich genauso die Pflegepersonalien und sogar junge Apotheker sind...
Sehr gut, dass du das ansprichst. Das hat mir ein junger Apotheker erzählt, dass man eigentlich schon länger versucht, dass man sagt, viele Apotheken könnten auch impfen. Das braucht man nicht, alles den Ärzten zu überlassen. Und das könnte man auch ganz schön flächendeckend regeln. Und diese ganzen Hausärzte sind ja sowieso überlagert mit Patienten, weil es immer weniger Hausärzte auf dem Lande gibt und und und. Und da streut man sich aber offenbar immer noch dagegen. Und diese Apotheker hatte jetzt die Hoffnung, dass sich jetzt einfach durch diesen Druck etwas ändert und dass man sagt, ok, dann lassen wir doch auch die Apotheker diese Impfungen machen.
Genau. Es gehört zum Ausbildungsprogramm. Junge Apotheker, ich weiß nicht genau, die letzten zehn Jahre oder so, kann man davon ausgehen, dass die das alle gelernt haben und auch können. Und ja, wenn was schiefgeht, muss man sowieso einen Notarzt holen. Aber diese ganzen Schockreaktionen auf Impfungen bleiben eh aus. Das Zeug wird ja nicht irgendwie in den Knochen oder so. Das muss einfach nur in den Muskel. Da nimmt man den Arm typischerweise, damit niemand überrascht ist von was das muss. Wir haben auch größere Muskel am Körper, zum Beispiel im Popo. Da könnte man viel zielsicherer, gerade wenn man... Und das war ja auch eine Überlegung, dass man die Nadel wirklich anpasst. Und jetzt nimmt man einfach die Standardnadel, die so lang ist, dass man alles mit ihr machen könnte. Man könnte auch einfach sagen, okay, wir gehen wirklich ins Bein. Der Muskel ist dort selbst bei den Menschen, die nicht sehr viel Sport machen, mindestens drei Zentimeter dick. Also ist die Nadel 1, 5 Zentimeter lang. Man schlägt die bis zum Anschlag rein und drückt das dann. Ein bisschen komplizierter ist natürlich noch, das Zeug aufzutauen und dann zu mischen. Das muss ja noch mal im Verhältnis eins zu irgendwas mit irgendeiner Lösung vermischt werden. Also nicht volle Dosis, sondern es kommt sozusagen noch ein flüssiges Trägermaterial dazu. Es ist nicht nur Wasser, aber so eine Salzmischung oder so. Das kann man natürlich dann, aber die Spritze selbst und so. Ich meine, wir haben so viel Insulinkranke in unserer deutschen Rentnerpublik, die nun mal an Zivilisationskrankheiten leidet, wie... Das wäre auch nochmal ein Thema für nächstes Jahr dann, wenn man mal so ein bisschen Bilanz auch zieht nach dem ganzen Stress. Wenn Jens Spahn einfach locker vom Hocker sagt, wir haben hier 40% Risikogruppe, muss man sich wirklich fragen, was haben wir denn bitte für ein Gesundheitssystem, dass das hinnimmt, dass hier einfach 40% wissend nicht an Altersschwäche sterben, sondern vorher an irgendwelchen Zivilisationskrankheiten. Also in der Ansicht steckt in diesem Thema noch viel drin, aber ich würde sagen, heute im Dezember belassen wir es bei Corona, was das angeht. Bleibt ja als Thema dann.
Man regt sich auch zu sehr auf.
Richtig.
Ich stelle es immer wieder fest. Ich rege mich ungloppig auf.
Ja, wir holen jetzt erst mal die Risikogruppen, also altersbedingt wirklich in die Impfung rein. Bis Ende März leider nur 5 Millionen. Das reicht aber zumindest für die 30.000 100-Jährigen, die wir in Deutschland haben. Die sind ja wohl jetzt im Jahresende durch. Also Durchschnittsalter der Todesfälle sind immer noch 83 Jahre in Deutschland, leicht über der allgemeinen Lebenserwartung. Und Durchschnittsalter der intensivpflichtigen Patienten 62 Jahre. Also da ist sozusagen noch wirklich viel. Das schafft man dann mit 5 Millionen, also 10 Millionen Impfdosen für 5 Millionen Menschen bis März. Noch eigentlich noch nicht das einzufangen. Dann kommt der entspannte Sommer. Dann kommt dann auch der Cure-Weck-Impfstoff. Das ist ja das, worauf die Politiker eigentlich gehofft hatten, seit sie Biontech-Impfstoff ausgeschlagen haben, als das Angebot bestand, hier mehrere 100 Millionen Dosen zu holen.
Aber das ist doch so skandalös. Warum wird das eigentlich nicht mehr politisiert? Also auch von der Opposition und und. Also warum geschieht das nicht? Es gab ja diesen großen Spiegelartikel darüber, der das sehr klar gemacht hat, wie sehr dort versagt wurde. Und das wird aber gar nicht als großes Thema gesehen. Stattdessen redet man über Impfgegner.
Vor allem Biontech hat das Angebot gemacht. Das kennen wir aus Amerika. Also den amerikanischen Fall kenne ich jetzt ein bisschen besser. Nehmt doch noch mal 100 Millionen Dosen extra. Neben den 100 Millionen, mit denen wir schon vereinbart haben. Ihr müsst sie erst bezahlen, wenn wir geliefert haben. Die Trump-Regierung hat Nein gesagt. Und das war ein Megaskandal. The Daily hat einen Podcast dazu gemacht. In Deutschland ja. In Europa wurde auch so ein Angebot ausgeschlagen. Und da hat Biontech auch das Angebot gemacht.
300 Millionen, glaube ich.
Mehr sogar noch, genau. Also auf jeden Fall mehr. Ich weiß nicht genau wie viel. Es war auch noch 500 Millionen. Hab ich auch schon mal gelesen. Ja, keine Ahnung. Es ist alles ein großes Rätsel. Es ist ein Skandal. Und jetzt allerdings muss man echt erst mal hoffen, dass es glatt über die Bühne geht. Danach kann man ja immer noch darüber reden. Wir haben ja zum Glück einen Bundestagswahlkampf, in dem wir das vielleicht noch mal ein bisschen durchthematisieren und aufarbeiten können. Hoffnung stirbt zuletzt.
Ich mache jetzt aber auch nicht mehr Hoffnung. Wir haben ja schon über Militär immer wieder im Jahr gesprochen, über Gesichtserkennung haben wir gesprochen, über Drohnen und diese Drohnen-Debatte, die gab es jetzt wieder einmal. Es gab 2019 schon eine Drohnen-Debatte im Dezember im Bundestag, wenn ich mich recht erinnere. Und jetzt gab es wieder eine, denn die SPD ist ja jetzt plötzlich nicht mehr so sehr für Drohnen. Man ist skeptisch, die Werbeauftragte ist für die Anschaffung von bewaffneten Drohnen. Die SPD sagt nein, wir brauchen eigentlich mehr Bedenkzeit. Wir müssen nochmal über alles reden. Man muss dazu sagen, man ist schon recht lange darüber am Reden. Man macht das seit acht Jahren. Und es gab jetzt nochmal eine Bundestagsdebatte. Und wieder kann ich hier feststellen, was ich schon das letzte Mal, als wir über Drohnen gesprochen haben, festgestellt haben. Dieser Bundestag ist nicht interessiert jetzt an einer intellektuellen Debatte darüber, nicht an einem reflektierten Austausch der Argumente. Und ich habe uns allen jetzt ersparen wollen, dass wir uns wieder anhören, was sagt da die CDU, die FDP, die AfD und und und. Und möchte nur einen einzigen Clip auswählen, der das wirklich nochmal ganz symptomatisch zeigt. Henning Otte von der CDU wirft jetzt SPD, Grüne und Linke folgendes vor.
Hier zeigt sich ein gemeinsamer Kniefall von SPD, Links und Grüne vor der sozialistisch-pazifistischen Ideologie. Das ist ein Verrat an der Bundeswehr.
Klüger wird es auch dann nicht. Und so geht das dann halt munter weiter und man sieht, dass diese Debatten zu nichts führen. Dann kommt aber noch mal Heike Keul. Das ist die Grüne Abgeordnete, die wir schon vom Ausschuss kennengelernt haben. Und die versucht jetzt wenigstens noch mal diese Argumente stark zu machen, die die Grünen haben gegen die Anschaffung von bewaffneten Drohnen. Denn es geht ja immer um den Schutz der Soldaten.
Der Schutz der Soldatinnen und Soldaten ist für uns ein entscheidendes Kriterium. Die vorgetragenen Fallbeispiele waren allerdings erschreckend ungeeignet, um den Vorteil bewaffneter Drohnen darzulegen. Ich hätte erwartet, dass Sie es uns schwerer machen. Durch Drohnen hätten weder die dargestellte Hinrichtung durch Terroristen verhindert, noch ein unübersichtliches Kampfgeschehen beim Angriff auf eine Patrouille beendet werden können. Bewaffnete Drohnen sind eben keine sauberen Wunderwaffen, die nur die Bösen treffen und die Guten schonen.
Also dieses Drama in der Bundesregierung entfaltete sich ja so, dass die SPD ihren, ich weiß gar nicht wie man es nennt, Schattenverteidigungsminister, die haben ja dann immer diese Sprecherrollen, verlor, weil er diese Entscheidung der SPD, sich jetzt gegen die Drohnen zu stellen, nicht mitmachte und dann sagte, also ich kann meine Partei hier nicht länger verstehen, ich gehe, ich verlasse diesen Posten. Die SPD stellt sich quer und dann stellte sich heraus, ich hab das beim Deutschlandfunk so gehört, fand ich ganz interessant, dass der Umschwung in der SPD jetzt so plötzlich gegen die Drohnen auch daher rührte, dass man sich den Krieg in Bergkarabach angeschaut hat. Wo eben dieses Argument, wo man mal sehen konnte, in der Theorie, im parlamentarischen Gespräch geht es um den Schutz der Soldaten. Und in der Praxis geht es danach um die absolute Ausbeutung aller Kapazitäten, die man mit Drohnen so hat. Und da gibt es einfach einen Brückenschlag dazwischen, der sich nicht durch Appelle, Goodwill, sonst irgendwas, das ist nur Verteidigung, das ist nur Aufklärung, wie auch immer, das ist nur im Notfall mal der wirkliche Einsatz von militärischen Wirkmitteln, wie es dann so heißt, dass man dem nicht glauben kann. Und dass man auch der Bundeswehr, die ja, wenn man ihr einmal das Mandat erteilt hat, ja, du darfst die Drohnen mit dir führen, nicht vertraut, da nicht über die Stränge zu schlagen mit dieser Waffe. Und das fand ich schon sehr mutig von der SPD, das mal so deutlich anzudeuten. Sie haben es nicht so deutlich gesagt, dass sie der Bundeswehr da nicht vertrauen. Aber da rührt das her, dass man einfach nicht glaubt, dass Soldaten nur wirklich das machen, was man damit machen darf. Und da kennen wir auch aus der Bundeswehr die bisherigen Aufarbeitungen von, naja, zum Beispiel, jederdings klein und so weiter, wie man dann doch mit Waffen umgeht, wenn man sie einmal zur Verfügung hat.
Genau, und Keul hat das ja damals auch im Ausschuss ganz deutlich gemacht. Es ist zwar so, dass wir es bei der Bundeswehr mit einer Parlamentsarmee zu tun haben, aber es ist nicht so, dass das Parlament dann mit dem Lageplan da sitzt und die Einsätze genau entscheidet, sondern die sagen Ja oder Nein. Und dann gibt es eine riesige Grauzone, die sich sehr, sehr erweitert, wenn man jetzt auf bewaffnete Drohnen noch setzt. Und wir hatten ja auch über Bergkarabach gesprochen mit Bezug auf die Drohnen. Und da wird das natürlich sehr deutlich. Und dann hat aber Keul sich gedacht, gut, ich habe doch damals schon angefragt bei der Bundesregierung, inwiefern denn diese Drohnen schützen würden oder gab es da Fälle? Kann die Bundesregierung mir mal Auskunft darüber geben? Wie sieht es dann mit dem Schutz der Soldaten aus? Und da hat sie ja keine Antwort erhalten. Und bzw. hat man sich dann so rausgeredet, man könnte das nicht so genau sagen. Jetzt hat sie das offenbar nochmal gemacht. Und sie geht nochmal kurz darauf ein.
Ich habe bei der Bundesregierung trotzdem nochmal schriftlich nachgefragt, wie oft die Bundeswehr in Afghanistan auf den Schutz durch bewaffnete Drohnen der Bündnispartner angewiesen war. Denn das wäre ja durchaus relevant gewesen. Die Antwort der Bundesregierung war allen Ernstes, dass sie darüber keine Kenntnis hat.
Ja, das ist ein Skandal, ehrlich gesagt. Das haben wir auch mehrfach hier schon im Fernsehpodcast immer mal wieder thematisiert. Inwieweit greift denn die Bundeswehr auf Drohnenhilfe ihrer Partner zurück? Und wenigstens das möchte doch bitte protokolliert sein, um beispielsweise einen Antrag zu schreiben, wir mussten jetzt siebenmal darauf zurückgreifen. Beim Achtmal würden wir gerne selber aus Zeitgründen oder wie auch immer selber diese Technik vorhalten. Und wenn man das nicht so begründen kann, dann geht es nicht. Also da würde ich auch sagen, das ist wirklich, klingt so nebensächlich, aber dass es da kein Wissen drüber gibt, das ist wirklich skandalös.
Unsere Verteidigungsministerin Annegret Kramp-Karenbauer, die war im saarländischen Fernsehen zu Gast. Und das war ein Gespräch, muss man sagen, nachdem es jetzt diesen E-Klar gab, um die Erhöhung des Rundfunkbeitrags. Und man merkt jetzt, da ist eine Moderatorin, die hat überhaupt kein Interesse daran, die Ministerpräsidentin, die ehemalige und jetzt Verteidigungsministerin zu kritisieren, sondern sie stellt eine Frage und liefert ihr aber auch gleich schon eine Antwort immer dann mit. Also, wenn man mal sehen will, wie Journalismus nicht stattfinden sollte, dann muss man sich dieses Interview bei YouTube ansehen. Wir gehen jetzt darauf nicht ein. Ich will das nur mal sagen, dass man wirklich daran sehen kann, dass man jetzt sich bei der CDU offenbar auch strategisch aufgestellt hat mit dieser zum Teil dann Abschaffung des Rundfunkbeitrags, sie oder nicht Erhöhung. Und sie spricht sich jetzt für den Rundfunkbeitrag zwar aus AKK, aber es wird sehr deutlich, hier zeigt einfach die CDU, wir haben schon eine politische Macht und wir können auch, wenn uns das hier nicht mehr weiter gefällt, sagen, das machen wir nicht mehr länger mit. Und das merkst du, du merkst wirklich diese Angst der Moderatorin, was ist denn, wenn die mir mal hier das saarländische Fernsehen abschaffen? Was mache ich dann eigentlich? Und ich muss sagen, ich weiß es auch nicht, was sie dann machen würde. Aber das zeigt auch noch mal ganz klar, warum man trotz aller Kritik am Öffentlich-Rechtlichen, und ich hab da viel und wir kommen heute zu einer Kultursendung, und ich hab da viel Kritik, dass man trotzdem dafür sein muss. Und zwar aus einem ganz strategischen Grund. Die Einführung des Privatfernsehens kam zustande durch die CDU. Das Interesse dahinter ist ein sehr simples. Man sagt sich, ja, das Öffentlich-Rechtliche, das hat nicht die Kapitalinteressen, wie sie ausgedrückt werden beim Privatfernsehen. Wir aber als CDU und CSU vertreten Kapitalinteressen. Also ist uns jedes private Medium viel, viel lieber, weil wir eigentlich mit denen viel stärker verbandet sind. Siehe Springer, du hast im Fernsehpodcast drüber gesprochen, über diese Springer-Doku, über die Bildzeitungs-Doku, die es jetzt bei Amazon Prime zu sehen gibt. Das heißt, es gibt von Seiten der CDU eigentlich natürlich eine grundsätzliche Abwehr gegen das Öffentlich-Rechtliche, weil es nicht unbedingt diesen Kapitalinteressen Ausdruck verleihen muss, wie das ein RTL, wie das eine Bildzeitung sowieso tut, weil sie nur an Profit interessiert sind, was aber nicht bedeutet, weil das wird dann auch immer so gesagt, ja und deswegen sind Öffentlich-Rechtliche alle links. Also es gibt da eine gewisse Kulturlinke. Das hat aber eher, glaube ich, was mit einer Berlin-Blase zu tun, dass man sich dann auf irgendwelche schicken Sachen gerade einigt. Aber sonst haben wir es jetzt nicht mit einem besonders linken Rundfunk zu tun. Das sieht man auch daran, wie zum Beispiel das Öffentlich-Rechtliche die Agenda 2010, die Hartz-IV-Reformen begleitet hat. Aber man muss sich das wirklich sehr bewusst machen, dass es also darum geht, dass man eigentlich eine Presse braucht, wenn man CDU oder CSU ist, die Kapitalinteressen vertritt auf eine Weise, dass die Leute, die eigentlich nicht von diesen Interessen profitieren, nämlich Leser der Bildzeitung, Zuschauer von RTL, trotzdem sagen, ach, das ist eine tolle Partei, die wähle ich mal. Denn eigentlich haben ja die CDU und die CSU eine ganz große Wählerklientel, die gegen ihr eigenes Interesse wählt. Das ist ja das Interessante. Also wenn man jetzt zum Beispiel die Linke hat oder die Grüne hat und wählt die, dann kann man immer noch sagen, das geht mir nicht weit genug, oder die SPD, die müssten noch sozialer sein, noch pazifistischer, noch grüner oder was auch immer. Aber man wählt sie nicht gegen das eigene Interesse, aber man wählt, wenn man, oder auch FDP, wenn man Union wählt, wählt man eigentlich gegen das Interesse, sei denn man ist selbst reich und sagt, gut, ich hab jetzt noch 40 Wohnungen zu vererben und ich möchte auch, dass ich wenig Steuern dafür zahle, dann sollte man auf jeden Fall die CDU wählen. Aber das kann man einfach sehr schön daran sehen. Und das nur als kleiner Exkurs mal. Und mit dieser Haltung sitzt jetzt AKK da. Also ich will doch, dass ihr hier weiter Fernsehen machen könnt und bekommt da nur liebe Fragen gestellt. Und sie sagt dann auch hier etwas zum Thema Drohnen und SPD.
Aber was ich nicht respektieren kann, ist, wenn man wirklich nach acht Jahren und auch in diesem Jahr intensiven Debatten und Diskussionen, Einsatzgrundsätzen, die entwickelt worden ist, sagt, wir sind noch nicht so weit, wir müssen noch weiter diskutieren. Das ist einfach feige. Und deswegen würde ich mir sehr wünschen, wenn die SPD klipp und klar sagt, was sie will oder nicht will, dann wissen alle, woran sie sind. Dann kann man es im Wahlkampf eben auch entsprechend zur Debatte stellen.
Na ja, sie hofft auf die öffentliche Meinung. Na gut.
Und dann macht sie das dann so, wie das dann in der Bundestagsdebatte schon zu sehen war, dass man sagt, ja, die SPD, die verrät unsere Soldaten, die werden alle sterben, weil wir diese Drohnen nicht anschaffen. Man kann ja Fragen auch dann so stellen, man wird dann Umfragen machen. Ich würde sagen, sind sie für bewaffnete Drohnen, damit unsere Soldaten maximal geschützt werden? Und dann sagen natürlich viele, viele Leute ja, weil sie keine Ahnung davon haben.
Genau, du musst ja nur die Frage richtig formulieren. Du hast ja immer Bild und RTL, deswegen nehme ich die auch mal, weil die sind da wirklich Schiffe für. Bild, ganzseitig und RTL, sagen wir mal so Punkt zwölf oder Punkt neun, diese typischen Sendungen, die halt so kommen. Da liegt es auf der Hand, dass du denjenigen, der drei Rollen Toilettenpapier zu viel kauft, zum absoluten Sozial-Sünder und Idioten abstempelst, aber wenn du dir 200 Millionen über Cum-Ex-Geschäfte heranholst, wenn überhaupt ein Thema dann immer noch unter der Maxime, aber auch ganz schön clever irgendwie.
Ja genau.
Also ist das Skandal dann nicht aufgemacht. Und in deren Sicht kannst du da solche Thron-Debatten, wir wollen doch die Soldaten schützen, also da geht man auf jeden Fall kein großes Risiko ein, wenn man glaubt, darüber, über öffentliche Meinung, die Entscheidung herbeiführen zu können. Und in deren Sicht nutzt sie das da ganz gut.
Wir wissen, 2020 war ein tolles Jahr, vor allem für die jungen Menschen. Die konnten sich mal so richtig austoben und die haben ja Zuverdienste ohne Ende, wo jetzt die ganzen Minijobs weggefallen sind. Und da denkt man noch, nein, also das ist natürlich sehr zynisch. In Wahrheit war dieses Jahr für junge Leute sehr, sehr hart. Und für Studenten ganz hart, weil die eben Jobs verloren haben, weil sie Kredite aufnehmen mussten. Und du hast das ja auch schon mal bei Twitter angesprochen. Eigentlich müssten jetzt die jungen Leute direkt so ein Startguthaben bekommen, dafür, dass sie jetzt auch so schwierige Zeiten hatten, dafür, dass sie so viel entbeeren müssen und dass sie Rücksicht genommen haben auf die Alten. Denn es gibt da ein paar Partypeople, aber die anderen haben sich ja auch sehr korrekt verhalten, muss man sagen. Und die leiden jetzt wieder darunter, dass die Impfungen unendlich lange brauchen werden. Man hätte alles viel schneller haben können. Natürlich ist es richtig, dass wohl in Arable zuerst geimpft werden, aber es könnte generell alles schneller gehen. Das heißt, für die jungen Leute ist das jetzt wieder eine harte Zeit. Und dann denkt man jetzt, okay, jetzt ruder ich doch mal in einem Punkt zurück. Wir wissen, AKK hat im Herbst 2019 gesagt, ja, das wäre doch mal schön, wenn man so eine Dienstjahrpflicht einführen würde. Jeder junge Mensch soll mal ein Jahr für sein Land etwas tun, nicht immer nur an sich denken. Und ich würde sagen, diese Dienstpflicht, die wurde jetzt übererfüllt. Und dafür müsste es jetzt eigentlich diese Entschädigung geben, von der du gesprochen hast. Und jetzt wird AKK am Ende dieses Interviews gefragt, welcher Punkt wäre ihnen denn wichtig, wenn der neue Kanzlerkandidat dann irgendwann feststeht, welchen sollte man noch mal aufgreifen? Ist das eher Migration oder mehr Abgrenzung zur AfD?
Mir persönlich wäre das Thema Dienstpflicht ein großes Anliegen. Wir haben jetzt gerade in der Bundeswehr den neuen Freiwilligendienst auch ins Leben gerufen mit dem hohen Interesse. Und ich bekomme viele Zuschriften, egal ob man für eine Dienstpflicht ist oder einen Freiwilligendienst, aber viele Zuschriften, die sagen, ja, wir bräuchten noch mal so was, was uns zusammenhält. Da gibt es eine hohe Bereitschaft.
Also diese Zuschriften kriegt sie natürlich nicht. Das ist wie Alice Schwarzer, die mit Verona Feldbusch im Fernsehstudio sitzt und sagt, also mir sagen ganz viele junge Leute auf der Straße, die Verona Feldbusch setzt mich so unter Druck.
Ja, genau. Die sprechen natürlich sofort Alice Schwarzer an und da kennen sie auch.
Ich hatte gestern, du hast es angesprochen, diesen Tweet gemacht, einfach zum Thema, junge Menschen sollten von der Bundesregierung mit 25.000 Euro dafür entschädigt werden, dass sie als allerletzte auf der Schutzliste des Staates stehen, was die Impfung angeht. Denn wir kommen jetzt in das Problem, dass wir relativ zügig, auch wenn wir es eben, aber der Plan ist zumindest, es zügig zu machen, die absoluten Intensivstations-Risikogruppen rausnehmen, raus sortieren durch Impfungen. Corona aber bleibt. Und zwar mit allen Long-Covid und so weiter Einschränkungen, die wir individuell, biologisch als auch volkswirtschaftlich dadurch so haben. Das heißt, der mediale Stress wird sehr sinkend dadurch, dass sich die Situation auf den Intensivstationen im Gesundheitssystem entspannt. Und dann weiß man nicht genau, zu was führt das dann eigentlich, dass wir vielleicht eine schnellere Durchseuchung noch haben, weil wir wissen ja, Corona ist immer noch eine exponentielle Gefahr, während wir linear impfen. Es sind nicht jeden Tag 20.000 in Berlin und nicht am ersten Tag 20.000 und dann 200.000 und so, sondern es geht eben linear und das dauert entsprechend. Da braucht man dann für die ganzen Berliner schon mal 200 Tage am Ende. Und auf diese Hinweise, man könnte ja auch einfach sagen 25.000 Euro dafür, dass man dann, keine Ahnung, sich zumindest zu Hause ein angenehmeres Leben macht oder ein bisschen entspannter in die Zukunft schaut, hat Gunter Dutt geschrieben. Ja, aber dafür wurden den damals jungen Menschen ja 12 bis 18 Monate durch Bundeswehr und Zivildienst genommen, dass man AKK jetzt vorschlägt, worauf ich wieder geantwortet habe, naja, die Menschen, die heute jung sind und diese 25.000 Euro brauchen, die haben zwar keine Dienstpflicht und machen kein soziales Dingsterbums, Ziviljahr oder sind bei der Bundeswehr, aber die arbeiten 20 Stunden in der Woche, um die viel zu hohe Miete für ihren Baby-Boomer-Vermieter aufzubringen. Also in der Hinsicht müssen wir ganz viele Gerechtigkeitsfragen einfach mal durchdeklinieren. Und für eine Dienstpflicht. Also ich frage mich, in welche Biografie das noch reinpassen soll heute. Das ist ja völlig idiotisch.
Und auf dieses Argument, dann rücken wir mal wieder zusammen oder haben wir mal wieder was gemeinsam. Man würdet den jungen Leuten mal wieder was auf, damit es den Boomer noch besser geht. Und ich finde, dass derart skandalös, dass so was überhaupt gesagt werden kann, ohne dass es danach einen Aufschrei gibt, einen richtigen Aufschrei. Und ich habe das aber auch damals noch erlebt, dass bei Zeitungsredakteuren dann auch, die so über 60 waren, ja, mich hat ja auch mein Sohn angerufen noch. Der hat gesagt, das war eigentlich doch ganz gut, als man bei der Bundeswehr war und dann jemand anderes sagte ja. Und mein Sohn, der ist ja direkt dann ins Ausland, der war gar nicht bei der Bundeswehr. Und heute vermisst er so das Gemeinschaftliche. Da muss ich sagen, dann gehen, vereinen, such dir eine Freundin, was auch immer. Aber nicht jetzt eine ganze Generation drückt die in eine Situation rein, in die sie nicht rein will. Also wo sind wir dann gelandet, dass wir jetzt irgendwie mal was Gemeinschaftliches brauchen? Ich brauche mal was Gemeinschaftliches im Sinne von finanzieller Hilfe, Steuererleichterungen für jene, die wenig verdienen. Also HKK ist wirklich, ja, man muss ausfallend werden, deswegen müssen wir was zu einem anderen Thema kommen. Aber du hast mit noch vielleicht was, was an diese Geldfrage doch ganz gut anknüpft, denn ich könnte ja jetzt einfach mal sagen, Stefan, woher willst du denn das ganze Geld nehmen?
Ja, sehr gut. Woher das ganze Geld nehmen, das fällt mir nicht schwer zu beantworten, denn wir haben es schon immer hier betont und erwähnt, zum Beispiel schon in der Januar-Ausgabe, als wir uns die Pressekonferenz von Christine Lagarde angeschaut haben. Sie war damals relativ neue EZB-Chefin. Und wir haben damals schon überlegt Modern Monetary Theory, also diese Idee, dass man einen Emittenten von Geld hat, dem das gar nicht wehtut, das Geld abzugeben, weil er es für sich nicht braucht. Die EZB kauft sich jetzt nicht weniger Milch, nur weil sie Geld ausgegeben hat, sondern die muss auf nichts verzichten und das Geld ist dann trotzdem da. Und da war ich doch zum einen sehr fasziniert von diesem Jahr insgesamt, denn wir können einfach mal festhalten, dass was wir vielleicht gehofft haben, was in einem Jahrzehnt passiert, nämlich dass sich erstens diese Theorie intellektuell niederschlägt, also dass Zeitungen dann mal aktiv und konstruktiv damit umgehen, statt immer nur was von der schwarzen Null, von den zukünftigen Generationen oder wie auch immer zu erzählen. Da sind wir noch nicht ganz. Wir haben immer noch Jens Südekum und so weiter, die es wohl wissend wie die Realität aussieht, den Zeitungsredaktionen als Meinungsstück darlegen. Die kommen gar nicht umhin, das zu drucken. Dann kommt doch wieder der Gernse-Mann, oder wie er heißt, von der Weltwirtschaftsredaktion, schreibt wieder. Das ist ja alles eine tolle Idee, aber, aber, aber. Auf der anderen Seite, also neben dieser intellektuellen, das muss einmal durchs Bewusstsein gedreht werden, haben wir eine Realität, in der die Europäische Zentralbank ihren Pandemic Emergency Fund, mit dem sie Staatsanleihen aufkauft, jüngst aufgestockt hat, auf 1, 8 Billionen Euro. Das ist in der Summe mehr, mehr als alle Staatsschulden, die dieses Jahr in Europa aufgenommen wurden. Vorrangig natürlich wegen Corona. Wir kennen die zwei deutschen Bundeshaushalte, die sich auf 400 Milliarden summieren und so weiter. Also mehr als die europäischen Länder dieses Jahr an Schulden aufgenommen haben, und zwar in Rekordschulden ja. Noch mehr Geld hat die EZB einfach so zur Verfügung gestellt. Unabhängig davon sitzt ja die Europäische Kommission immer noch an der Idee, man musste sie jetzt ein bisschen verlängern wegen diesem Veto aus Polen und Ungarn. Auch nochmal 750 Milliarden an eigenen Schulden aufgenommen natürlich bei der EZB. Also überbande natürlich, es darf ja keine direkte Finanzierung geben, aber man geht zum Finanzmarkt und weiß, die sind sich da sicher, weil die EZB kauft zu 100 Prozent. Dieses Versprechen ist gegeben. Also wir sprechen hier von 2, 5 Billionen Euro, die im Raum stehen. Und 1, 8 Billionen davon, das EZB-Geld ist tatsächlich schon ausgezahlt. Also das ist nicht so, dass da so eine Idee ist und dann hoffen wir mal, dass kein Veto kommt oder so, sondern Christine Lagarde sitzt da und sagt, ich habe meine Leute beauftragt, so und so viel vom Markt wegzukaufen. Und damit ist dieses Geld zur Verfügung. Also ganz, ganz crazy eigentlich, was hier passiert, dafür, dass es ja mit Ja jetzt eigentlich gar kein Thema ist. Also wir müssen jetzt nicht drauf warten, dass im Börsenbericht der ARD-Tagesthema oder so, das mal irgendwie so thematisiert wird.
Ja, schwarze Tage für Hans-Werner Sinn, kann man sagen. Hans-Werner Sinn hat ja schon wieder vor der Inflation gewarnt hat.
Er hat jetzt im Dezember, richtig.
Erklärt, diese Inflation damals, die hat zum Nationalsozialismus geführt, was so nicht richtig ist.
Darauf will ich hinaus. Hans-Werner Sinn hat jetzt im Dezember, ich habe keinen Clip davon, keine Angst. Er hat wieder mal einen Vortrag gehalten. Er ist ja emeritierter Professor und ehemals Ifo-Institut und so weiter. Sie kriegt aber noch die Anfragen, nimmt er gerne an, um sein Mantra. Aber jetzt kommt die Hyperinflation, weil 1, 8 Billionen, das steckt keiner so einfach weg. Stellt sich raus, wir sind in dem dritten Monat in Folge in Deflation. Und was heißt eigentlich Deflation? Und da gab es, da habe ich auch keinen Clip von, deswegen, das müsst ihr dann komplett hören, dieses einstündige Gespräch von Ole, deinem Wohlstand für alle, Kompagnon mit Adam Toos. Wahrscheinlich dem größten Typen überhaupt, gerade in der Regel Fratscher, Südekum, Toos, wie sie alle heißen. Es gibt ja im Englischen zum Glück ein paar mehr, und er kann ja sehr gut Deutsch. Er hat vor zehn Jahren oder so ein Buch über Hitler geschrieben.
Genau, über die NS-Wirtschaft.
Genau. Die Zeiten Hitlers, was kann man eigentlich wirtschafts- und also nicht nur politisch über die Zeit, sondern auch mal über die Wirtschaft der Zeit so sagen. Dieses Buch kenne ich natürlich nicht, denn 700 Seiten, das ist abschreckend, ehrlich gesagt.
Es ist hochinteressant, sagt Ole, ich habe es jetzt hier liegen, aber noch nicht gelesen.
Genau, aber ein einständiges Gespräch, das packe ich natürlich locker in meiner halben Stunde Laufen, die ich mache und drei Punkte will ich kurz aufgreifen. Hitler hat vier Jahre lang die eigene Volkswirtschaft damit blockiert, dass er Kriegsvorbereitung getroffen hat. Das heißt, die ganze Legende, Hitler hat das alles so toll gemacht und den Menschen wieder Arbeit gegeben, nachdem die fiesen Franzosen mit dem Versailler Vertrag Deutschland eigentlich ramponiert haben. Nee, Hitler hat Deutschland ganz schön ramponiert und zwar schon vier Jahre vorm Krieg, indem er signifikante Teile, sagen wir mal 20, 30 Prozent, die zahle ich nicht mehr genau, die Adam-Tues, einfach rausgenommen hat. Also man hat eine Volkswirtschaft, man bezahlt auch die Leute, aber niemand hat was davon, dass einfach ein Panzer mehr dann auf dem Bahnhof steht, um in vier Jahren abgeholt zu werden. Also das trägt jetzt nicht zu irgendeinem Kreislaufwirtschaften bei, sondern da steht einfach Panzer.
Ja, oder zu einer Reinvestition. Also der Panzer wird dann irgendwann verschossen und dann ist gut. Also das ist keine Wirtschaft, die Wachstum produziert, sondern wirklich dann im wahrsten Sinne des Wortes Zerstörung auf Dauer.
Genau. Und da habe ich mir so gedacht, ja, diese Art der Externalisierung von völkwirtschaftlichen Kapital und vor allem auch Kapazität, die erleben wir ja gerade wieder. Wenn wir sagen, okay, die EZB stellt zwar sehr viel Geld zur Verfügung, aber was nützt das eigentlich, wenn es nicht im Kreislauf kommt, sondern einmal durch die Volkswirtschaft durchrutscht und sich am Ende als Kapitalstock bei Amazon sammelt? Was nützt es uns allen, dass Apple jetzt zwei Billionen wert ist? Das ist doch kein Erfolgskriterium für irgendwas. Also wir machen zwar keine Kriegsvorbereitung, allerdings wird hier wieder ganz schön viel Geld einfach, also wir haben keinen guten Kreislauf gerade, das kann man glaube ich sagen, hier ist ja was kaputt. Und so wie Adam Toos sich nicht zutraut, auf die Frage von Ole zu sagen, was ist denn das jetzt eigentlich, diese NS-Wirtschaft. Also er nimmt ja gar keinen, das ist jetzt Kapitalismus, es ist, so wie bei China sind wir ja auch unklar, ist das jetzt Kapital-Kommunismus oder wie auch immer, so traut er sich dieses Urteil da auch nicht zu. Und ich finde, wir sollten jetzt wieder in diesem Zustand übergehen, zu sagen, also eine Marktwirtschaft ist das gerade nicht, wo wir 2020 jetzt reinstarten, sondern das ist irgendwas anderes. Wir kommen nachher auf den Digital Services Act, wo man da mal ein bisschen auch den Markt sich mal ein bisschen anders anschaut und über Monopole auch mal neu nachdenkt. Aber das scheint mir doch so ein gewisses Gleichnis zu sein. Wir wissen nicht genau, wo wir das gerade zu tun haben. Gleichzeitig wollen wir ja gerade das Klima retten. Da kommen wir im Salon darauf zurück, denn wir hatten im Januar dieses große Klimaversprechen, European Green Deal. Und dann hatten wir im November, das haben wir hier besprochen, dass die Landwirtschaft einfach sagt, ne, da machen wir nicht mit. Wir als eigentlich größter Treiber des Klimawandels, klar, Verkehr und so spielt auch eine Rolle, aber also uns ist das eigentlich egal. Wir machen eigentlich mit. Wie gelang das eigentlich? Und da haben wir ja festgestellt, erstens ganz schön viele Subventionen. Also das ist auch keine Marktwirtschaft, sondern da geht es um 700, ne, in sieben Jahren um 500 Milliarden oder so, also wahnsinnig viel Geld. Die ganze Landwirtschaft wird eigentlich zu mehr als 50 Prozent nicht von Marktpreisen oder so durchfinanziert, sondern einfach weil es Subventionen gibt. Und wir haben eine Hyper-Idealisierung des, keine Ahnung, Hungervermeidungsgedankens oder so was. Also wir geben immer noch unfassbar viel Geld, damit Julia Klöckner uns dann sagen kann, wir wollen ja den Hunger der Welt bekämpfen. Das ist ja das Ziel unserer europäischen Landwirtschaft, dass wir den Hunger der Welt bekämpfen. Und dann fragt man sich, wo kommt denn das eigentlich her? Stellt sich raus, Adam Toos kann darüber aufklären. Ja, das ist diese Nazi-Ideologie. Man blockiert eine Volkswirtschaft darüber, dass man sehr viele Panzer herstellt. Also braucht man eine Bauernschaft, die nicht nur zum eigenen Fortkommen auf dem Markt tätig wird, sondern sie muss hyperideologisiert werden. Ohne den deutschen Bauern gibt es keine Zukunft. Und wir haben beide Ideen. Also, dass wir zum einen ganz viel staatliches Geld den Bauern geben und das bäuerliche Arbeiten selbst auch hyperidealisieren. Das haben wir immer noch. Also beide Traditionsforten sind immer noch fremd.
Ich möchte jetzt nicht glöckner vergleichen mit damals, aber es gibt eine diskursive Tradition, in der man sich befindet. Denn wenn man sich Filme aus der NS-Zeit ansieht, dann gibt es dort eine ganz starke Verklärung des Bauern. Und zwar in einer Weise, wie sie schon in den 30er Jahren überhaupt nicht mehr vorzufinden war. Also mit der Sense sah man sie dort arbeiten. Die moderne Landwirtschaft, dass da eine Industrialisierung schon stattgefunden hat, all das kommt in diesen Filmen nicht vor. Anders ist es dann bei späteren sozialistischen Filmen aus Deutschland. Also da ist man eigentlich stolz, wenn die Traktoren kommen, wenn die Industrialisierung stattfindet, wenn es, wenngleich es da auch eine Verklärung dann in anderer Weise gibt. Aber in der NS-Zeit haben wir eine Verklärung eines bäuerlichen Lebens, das es damals schon nicht mehr gibt und das es heute viel weniger gibt. Und das war ja bei dieser Pressekonferenz, über die wir gesprochen haben, so interessant, dass Julia Klöckner permanent Bilder aufruft von einem bäuerlichen Leben, das es so viel leicht nie gegeben hat, wenn dann irgendwann tief im 19. Jahrhundert.
Genau. Und das ist insbesondere dramatisch, da wir jetzt durch Corona, also in der Ansicht auch danke Corona, die Aufklärung haben, wie es auf Spargelhöfen zugeht. Wie es bei Tönnies zugeht, wie es in der ganzen Nahrungsmittelproduktion zugeht. Und das kann man nicht weiter so ideologisieren. Also hier muss man jetzt wirklich mal neu drüber nachdenken. Und dass das seinen Ursprung tatsächlich in dieser Hitlerzeit hatte, finde ich schon überraschend, weil wir haben es durchgeschleppt. Wir könnten heute auch wirklich sagen, und das haben wir damals auch besprochen, also was das damals war im November, wir können jetzt auch einfach wirklich mal sagen, Gratulation an uns alle! Wir haben es geschafft. Den Hunger, zumindest in der westlichen Welt, in der afrikanischen Welt wissen wir, da gibt es immer noch Hunger, weil wir ihn nicht beseitigen wollen. Wir brauchen diese Absatzmärkte und das ist sozusagen politisch entschieden. Aber eigentlich haben wir eine Überproduktion und eigentlich können wir uns jetzt alle gratulieren und dann so im marktischen Sinne sagen, wir haben jetzt die Stufe erreicht. Ab jetzt können wir neu darüber nachdenken. Das machen wir aber nicht, sondern wir bleiben weiter dabei. Nein, die brauchen diese Milliarden, weil wir müssen ja die Welt versorgen. Und wenn dann irgendwie auffällt, dass wir ja die Spargel-Sklaven haben und bei Tönnies irgendwelche Menschen, die für 30 Cent oder so eine Stunde am Fließband stehen und dann auf zehn Quadratmetern zu Zehnt leben, das sind halt so Nebensächlichkeiten. Die sind ja auch alle schon wieder vergessen, also wird ja nicht thematisiert. Und in deren Sicht fand ich das Ganze interessant. Und der dritte Punkt aus diesem Gespräch mit Adam Toos. Ole fragt ihn, hatten die Leute damals nicht Angst vor Überinflation? 1923, 1929, Schwarzer Freitag, alles kommt zusammen. Wir haben auch in den Filmen Erich Kessner und so weiter, diese ganzen, wie die Menschen mit der Schubkarre zu Brot kaufen gehen und das Geld hat trotzdem nicht gereicht, weil es in der Stunde, die man zum Backup braucht, schon wieder teurer geworden ist. Und dann sagt Adam Toos, so ganz nebenbei, nee, damals war eigentlich das auch große Problem, Deflation. Es ist eigentlich das Umgetrete. Und jetzt muss man wirklich 2020 jetzt überlegen, was bedeuten eigentlich Inflation und Deflation? Inflation bedeutet, Sachen werden teurer. Das kennen wir aus der Geschichte. Da kann man auch dramatisieren, weil Sachen werden teurer. Heißt, die Konsequenz ist in der sozialen Dimension einfach Armut. Menschen werden exkludiert aus dem Wirtschaftssystem rausgeschmissen und sei es die Hälfte der Gesellschaft. Also wir haben jetzt in Amerika wieder das Phänomen, dass irgendwie 10% der Leute wirklich drohen, aus ihren Häusern geschmissen zu werden. Und 50 Millionen Amerikaner sind wirklich von Hunger betroffen. Also können einfach nicht in den Laden gehen und sich was kaufen. Also wenn Sachen teurer werden, Armut und so weiter, das führt zu Exklusion, aber Deflation, also wenn der ganze Motivationskreislauf über Zinsen, also jetzt schon mal was tun, was sich erst in einem Jahr auszahlt und dafür zahlt jemand schon mal vorher, aber dafür gibt man nicht mehr Geld zurück. Wenn Deflation diesen Kreislauf zerstört, dann sprechen wir nicht von Exklusion einzelner Teile, sondern das ist einfach die Disruption des ganzen Systems, also des ganzen Prinzipes. Müssen wir wirklich überlegen, wenn wir jetzt 1, 8 Billionen innerhalb eines Jahres zur Verfügung gestellt bekommen haben und die letzten drei Monate dieses Jahres dann trotzdem Deflationstendenzen, dann wird es ganz schwer, bis zum Jahr 2029 zu kommen, ohne dass es entweder einen großen, was weiß ich, Zusammenbruch von irgendwas gibt, dass wirklich relevante Systeme nicht mehr funktionieren. Oder man könnte jetzt schon mal drüber nachdenken, wie kriegt man das in eine Debatte? Über was muss man jetzt eigentlich nachdenken? Brauchen wir wirklich ein ganz neues System irgendwie? Und beispielsweise, indem wir einfach sagen, wir geben jetzt wirklich mal jedem 25.000 Euro. Vielleicht nicht nur jedem U25, sondern einfach mal jedem Menschen in Deutschland kriegt es einfach mal 25.000 Euro. Kann man ausrechnen, so viel ist das gar nicht. Im Vergleich zu 1, 8 Millionen Euro.
Da wäre Helikoptergeld.
Helikoptergeld?
In einem hohen Maße. Also Helikoptergeld gibt es ja hin und wieder mal in den USA. Das sind aber dann wirklich kleine Schecks, 400, 600, 800 Dollar. Schecks, die es dann gibt, um das Ganze ein bisschen anzukurbeln. Bringt relativ wenig. Aber solche Beträge werden normalerweise nicht ausgezahlt als Helikoptergeld. Ist die Frage, ob sich dadurch etwas verändern würde? Ich glaube schon. Es kann natürlich auch dann tatsächlich zu kurzzeitige inflationäre Schüve geben. Aber ich glaube, das wäre bei so Einmalzahlungen nicht so groß. Also das Problem sehe ich dann eher. Wir haben das ja oder auch sehr kritisiert mal angesprochen mit dem bedingungslosen Grundeinkommen, dass da auch inflationäre Tendenzen bestehen könnten, die am Ende dafür sorgen, dass das bedingungslose Grundeinkommen gar nichts bringt, sondern alles wird ein bisschen teurer. Alle haben dann dadurch wieder etwas weniger Geld. Das ist nochmal eine andere Frage. Was du aber ansprichst, ist, glaube ich, ein ganz großes Problem, das wir nochmal begreifen müssen. Und das sagen ja auch die von dir genannten Wirtschaftswissenschaftler alle, dass wir eine große, große Nachfrageproblematik haben. Und zwar seit fast einem halben Jahrhundert. Das heißt, unsere Bedürfnisse sind sehr stark im Westen gedeckt. Es gibt keinen großen, es gibt einen Nachfragemangel. Hinzu kommt auch, dass weniger Geld da ist, also dass die Löhne nicht entsprechend gestiegen sind, dass zwar die Aktienkurse nach oben gegangen sind, die Löhne aber nicht gestiegen sind. So kann die Nachfrage gar nicht sehr viel größer werden. Und dass sich eigentlich diese westliche Wirtschaft nur deshalb so gut aufrechterhalten kann, weil es fernab zum Beispiel in Asien wachsende, stark wachsende Märkte gibt. Und wir hatten ja diesen Handelsblatt-Titel in diesem Herbst. China stützt Weltwirtschaft. Und das haben wir jetzt gerade. Das ist die einzige Volkswirtschaft, die wächst weiterhin, die jetzt durch die Corona-Krise auch sehr gut gekommen ist, die natürlich nicht ganz diese Wachstumszahlen erreichen kann, die prognostiziert waren, bevor es Corona gab. Aber wir haben damit ein ganz, ganz großes Problem, dass wir eine hohe Abhängigkeit davon haben, dass da irgendwo noch Wachstum stattfindet. Nur von diesem Wachstum profitieren dann häufig Aktienkonzerne und auch ihre Aktionäre. Denn ich gehe ja nicht selbst auch nach China jetzt arbeiten. Und ich verlagere nicht meine sonstigen Produktionen dahin, sondern wenn da eine Produktion hin verlagert wird, profitiert der Konzern als solcher davon, aber in der Regel jetzt nicht die Arbeiter hier. Und das ist etwas, was eigentlich nicht angesprochen wird, dass dieses Wachstum ohnehin sehr künstlich am Leben erhalten wird. Und dass wir jetzt immer mehr sehen, die buttern da Geld rein, Milliarde um Milliarde. Und nichts tut sich mehr, weil man das ja eigentlich glaubte, Niedrigzins, all das wird Investitionen in Gang setzen. Und wenn das nicht geschieht, dann haben wir ein ganz, ganz großes politisches Problem. Und in der Tat zeichnet sich dann noch nicht ganz klar ein neues System ab. Aber es zeichnet sich zumindest ab, dass dieses System nicht funktionieren kann. Und die Transformation ist dann auch keine Frage von politischem Willen. In dem Sinne, wird die Transformation stattfinden? Ja, sie wird stattfinden. Politisch wird es, wo man fragt, ja wie soll sie denn stattfinden am besten?
Genau, sie muss begleitet werden. Denn sag mal mal, jetzt haben wir drei Monate Deflation in Deutschland. Angenommen, das bleibt bis die nächsten zwölf Monate so. Was heißt das eigentlich? Das heißt ja am Ende, dass man mit gar keiner Geschäftsidee mehr groß auftrumpfen kann, weil wirklich jeder, der noch Geld hat, und es sind ja viele, die Geld haben, sagen, nee, mir kann ja keiner garantieren, dass irgendwie, und dann bringt man es nur noch zum deutschen Staat, kauft sich Staatsanleihen. Weil man da zumindest die Sicherheit geboten bekommt. Ja, es wird zwar weniger, was man zurückbekommt, ist ja jetzt grad schon so, aber man weiß zumindest, was man zurückbekommt. Wenn man jetzt in Investitionen macht, bei einer ohnehin niedrigen Zins- oder Negativzinslage, dann kann man sich gar nicht vorstellen, wie groß die Anstrengung des Unternehmers sein muss, um da überhaupt noch ein Plus rauszuholen. Deswegen könnte man vielleicht noch zu Amazon gehen oder zu Google, also den ganz Großen, die sozusagen über Marktschließung, Monopol-Absicherung, sich einfach ein Wachstum organisieren können, indem sie einfach den Rest zertrümmern. Und das passiert ja so auch. Oder, und deswegen wäre das so wichtig, da eine Debatte zu haben, dass sich auch Volkswirtschaftler, ich habe mal mit Süle kommen von einem halben Jahr, so ein bisschen darüber geplaudert im Fernsehpodcast. Was bedeutet es eigentlich, Volkswirtschaftler zu sein 2020? Muss man nicht einfach alles, was in Lehrbüchern steht, über den Haufen werfen oder sich sogar so daran abarbeiten, dass man wieder Neues daraus lernt. Und wenn man jetzt sagt, wir machen Helikoptergeld, die Argumente dagegen, die von euch kamen, bei Wohlstand für alle, sind ja alle richtig. Aber man könnte ja sozusagen darüber hinausgehen und sagen, wir bauen aber die Inflation da mit ein. Und mit bauen meine ich, wir programmieren sie mit ein. Also wir geben gar nicht Bargeld aus, sondern wir sagen, und daran arbeitet die EZB, das haben wir gelesen hier auch, am elektronischem Euro, der einfach verfällt. Der elektronische Euro verfällt einfach jeden Tag um ein halbes Prozent. Und umso länger du darüber nachdenkst, was du damit machst, umso weniger kannst du damit machen. Deswegen lieber nicht so viel drüber nachdenken und es einfach ausgeben. Also man gibt U25 Menschen 25.000 Euro und sagt, umso schneller du es ausgibst, umso mehrst du davon. Und in einem Jahr ist es vorbei. Der Countdown läuft. Und das wäre natürlich...
Jetzt werden uns einige Damen und Herren hier zuhören und sagen, Mensch, was reden die denn da? Wie wir sollen jetzt mehr konsumieren? Und wir haben ja dieses große, große Jahr 2020-Narrativ noch im Ohr. Wie schön, jetzt beim ersten Lockdown, jetzt besinnen wir mal wieder uns. Jetzt konsumieren wir nicht nur. Wir haben ja viel zu viel gekauft. Der Habs hat auch gesagt, das ging alles zu rasant. Und jetzt sitzen wir beide hier und sagen, ja, das wäre doch toll, wenn wir so einen Euro haben, digitalen, der auch dann noch sagt, hier, gib mich schnell aus. Morgen bin ich nur noch die Hälfte wert. Warum ist das eigentlich so? Das könnte man ja jetzt mal fragen. Man könnte ja sagen, ist doch gut, wenn wenig konsumiert wird, dann kommt ja gerne, ja, dann werden wenig Autos gekauft. Und dann wird die Umwelt besser. Und ist auch gut fürs Klima, wenn ich auch einen Anzug nochmal auftrage. Ja, das ist die eine Argumentation und die ist grundsätzlich nicht falsch. Allerdings muss man sagen, wenn man bei dieser Argumentation bleibt, bedeutet das nicht nur Wohlstandseinbußen, das ist so euphemistisch eigentlich formuliert, sondern es bedeutet Armut. Du hast es ja gerade sehr gut geschildert, was dann passiert, wenn wir solche deflationären Verhältnisse bekommen. Und das ist ja auch diese interessante Idee davon, Tuus zu sagen, wir hatten da eine Deflation und die hat auch dann Tür und Tor geöffnet für, zum Beispiel die Nazis. Investitionen sind ja folgendermaßen zu betrachten, man investiert Geld im Kapitalismus, um mehr Geld am Ende rauszuhaben, sonst brauche ich ja nichts zu investieren. Wenn ich jetzt jemanden vor mir habe, der eine Geschäftsidee hat und er sagt, er braucht 10.000 Euro und er sagt, du und Wolfgang, wenn die erfolgreich ist, dann bekommst du 10.000 Euro wieder, dann würde ich sagen, ja, dann behalte ich die doch gleich, dann gebe ich doch nichts. Wenn er mir sagt, du bekommst am Ende 11.000 Euro, würde ich sagen, okay, dann habe ich ja einen Gewinn gemacht und mehr als wenn es auf der Bank liegt oder im Kopfkissen verstaut ist. Wenn das aber nicht mehr stattfindet, dann haben wir ein deflationäres Problem bzw. noch viel größeres Problem, haben wir ein so stark systemisches Problem, dass wir nicht einfach sagen können, naja, gut, dann ist noch nichts fürs Klima getan. Das ist aber so ein bisschen wie, wenn wir alle die Luft anhalten, wäre auch mal was fürs Klima getan. Das kann nicht die Lösung sein. Also wenn wir auf diesen Postwachstumszweig gehen, es gibt auch klügere Postwachstumsansätze, wenn wir diesen Postwachstumszweig verfolgen, dann müssen wir sagen, gut, dann ruinieren wir eine Volkswirtschaft und dann können wir davon ausgehen, dass die, die jetzt so einigermaßen da stehen oder wenig haben, noch viel schlechter dastehen werden und dann wird es ein paar Gewinner geben, wie es die in jedem System immer irgendwo gibt. Aber das wäre eine ganz fatale Angelegenheit. Deswegen Konsum ist nicht grundsätzlich etwas Schlechtes und wenn Dinge produziert werden, ist das an sich eine Möglichkeit, zum Beispiel aus Armutverilendungen herauszukommen. Das zeigt im Übrigen der Blick auf China, wo genau das geschafft wurde.
China ist ein gutes Stichpunkt, denn in China versucht man, auch wenn man in diesem Jahr sehr viele Umweltauflagen locker genommen hat, versucht man ein Wachstum nachhaltig zu gestalten, um beispielsweise nicht die Städte zu verseuchen. Wir hatten es im Klimarückblick mit Lin mal thematisiert. In Neudeli sehen wir heute die Bilder von dem Smog, die wir vor zehn Jahren noch in Peking gesehen haben. Und in Peking sehen wir die jetzt nicht mehr. Sondern in Peking steigt die Lebensqualität auch dadurch, dass man da Wachstum vereint mit ein paar biologischen Ansprüchen, die man so hat. Und das ist ja der zweite große Strang in Europa. Wir hatten es ja im Frühjahr so besprochen. Der European Green Deal ist zum einen ein ökologisches Programm. Der ist aber zum anderen die Antwort auf die Suche nach der ohnehin lange ausstehenden neuen Wachstumsstrategie. So und wenn man sich jetzt überlegt, man gibt jetzt Menschen einfach mal sehr viel Geld. Also nicht nur einfach eine Lohnerhöhung von 10%, sondern jeder bekommt jetzt einfach wirklich mal 25.000 Euro oder so aufs Konto mit einem Verfallsdatum. Das ist sozusagen hypothetisches, das muss man gucken, wie man es organisiert. Aber der Konsum in Deutschland zeichnet sich eigentlich nicht dadurch aus, dass er extrem umweltschädlich ist. Menschen, die ein bisschen zu viel Geld haben, die gehen halt häufiger zum Friseur. Die gönnen sich mal eine Massage, die steigen mal in den Zug, fahren in die nächste Großstadt, erleben da irgendwas Kulturelles. Das zerstört alles nicht das Klima, führt aber zu Wirtschaftskreislauf. Denn da hängen dann Dienstleistungsarbeiten dran, die wir alle aussortiert haben gerade. Dieses stille, legende öffentliche Leben heißt keine Dienstleistung mehr. Das ist dann nur Schiffre, Friseur und so. Aber das ist es im Grunde, dieses Kleinteilige. Wir wissen, das Klima wird zerstört, wenn Superreiche, die in den Alpen leben, meinen, sie müssten auch mal in Japan Ski fahren. Die verpulmern dann 15.000 Tonnen Kerosin auf dem Weg dahin und so weiter. Das zerstört das Klima. Dieses normale, urbane, städtische Leben in einer geöffneten Gesellschaft, die nicht unter Corona-Lockdown leidet, zerstört das Klima nicht. Aber führt trotzdem zu viel Wohlstand, weil einfach sehr viele was zu tun haben, das finanziell entgolden wird, was auch so eine gewisse Wertschätzung dann mit sich bringt. Das gehört dazu. Und man fühlt sich gebraucht und aufgehoben. Man kriegt dann über die Lohnzahlung auch mal den Dank. Man könnte sich ja durchaus vorstellen. Ich weiß noch, wie das bei uns im Kindergarten war. Bei unseren Kindern im Kindergarten ist ja jetzt gerade so dieses ganze Lockdown, wo auch die ganzen Mitarbeiter dort noch mal den Eltern ins Gewissen reden. Ja, sie wissen ja schon, dass hier so ein bisschen Notbetrieb ist. Wollt ihr das Kind nicht doch lieber zu Hause behalten? Und man fühlt sich eigentlich schlecht dabei, die Kinder da abzugeben, weil man will ja auch mal was geregelt kriegen. Und sich dann nicht nur mit den Kindern rumschlagen den ganzen Tag, weil dann kriegt man gar nichts geregelt. So, und vor fünf Jahren zum Beispiel war Kindergarten in Deutschland, und das ist echt ein echter Rückbau, finde ich. Montags gehen die alle morgens schwimmen. Da ist genug Personal da, um schwimmen zu gehen. Dienstags kommt Petra nachmittags und liest drei Stunden Bücher vor. Und so, ja. Und das wurde alles aussortiert. Und es wäre so einfach und überhaupt nicht klimaschädlich, zu sagen, okay, wir sind eine Rentenpublik, wir sind wirklich sehr viele, sehr alte, sehr einsame Menschen, die auch noch arm sind und die können sich durchaus mal was dazu verdienen. Und das fänden die auch super cool, wenn sie sagen, okay, ich hab Dienstag vormittags eh nichts vor, ich begleite jetzt die Kindergruppe ins Schwimmbad. Und dann gehen da halt einfach drei Senioren, die so gerade im Renten an, also fitte Senioren, aber stimmen können. 65-Jährige, 66-Jährige, da muss man keine Angst haben, dass die es nicht hinkriegen, die Kinder dann irgendwie zu betreuen, sondern die stehen voll im Leben. Und denen kann man das einfach mal machen. Und dass man nachmittags eben nicht nur darauf hofft, dass die Oma Zeit hat vorzulesen, sondern dass man ihr einfach 15 Euro die Stunde dafür zahlt. 45 Euro die Woche, damit da jemand im Kindergarten vorliest. Das ist nun wirklich ein enormer volkswirtschaftlicher Gewinn auf allen Seiten bis hin zu, es gibt keinen größeren Bildungserfolg, als wenn man Kindern viel vorgelesen hat. Wir haben das nochmal ein bisschen erlebt.
Bei der sogenannten Flüchtlingskrise, dort waren nämlich einige ältere, zum Beispiel pensionierte Lehrer und dergleichen, plötzlich gefordert, können wir da Deutschstunden anbieten? Ich kenne auch einen Herrn aus Koblenz, der politischer Redenschreiber war, also mit der Sprache sich einigermaßen auskennt, und der pensioniert ist und der sagte dann zu mir, er hätte noch nie für so wenig Geld gearbeitet, meinte er dann, Scherzhaft, aber hatte eine große Freude daran, dies jetzt zu tun, nämlich diesen jungen Menschen die deutsche Sprache beizubringen. Das heißt, da haben wir das nochmal gehabt, und das leuchtet ja sofort ein. Und wer auch nicht klimaschädlich, genauso wie es nicht klimaschädlich ist mit der Familie, ruhig zweimal, dreimal, viermal im Jahr in den Zoo zu gehen und sonst was, man kann sich ja mal an die eigenen Familienausflüge erinnern oder an die, die man jetzt vielleicht mit den eigenen Kindern unternimmt. Wie viel klimaschädlich ist da dabei? Also die Fernreisen, die ziehen wir jetzt mal ab. Die finde ich ja, wie wir wissen, sehr unsinnig. Aber sonst können wir ja sagen, ist das ganze Jahr über doch ein sehr klimafreundliches, bedeutet spazieren gehen, bedeutet ins Kino gehen, bedeutet ruhig noch mal ein Eis, auch ein zweites Eis noch am Nachmittag und so weiter.
Genau und in deren Sicht Deflation, wir wissen alle nicht, was das ist. Ich will nur einen kleinen Clip in diesem Segment mal spielen. Vom Januar, als nämlich Christine Lagarde da saß, vielleicht haben wir im Januar noch nicht so viele zugehört. Im Januar haben wir besprochen, wie Christine Lagarde sich fragte, was ist eigentlich Inflation?
Wie gesagt, wir lassen keine Steine untern.
Also Christine Lagarde überlegt im Januar, was ist eigentlich Inflation? Wir sollten jetzt im Dezember sagen, liebe Christine Lagarde, denk auch mal drüber nach, was ist eigentlich Inflation? Zu was führt das denn eigentlich? Und was müsste man jetzt so alles an Gedanken anstrengen, denn ich glaube wir stolpern hier in ganz ganz große Probleme. Und die haben nicht nur damit zu tun, dass junge Menschen gerade im Dienstleistungsdirektor nicht das Geld erwirtschaften können, was sie dann ihren Babyboomer-Vermietern rüberwachsen lassen einmal im Monat. Das ist nur der Anfang davon, das ist sozusagen das, was jetzt als erstes auftaucht. Aber dieser ganze Kulturbetrieb und so, dieses ganze Subventionsgefüge, das muss alles mal neu überdacht werden. Wir müssen jetzt Geld zur Verfügung stellen, damit Menschen was machen können.
Na ja, sollen wir ein heiteres Thema jetzt wählen? Ich weiß gar nicht, ob es heiter ist, aber ein kulturelles Thema zumindest. Wir haben ja nicht so häufig oder fast gar nicht über Kultur gesprochen in diesem Podcast. Du tust das ja hin und wieder im Fernsehpodcast, aber wir waren doch sehr kulturarm, was sicherlich auch daran liegt, dass nicht viel stattgefunden hat. Aber ich dachte, ja. Ja, und auf die kommen wir jetzt dann auch nochmal zu sprechen. Es gab ja das literarische Quartett in den 80er Jahren begann. Es ging 14, 15 Jahre lang mit Marcel Reich-Ranicki an der Spitze. Um ihn herum saßen Helmut Karasek, Sigrid Loeffler und dann immer ein wechselnder Gast. So begann das literarische Quartett, 1988 war es und es war ein immenser Erfolg. Im ZDF wurde es gezeigt. Es war ein unglaublicher Erfolg deshalb, weil man nicht gedacht hat, dass da ein Format stattfinden kann, das 70, 75 Minuten lang dauert. Es wird in der Regel nur über fünf Bücher gesprochen und es streiten sich vier Menschen, die auch nicht sonderlich bekannt waren. Außerreich Reinitzki hatte damals schon eine gewisse Prominenz, aber Siegfried Loeffler kannte man nicht, Karassö kannte man ein bisschen, aber er war lange nicht so berühmt wie dann später. Es wurde durch das Quartett und durch RTL-Shows dann auch später. Und dann waren dort Kritiker zu Gast. Die kannte man in der Regel nur, wenn man das Företon aufmerksam rezipierte. Und dann sprachen die auch noch über Bücher, die auch die meisten Leute ja gar nicht gelesen hatten. Und oft kannten sie die Autoren auch gar nicht klar. Da waren Gras, Walzer und so weiter waren dabei. Aber es waren auch viele, viele Autoren, die man überhaupt nicht kannte in Deutschland erstmals übersetzt und und und. Und dennoch war dieses Format ein Quotenhit. Dieses Format hatte mehr als eine Million Zuschauer in der Regel. Und ich sage das alles, weil ich gar nicht weiß, wer uns jetzt hier zuhört, zuschaut und wer noch damit vertraut ist. Also ich kenne das natürlich auch nur von YouTube beziehungsweise kann mich an Kindertage erinnern, den ich dann so die letzten Ausgaben des Quartetts gesehen habe. Dann gab es noch mal einige Specials zu Schillers Geburtstag, zu Brecht Geburtstag. Aber sonst kann man sich, glaube ich, wenn man etwas jünger ist, gar nicht mehr vorstellen, was das für eine Institution war, dieses Quartett, um mal eine Stimmung davon zu bekommen. Denn das ist jetzt der große Bogen. Das Quartett gibt es noch heute in anderer Besetzung und auch sonst sehr anders. Um mal eine Stimmung davon zu bekommen, wie ging es da eigentlich zu? Hören wir jetzt hier den Großkritiker, FAZ-Literaturchef Marcel Reichraditzky. Er spricht hier über einen Roman von Martin Walzer.
Er kann viel, dieser Martin Walzer. Erzählen kann er uns verrecken nicht.
Ja, das waren Urteile, die dort oft zu vernehmen waren. Also sehr, sehr drastische Formulierungen, polemische Überspitzungen. Und alle haben sich daran sehr rege beteiligt. Wir hören jetzt in eine ebenfalls legendäre Debatte ein. Es geht da um den Günther-Grass-Roman Ein Weites Feld. Ein Roman, der sich mit Fontane und auch mit der DDR auseinandersetzt. Ein Weites Feld, das ist dieser berühmte Satz aus Effy Briest. Und ich kann sagen, wenn man sich wirklich mal quellen möchte, dann liest man diesen Roman. Und Marcel Reichraditzky hatte eine ähnliche Auffassung. Und wir hören jetzt mal eine Minute Diskussion, damit wir mal sehen, wie hoch her es dort ging.
Einen Vorschlag machen. Hängen wir doch das Buch ein bisschen niedriger.
Noch niedriger können wir es nicht hängen. Wir sagen, es ist wertlose Prose, leidweilige und unliedbar. Und Sie sagen, wir sollen es niedriger hängen.
Nein, wenn Sie das Buch vom Jahrhundertereignis etwas niedriger hängen.
Dann bleibt es ein genauso schlechtes Buch wie jetzt.
Wenn dieses Buch von Siegfried Lenz geschrieben werde oder von Stefan Haidt, dann würden Sie es dulden. Und dann würden Sie es leben lassen, dass Sie mit einer solchen Erbieterung ruiniert werden.
Ich kann etwas, was tot ist, nicht leben lassen.
Sie haben es ja tot geredet.
Nein, passen Sie mal auf. Es gibt Autoren, die mit einem ersten Buch fabelhaft angefangen haben, mit Grasse. Thomas Mann hat im Leben einen Roman wie die Buddenbrokes nicht geschrieben.
Es gibt nicht viele Autoren, die ihr ganzes Leben hindurch eine gewisse Qualität halten.
Niemand verlangt von ihm, dass er immer dieselbe Ebene hält. Aber das ist ein Buch, das total wertlos und langweilig ist. Nein, ist es nicht. Von der ersten bis zur letzten Zeile.
Ich frage mich ja immer, literarisches Quartett, wir kommen gleich auf die Sendung, du hast mir eben schon gesagt, du hast diese Bücher, die da besprochen wurden, wirklich gelesen. Die haben ja natürlich auch immer angekündigt, nächsten Monat lesen wir das und das. Da schauen ja sehr viele Leute zu, die diese Bücher nicht gelesen haben.
Nein.
Sondern die wollen einfach die Diskussionen darüber sehen. Und bei der Frage, worüber, muss man ja wie beim Fußball sagen, es geht ja eigentlich um nichts. Es sind ja erst mal nur Bücher, Geschichten, Stories, Romane, keine Sachbücher oder so, wo man sich darüber streitet, welche Schlussfolgerung ziehen wir jetzt politisch daraus, sondern es geht ja eigentlich um nichts, oder? Kann man das so sagen, oder wäre das jetzt zu hart?
Es geht um alles, denn es geht um die Literatur. Und das war das großartige Anmaße Reich-Ranitzky. Er lebte für die Literatur. Ich empfehle jedem seine Autobiografie, mein Leben. Er war ein Mann, für den es nichts Wichtigeres gab als Literatur und der auch genau bei solchen Fernsehsendungen oder auch bei Auftritte, ich habe ihn bei der Frankfurter Buchmesse zweimal erlebt, einem sofort vermitteln könnte, es gibt nichts Wichtigeres als Literatur. Entscheidend ist der neue Roman von Gras oder Walser oder Philip Ross. Das ist das Wichtigste. Alles andere ist Makulatur. Und das ist toll, dass diese Stimmung sich sofort herstellt dort. Und er, auch weil er so sehr für die Literatur brennt, so oft von ihr enttäuscht wird, wie der nächste kleine Clip zeigt.
Die meisten Bücher, die wir im Quartett hier besprochen haben, im Laufe der beinahe 14 Jahre, habe ich von der ersten bis zur letzten Zeile gelesen. In den meisten Fällen war es eine Qual.
Ja, so ging es mir bei den meisten der Bücher, die ich jetzt für dieses neue Quartett gelesen habe auch. Um aber noch mal zu zeigen, wie wichtig diese Sendung auch war als Institution, möchte ich einen Ausschnitt zeigen, darauf hattest du mich hingewiesen, nämlich von Harald Schmidt. Harald Schmidt hat dann Folgendes gemacht bei einer Ausgabe des literarischen Quartetts. Ich glaube, das war Anfang 2000, dass er vorher auch die Bücher alle las, die dort besprochen wurden, hat sich dann ein paar Leute dahin gesetzt, hat sich selbst auf einen Schreibtisch gesetzt, um sich auch so als Platzverdränger zu inszenieren, also als Marcel Reich-Ranitzky, und hat dann wirklich parodistisch eine ganze Sendung gemacht. Das literarische Quartett, die besprechen einfach mal alle Bücher und hier mal einen Ausschnitt, denn man weiß immer, wenn man parodiert wird, dann hat man es geschafft. Und Marcel Reich-Ranitzky hat es natürlich geschafft.
Das nächste Buch ist von Don DeLillo, heißt Körperzeit, erschienen bei Kippen, Heuer und Witsch, glänzend gemacht beim Frühstück. Die Beobachtung, wie sie die Sojakörner holt, wie sie den Kaffee, wie er überhaupt nicht nur hinhört, sondern auch was ganz anderes antwortet, als sie gefragt hat. Die Beobachtung, wie er die Feige zerteilt, und es ist klar, dass man sofort Vagina assoziiert.
Also ich fand diese Sendung damals sensationell, denn zum einen stellt er sich ja dem Anspruch, ich greife hier vorweg, was der echte MRR dann dazu sagen wird. Zweitens hat er sich halt diese Stimme da von ihm ausgeliehen. Und drittens macht er nur monolog in dieser Sendung. Er lässt ja die anderen gar nicht zu Wort kommen, sondern er sitzt auf diesem Schreibtisch, Platzverdränger ist genau der richtige Begriff, und macht nur monolog. Und ich habe mich damals schon gefragt, weil mein Vater meinte auch so, ja, irgendwie bedeutet das ja, dass das halt schon gelingt als Harald Schmidt-Show. Vielleicht, klar, Literatur bedeutet alles, und damit ist es nicht weit weg vom Nichts. Also wenn man es zu übertreibt, dann ist es halt auch gleich... Und es gibt halt auch Menschen, die so über Fußball reden. Für die ist Fußball einfach alles. Und es ist einmal die Woche, und dann geht man dahin, ja, man hat dann aber ein schlechtes Spiel gesehen. Es gibt nur ganz wenige sehr gute Spiele, sehr viele sehr schlechte Spiele. Aber am Ende müssen halt drei gute Spiele in der Saison reichen dann aus, um irgendwie und so, wenn es drauf ankommt. Und so ist das ja auch bei dieser literarischen Aufarbeitung auch. Und das Literarischquartett hat es eben... Also dadurch, dass es im Fernsehen stattfindet, oder stattfand, vielleicht beerdigen wir es ja heute auch, ist das so die Verschränkung ins Unterhaltssame. Also wir wollen, so wie Harald Schmidt schon, den Unterhaltungskern gut rausgeschält hat von Marcel Reich-Ranitzky. Und den dann präsentieren kann, unabhängig von der Person, ist das schon... also ich finde es schon faszinierend, welche Nähe einfach zwischen Fußballer und Literatur dann doch hier ist. Was die Beschäftigung damit angeht, die Zeitdauer, dann so dieses, wir machen es aber gesellig. Klar, jeder liest für sich, jeder guckt das Spiel für sich, aber am Ende gibt es halt dieses gesellige Einander-Abgleichen, was man dabei fühlte. Und dann gibt es da unterschiedliche Gefühle und so. Dann trifft das so auseinander. Und dann vielleicht sogar Fanlager, das haben wir eben auch schon gehört. Das ist da so, also finde ich schon ganz witzig eigentlich.
Und bei Reich Ranicki war es ja auch so, dass er sich als Lehrmeister und als Entertainer gleichermaßen verstand. Und das war das Entscheidende, dass er jetzt nicht nur die Klamauk-Figur war. Und sicherlich war er da mitunter auch in irgendwelchen Unterhaltungsformaten, weil man den als witzig fand, wie er so sprach. Aber er war eben auch jemand, der extrem viel Ahnung hatte, zumindest von der klassischen Literatur. Wie wir gleich noch mal sehen werden, mit der sehr modernen Literatur konnte er dann wenig anfangen. Und wir hören nur jetzt mal gerade noch an, wie diese Sendung in der Regel endete oder immer endete von Reich Ranecki.
Wir haben wieder einmal nichts geklärt. Aber es war ja nicht unsere Absicht, etwas zu klären. Wir können nur abschließen mit dem Wort von Brecht aus dem Sechuan-Drama. Und also sehen wir betroffen, den Vorhang zu und alle Fragen offen.
Sehr schöner Abschluss. Also nicht diese lustige Schlussrunde bei Plasberg. Hat aber Ferien, jetzt kann jeder noch mal was sagen. Sondern man riecht ab und sagt, wir kommen da auch nicht zum Ende.
Plasberg ist ja immer ganz albern. Mit wem würden Sie denn in den Urlaub fahren? Und dann soll jeder eine Runde das noch mal sagen. Und so dieses ganz sozial verschränkte und eben nicht alle Fragen offen, sondern wenigstens eine Frage beantworten wir jetzt noch mal.
Und jetzt kommen wir zu einer Geschichte des Verfalls, die ich jetzt hier erzählen möchte. Wir hören jetzt rein in das literarische Quartett, das wieder dann zum Leben erweckt wurde. Übrigens hatte man kurz an Harald Schmidt gedacht, der hatte aber abgelehnt. Von Volker Weidemann, der hat das dann damals geleitet. Christine Westermann, die aber mehr so als empathische Leserin dort saß, die gerne Bücher liest und ein bisschen redet. Und hin und wieder muss man sagen, Christine, halt doch bitte mal das Buch richtig rum. Aber es war jetzt nicht literarisch auf irgendeinem entsprechenden Niveau. Dann saß dort anfangs Maxim Biller, der sich ein bisschen so in der Reich-Ranicki-Rolle einfinden wollte. Was ihm aber fehlte, war genau das eine, nämlich Entertainment. Und er konnte überhaupt nicht was humorvoll artikulieren. Zudem hat er auch merkwürdige Ansichten dort zur Literatur vertreten. Also er hasste, das ist ja so auch in seiner Literatur, immer wieder kommt das raus, Thomas Mann. Und dann muss er das auch jederzeit wieder deutlich machen, wie schlecht eigentlich Thomas Mann ist. Und naja, gut, er war, glaube ich, auch nicht so eine tolle Besetzung. Er hat aber wenigstens eine gewisse Aggressivität reingeschafft. Dann hat man ihn irgendwann ausgetauscht, er ist gegangen. Und dann kam Thea Dorn und dann hatte man auch immer wieder einen ständigen Gast. Aber der hatte auch nichts mit Literatur zu tun, also kein Literaturkritiker. Zum Beispiel saß dort Habeck und wir hören uns jetzt einfach nur mal die Schlussminute dieser Sendung an, weil wir haben jetzt gerade das noch im Ohr. Also sehen wir betroffen, den Vorhang zu und alle Fragen offen. Und jetzt hören wir mal, wie so eine Sendung beendet wird, beziehungsweise man muss eigentlich sagen, so ausfaded, aussubbt.
Leute, das ist das Zeichen, das ist das Zeichen, wir kommen zu den... Ach so, Fußball hier, Herr Habeck, ist natürlich Handballergebnis. Müssen wir sagen, dann machen wir so 40 zu 30 oder so. Sie sind Handballfan mehr als Fußball, ne?
Ich komme aus der Stadt des Deutschen Meisters, würde ich sagen.
Michelle Wellback, wie darf ich Sie eigentlich da deuten?
Sie dürfen mich mit einem 40, also wenn wir Handball machen.
Das verstehe ich jetzt nicht. Also dann nehmen wir ein schönes 2 zu 2. Yana Gihara, 3 zu 1. Gabriele Target, 3 zu 1.
Nein, da bin ich, weil ich Museen schätze, war 3 zu 1 gegen Sie oder für Sie? Ich bin dagegen.
Haben wir's.
Und die Cebolda hat jetzt auch nichts mehr rausgerissen. 1 zu 3.
Ich sag doch, das liegt irgendwie da. Wenn man es gut hin...
Aber wie darüber gesprochen wird, also es ist ja schon formal eine Katastrophe und inhaltlich war es dann auch, Sie haben dann über Wayback gesprochen, das will ich jetzt niemandem antun, da irgendwelche Clips draus zu zeigen, deswegen springen wir in die aktuelle Sendung.
Lass mich noch ein Wort zu Volker Weidemann sagen, der war ja damals in der FAZ, als ich auch da war, ist dann zum Spiegel gewechselt, hat dann dieses Angebot angenommen, das da zu machen.
Du darfst nur was zu ihm sagen, wenn du was Schlechtes über ihn sagst.
Ich fand Volker Weidemann gefällt sich einfach selber vor einer Kamera, der sieht sich da einfach gerne und der hat dann seine wilden Haare, weil er ist ja auch so ein bisschen Denker, intellektuell, hat man natürlich ganz wilde Haare und seine Gesichtsfalten, glaubt er, sind total kameraaffin irgendwie. Und dann hat er dieses Literarische Quartett irgendwie so moderiert, also so gegenstandslos, muss man einfach sagen irgendwie. Er selber wollte so der Gegenstand sein. Und er macht ja jetzt beim Spiegel auch so eine Literatursendung.
Auch ganz gräßlich.
Wo er es genauso weitermacht und das verstehe ich einfach nicht, warum man sich nicht wirklich mal, ich meine, diese Christine, wie heißt sie nochmal? Westermann. Die finde ich ja wirklich schlimm, weil die sitzt ja vor der Fernsehkamera.
Die war aber einfach in dem Format falsch. Also sie kann ja, ihr eigenes Format, was sie hatte mit Kurtz-Alzmann, war ja okay.
Ja, weil Kurtz-Alzmann halt da war und klare Urteile gesprochen hat und Meinung und klar moderiert und sie stand dann immer so daneben und hat das alles wieder eingefangen mit ihrer ganzen Empathie und hier und da und so. Und ich habe sie jetzt kürzlich in so einem Podcast gehört, Matzes Hotel, wo sie dann irgendwie immer, das verstehe ich dann auch nicht, warum die Podcastlandschaft immer so einauf. Ja, sie war schon überall als Gast, aber bei uns öffnet sie sich heute mal richtig und so. Und da hat sie dann so darüber erzählt, wie sie so auf Selbstfindungstrip ist und so, wo ich mir nur gedacht habe, ja, ich meine, du verdienst so viel Geld im Fernsehen, du kannst dir das erlauben, einfach mal dieses Justin Bieber Ding. Klar, also du kannst es dir erlauben, einfach mal hier in so ein Selbstfindungsding irgendwie reinzugehen und daraus dein Weltbild zu stricken. Das ist aber völlig unangemessen und auch ein bisschen unanständig, das so nach außen zu tragen. Und dann hat er auch für mich das alles Sinn gemacht, dieses ganze Literatschquartett mit ihr, weil sie immer so dieses, ich bin hier die Gute, ich bin hier die Vorsichtige, ich bin hier die Empathische, ich pisse hier niemanden ans Bein oder so. Obwohl genau der Wunsch war, so wie Reichrand Nitschke da ranzugehen und sagen, ich habe einen Holocaust überlebt und jetzt liegt mir immer so ein scheiß Buch vor und jetzt kommt mir immer mein Urteil. Und das wollte man eigentlich genau so sehen und wir sehen ja, wie sehr so.
Und dann auch eine Sigrid Löffler, das haben wir jetzt gar nicht gebracht, aber Sigrid Löffler konnte da ja auch ordentlich kontern und hat dann gesagt, also man muss mal über ihre literarischen Kriterien sprechen und schauen sie mal, was die Österreicher dann und dann geschrieben haben. Also die kannte sich natürlich auch bestens aus, vielleicht sogar noch ein bisschen besser als reich René Tietz. Und wir haben dann bei Christine Westermann halt so einen Gefühls-Sprech. Es gibt einen sehr schönen Ausschnitt, ich weiß gerade nicht welche Harald-Schmidt-Sendung, eine der späteren, da sagt er dann, ja, manchmal ist es ja auch schön, wenn man mal so aussteigen will und dann geht man zum Beispiel ins Kloster, wie Christine Westermann und bringt ein Kamerateam mit, das ist dann sehr entspannt. Also das hat sie wohl auch für den WDR dann mal so gemacht.
Genau, die hat sich ja sehr gezorft, da war sie auch einmal sehr getroffen. Davon hat sie über Jahre noch erzählt, wie es getroffen ist, wie sie von einem Harald-Schmidt-Witz war. Aber ja, solche Leute wie Christine Westermann brauche ich in den Medien nicht. Und ich finde es schade, dass es Deutschland...
Aber Volker Weidemann noch viel weniger.
Noch viel weniger.
Volker Weidemanns Literaturverständnis ist so ein bisschen Pop-Literatur, so ein bisschen Zwanziger Jahre, aber bitte nicht die bösen Autoren, sondern eher so Irmgard Coyne und sowas, was keine schlechte Autorin ist. Aber das ist alles doch sehr mau. Und wenn man sich jetzt das neue Quartett ansieht, geleitet von Thea Dorn, dann wird das nicht besser. Man muss hinzufügen, diese neuen Quartette sind nicht mehr so lang. Die dauern nur noch 45, 50 Minuten. Trotzdem wird über vier Bücher gesprochen. Trotzdem empfiehlt am Ende sogar noch mal jeder Gast extra ein Buch. Also da gehen noch mal Minuten ab. Dann wird jedes Buch anfangs schon mal von Theatoren kurz vorgestellt. Dann werden die Gäste länger vorgestellt als früher. Das war bei Reich Ranicki auch anders. Der begrüßte auch noch nicht mal das Publikum. Dafür war ja keine Zeit, sondern die Musik verklang. Und Reich Ranicki sagte, am literarischen Quartett nehmen Teil wie üblich. Helmut Karasek. Und dann ging es los. Man hat keine Zeit vergeudet. Das ist jetzt vollkommen anders. Jetzt gab es allerdings einen Skandal um dieses Quartett. Sonst hätte man fast vergessen, dass es das überhaupt noch gibt, dass es noch gesendet wird. Lisa Eckhardt war zu Gast. Geht das? Man hat doch diese Witze im Ohr noch oder diese Debatte darum, antisemitische Witze gemacht. Kann sie jetzt da quasi an der Stelle sitzen, an der Marcel Reich Ranicki saß, der den Holocaust überlebt hat. Maxim Biller hat dann einen sehr drastischen Text wohl verfasst in der Süddeutschen. Ich habe ihn nicht gelesen. Ich muss sagen, das ist mir so ein Berliner Geklüngel. Dann ist man sich irgendwie bei Borzac grad um eins über Lisa Eckhardt und wahrscheinlich sagte einer, gut, dann schreib ich einen Pro bei der Welt. Ich ruf mal den Ulf an und dann sagt der Biller, ich schreib mal was dagegen in der Süddeutschen. Also man einigt sich da unter sich. Da hab ich eigentlich gar keine Lust, mich darauf einzulassen. Hab auch den Text von Weidermann dazu, der sich dann auch jetzt nochmal einmischt und nur überflogen. Also es soll jetzt hier nicht darum gehen, dass man Lisa Eckhardt ins Quartett einladen. Das interessiert mich tatsächlich nicht so. Im Gegenteil, ich werd jetzt gleich auch leider sagen müssen, dass Lisa Eckhardt im Vergleich, was jetzt vielleicht noch nicht so schwer ist, aber im Vergleich zu den anderen noch eine relativ gute Figur macht.
Zu dieser Lisa Eckhardt Kontroverse hat ja Volker Weidermann, wie du eben sagtest, im Spiegel. Ich hab den Text nicht gelesen, nicht ein Wort, nicht mehr überflogen. Aber die Überschrift lautet, nicht in seiner Sendung. Und da, finde ich, steckt so eine Anwaltschaft drin, dass Volker Weidermann jetzt für Martin Reich Raditzky dies literarische Quartett, das er selber so in den Sand gesetzt hat, verteidigt, die ich auch schon wieder scheiße finde. Also das ist wirklich rundum wirklich verbrannte Erde, die wir hier gerade begutachten. Das ist ganz schlimm.
Ja, also wenn irgendjemand nicht die Tradition fortgesetzt hat von Reich Raditzky, dann war es Volker Weidermann. Das kann man wohl festhalten. So, ich habe diese vier Bücher gelesen, die dort besprochen wurden. Es war auch eine Qual. Das kann ich für vieles sagen, aber vereine es zumindest nicht. Und darum geht es gleich am Anfang. Das hat Lisa Eckhardt mitgebracht. Der Essay-Band von Michelle Welbeck, ein bisschen schlechter. Grandiose Essays zu empfehlen, allerdings jetzt nur für Leute, die schon mit dem ein oder anderen Welbeck Roman vertraut sind. Und sie sprechen jetzt darüber. Und hier findet ein bisschen Debatte statt. Aber wir merken jetzt gleich an der Stimmung, es ist schon sehr anders.
Es hebt an mit einer Apologie des Konservatismus, also gegen diesen zwangsneurotischen Wandel. Er lässt auch Corona einfließen, wie er so schön sagt. Virus ohne Eigenschaften, was die onanistische Vereinzelung unserer Gesellschaft, die er ja auch oft behandelt, nur vorantreiben wird. Man hat hier einen Künstler, der hat ein tiefes moralisches Bewusstsein und keinerlei Lust zu moralisieren. Das meine ich, ist was sehr Extraordinäres heutzutage, wo es sich bei Künstlern meist umgekehrt verhält.
Das finde ich ehrlich gesagt sehr gut, denn sie nimmt sich hier einfach ihre eigene Haltung, die sie gut findet, schiebt sie ihm unter und verkauft ihn dann so als, der Typ steht an meiner Seite.
Das macht sie durchsehend.
Genau, wir haben das Urteil von uns ja klar gemacht, als wir es besprochen haben, sie findet eben an der Ästhetik Hitler so viel überzeugend, dass sie die Inhalte von Hitler egal sind. Und das ist zu kritisieren, deswegen sollte sie nicht so viel über Hitler reden. Aber wenn man das mal abschließt als Punkt, ohne dass man es abschließen kann, weil klar, das schleppt sie jetzt auch als ihre eigene Geschichte mit in diese Sendung rein. Aber wenn man jetzt die Sendung mal so an sich so betrachtet, fand ich diese 30 Sekunden sehr gut.
Ja, sehr interessant und wir behalten uns im Hinterkopf. Onanie wurde angesprochen, kommen wir ganz spät nochmal drauf. Wir hören jetzt mal weiter.
Ansonsten, wer Orwell kennt und schätzt als diesen dandy-esken Diogenes, der findet ihn hier auch wieder. Also er schimpft auf den Individualismus, den Liberalismus, natürlich auf das Rauchverbot. Aber ich glaube, interessant ist das Buch vor allem für jene, denen seine Romane immer ein bisschen zu nihilistisch, zu düster und vielleicht zu pervers waren, weil die begegnen hier einem geradezu romantischen Tierliebhaber, der bei Schubert laut weint.
Und da hat sie vollkommen recht. Wir sehen, wir erleben, well back, von einer anderen Seite nochmal jemand, der sagt, die Menschenwürde ist auch mit aller Gewalt, mit allen Mitteln zu verteidigen. Es kann nicht sein, dass jemand, der schwer krank ist, dann vom Staat getötet wird. Da gibt es einen großen Essay dazu drin. Wir haben wirklich ganz grandiose Texte, aber wir haben eben nicht nur Lisa Eckert im Quartett sitzen, sondern dort saß auch die Tennisspielerin Andrea Petkovic, die nun auch einen Roman verfasst hat. Und da würde ich mal sagen, ach nee, da kommen wir noch gar nicht zu. Wir hören erstmal Ulrich Mathes. Also Ulrich Mathes ist auch da. Wir wissen auch keinen Literaturkritiker, hatte aber große Bedenken bei diesem well back. Den hören wir jetzt mal zuerst.
Ich bin ein begeisterter, ein freudiger Leser der Romane von well back, selbst wenn ich manchmal mit den Zähnen knirschen muss. Bei diesem Essay-Bank ging mir das anders. Ich habe im Laufe der Lektüre zunehmend, sagen wir mal, die Lust daran verloren zu entschlüsseln, handelt es sich bei dieser oder jener Äußerung um eine ironische Bemerkung, ist es eine Provokation, ist es seine Privatmoral, ist es der Gesellschaftsklauen und vor allem ist es noch konservativ oder ist es schon reaktionär. Und ich habe mich bei manchen seiner Äußerung tatsächlich dafür entschlossen, es für Letzteres zu halten.
Uiuiui, da hat jemand Angst vor böser Literatur, würde ich sagen, und auch vor Ambivalenz.
Ja, aber da würde ich sagen, da wird doch Uiui Berg, sofern er Deutsch versteht, da sitzen und denken, oh, endlich hat das mal so funktioniert, wie ich das wollte. Da ist jemand völlig durch den Wind.
Und wir hören mal weiter, was er zu sagen hat.
Ich möchte nur ein paar wenige Punkte zitieren. Er plädiert für die Abschaffung des Parlaments zugunsten einer einheitlichen Direktdemokratie. Er lobt die Staatsform der Monarchie. Er findet, dass eine ziemlich harmonische Sphäre, er sagt, die Stände würden so schön übereinander wachen, angefangen mit dem Papst, der über die Könige wacht und so weiter, immer weiter nach unten. Er unterscheidet nicht zwischen Islam und Islamismus. Er sagt, er spüre die Verpflichtung, die Islamophobie zu verteidigen, ob er nun selber Islamophob sei oder nicht. Man habe das Recht, grundsätzlich eine Religion anzugreifen. Er tadelt den Papst für seine Kritik am Rechtsaußen, Ex-Premier Salvini, und er hält Trump für einen der besten Präsidenten, die Amerika hier hatte.
Das waren jetzt die ganzen vielen bösen, vermeintlich bösen Punkte bei Webeck. Und ja, es gibt da diesen großartigen Essay, warum Trump der allerbeste Präsident ist. Und das ist aber ein sehr schönes Gedankenspiel, das er da hat. Er sagt, das ist doch eigentlich jetzt toll, wenn, man muss sagen, das ist ja schon zwei Jahre alt, dieser Text, wenn Trump sich doch so ganz isolationistisch geben würde, wenn sich jetzt also Amerika ganz aus der Weltpolitik zurückzieht, und China war ja auch nie an großer Weltpolitik interessiert, dann sind wir alle wieder so für uns. Und liebe Amerikaner, ihr seid natürlich bei uns in Frankreich immer herzlich willkommen als Touristen. Und das ist eben ein Spiel, das man nur in der Form des Essays, des literarischen Essays machen kann. Das kann man nicht in einer politischen Talkshow sagen. Dann steht man irgendwo, glaube ich, am falschen Ende. Aber gerade hier beginnt Literatur, und das haben ja gerade französische Schriftsteller immer sehr schön beherrscht, dass sie dort in der Literatur einen Freiraum sich schaffen, in dem auch alles gedacht werden darf. Und wir erleben jetzt hier eigentlich so einen, man muss es dann vielleicht doch so sagen, linksliberalen Diskurs, der sagt, mir ist das aber jetzt alles ein bisschen zu gefährlich, was hier angesprochen wird. Ja, dann kann man auch nicht Marquis de Sade oder so lesen.
Ja, vor allem, warum befasst man sich mit Literatur, wenn man die Funktion der Literatur dann so missachtet einfach in dem Moment. Ja, wenn man nur auf die Signalworte im Text geht und sagt, da findet jemand Trump gut, das geht aber nicht. Weil es könnte ja auch sein, dass er selber Vorbehalte hat mit, er kann das Experiment, das iterarische Experiment von Holbeck jetzt nicht ganz skutieren, weil das könnte ja passieren, dass jemand ihn in der Sendung falsch versteht. Dass er deswegen einfach nur nochmal den Flock einschlägt, ne, Trump ist böse.
Ja, jetzt äußert sich Andrea Petkovic, die Tennisspielerin, die jetzt auch einen Roman geschrieben hat dazu, warum sie da sitzt, weiß ich nicht so genau und ich glaube, man würde es auch nach den Clips nicht unbedingt sagen können.
Und ich hatte das Gefühl, ganz ehrlich, am liebsten würde er einfach den ganzen Tag in seinem Zimmer sitzen, lesen und schreiben, sich vielleicht einmal in zwei Wochen mit jemanden treffen auf dem Weinchen. Und das Einzige, was ich nicht verstehe, warum müssen wir alle dabei mitmachen? Dann soll er das doch machen. Und ich hatte manchmal das Gefühl, er kommt nicht darauf klar, dass die Welt sich weiter dreht.
Also ich finde es nicht verkehrt, dass man einen offenen Stuhl für alle hat und dann sozusagen fast nach Losverfahren auswählt, wer man da hat, dass man hier wieder nach Prominenz geht. Klar, man hätte jetzt auch wirklich keine Ahnung.
Ja, aber man hätte ja auch jetzt jemanden nehmen können, der auch so ein Buch lesen und rezipieren und wiedergeben kann und vielleicht sich auch noch in originellen Gedanken dazu macht.
Genau, würde ich jetzt zu dem Ausschnitt auch sagen. Wird noch besser, sage ich dir. Also Literatur ist immer ein Angebot. Man kann auch zurückfragen jetzt an sie, ja, wieso hast du es denn dann gelesen? Weil es Auftrag war, das in der Sendung zu lesen oder was? Weil dafür haben wir ja genug Bücher eigentlich, dass man dann einfach sagt, wenn ich nicht ganz verstehe, warum der Autor mir das hingeschrieben hat, dann muss ich mir nicht rechtfertigen, warum ich das jetzt lese und dann lese ich halt was anderes. Also in deren Sicht...
Wir hören Theodor.
Er hat zum Beispiel, das ist der letzte Text, der in diesem Band versammelt ist, einen Fall, der in Frankreich und nicht nur in Frankreich für extreme Aufmerksamkeit sorgte, Vincent Lambert, die Geschichte eines Krankenpflegers, der nach einem Unfall ins Wachkoma fiel und wo jahrelang ein wüstes Ringen zwischen Angehörigen, dem Staat, dem Krankenhaus stattfand, ob man den weiter künstlich ernährt oder sterben lässt. Da hält Uel Beck ein flammendes Plädoyer dafür, das behindertes Leben um jeden Preis, wenn es denn aus sich heraus noch leben will, was bei diesem Lambert der Fall war, es um jeden Preis am Leben zu halten. Auch in seinem Trump-Aufsatz, der natürlich erst mal als Provokation ganz klar angelegt ist. Ein Artikel, der heißt, der Mann ist ein guter Präsident, der will provozieren. Was bringt der als Erstes? Er sagt, das Dolle an Trump ist, dass er aufhört, dass er die Obama-Außenpolitik verlängert, dass er aufhört, den Rest der Welt mit Kriegen in demokratischer Absicht zu überziehen. Das heißt, ich glaube auch, Herr Mattes, Sie gehen dem Uel Beck gewissermaßen auf den Leim, indem Sie sagen, ich stelle jetzt den bösen Uel Beck in die Vitrine?
Na, sehr gut.
Ich habe auf eines verzichtet, sie hatte so einen kleinen Liebesbrief verfasst an Marcel Reichranitzky in diesem Jahr. Reichranitzky hatte ein Jubiläum und dann saß sie dort auf diesem Sofa und hat gesagt, lieber Herr Reichranitzky, jetzt gucken Sie uns zu vielleicht und hat dann irgendwas da zitiert. Das war so kreislich, dass ich es hier weggelassen habe. Jetzt würde ich sagen, springen wir ein ganz kleines bisschen, um es nicht zu lang zu machen und gehen nochmal zu dem Ausschnitt 175. Petkovic äußert da nochmal so eine ganz typische Phrase, die man in vielen Literatursendungen hören kann.
Dieses Hin und Her gerissen werden, das mag ich bei Büchern eigentlich.
Ja, du nicht, dieses Hin und Her gerissen werden. Ja, Lisa Eckert hat dann zuvor nochmal eingebracht, dass ich will dazu sagen, ich werde nicht so gerne hin und her gerissen.
Ich lese sehr gern mein, also ich lese nicht gerne vor, weil mir das einfach motorisch Schmerzen bereitet nach einer Weile, aber ich lese sehr gerne meinen Kindern Harry Potter vor, weil das einfach eine straighte Geschichte ist, die geht von A nach B, da wird man nicht hin und her gerissen. Klar, es gibt eine tolle Pointe mit Snape und so am Ende, aber ich will nicht hin und her gerissen werden, deswegen mache ich auch Sachbücher, die von einem Autor geschrieben sind, der mir seine Sachlage darlegt, und dann kann ich ja noch die Gegensache, aber ich will dieses Integrierte und jetzt verwirre ich mal alle und mach das hier so.
Möchtest du also nicht den Nouveau-Romand haben, aber da bist du sehr nah bei Wollbeck, denn Wollbeck lehnt ja den experimentellen Roman auch ab und sagt, man soll sowieso nicht mit Form experimentieren, das erklärt er hier auch noch mal, so alle 100 Jahre würde mal formal was Neues passieren und das sei dann auch interessant, aber sonst soll man eher mal linear erzählen lernen. Das sollte man sich vielleicht doch ein bisschen auf die Fahnen schreiben, gerade auch unsere deutschen Autoren in ihren Schreibschulen, die jetzt sagen, ich revolutioniere mal schnell was und dann geht meistens schief.
Umso mehr man sich der Form verpflichtet fühlt, umso mehr kann man inhaltlich spielen. Deswegen ist Faust einfach mal das beste deutsche Buch, das jemals geschrieben wurde. Weil das ist in der Form einfach immer klar, da weiß man genau, noch zwei Zeilen und es reimt sich wieder, noch zwei Zeilen und es reimt sich wieder, noch zwei Zeilen und es reimt sich wieder.
Also Faust war jetzt ein sehr schlechtes Beispiel, weil es so eine sehr offene Form hat. Also es gibt geschlossene Dramen und es gibt geschlossene Formen. Ich gehe ja auf Taurus oder so vielleicht eher. Also Faust hat gerade der zweite Teil auch inszenatorische Schwierigkeiten, die sich aus dieser Offenheit ergeben. Aber gut, wir gehen noch mal ganz kurz zurück zu Eckhard und Nietzsche, denn du hast es natürlich schon sofort erkannt. Eckhard will ihr Programm, ihr Kabarettprogramm natürlich unterbringen und tut das dann auch hier.
Ich meine aber, dass das bei Wellback bei manchen Lesern dann schon eine falsche Herangehensweise ist, wenn sie mit so einem großen Masochismus dieses Buch öffnen und gepiept werden wollen. Ich meine, dass er das nie... Ach so, ja gut, aber eben manchen, nein, ich meine, dass man den Skandal erwartet. Ich habe es auch in keiner Weise als skandalös empfunden, also was sie dann vielleicht sogar langweilig empfinden. Das für mich das Skandalöseste war, dass er sich mehrmals gegen Nietzsche versündigt, was ich meine, ist absolut nicht notwendig. Also er nimmt ihm übel, dass er sich als den Antichrist aufspielt, wobei Wellback sich selbst an einer Stelle in die Nähe von Christus selbst drückt. Er leckt am Unglück der Gesellschaft und nimmt da quasi das Übel auf sich.
Ja, was wir hier noch mal deutlich sehen, Eckhardt möchte sich in so eine Nietzsche über Menschen Ikone hineinbewegen. Das ist ja auch die ganze Inszenierung. Und deswegen stellt sie noch mehrmals dann heraus, wie wichtig hier eigentlich Nietzsche ist, dass Wellback das nicht richtig verstanden hat. Ich glaube, dass wir hier ein Problem haben, dass sie Wellback dann nicht ganz versteht. Aber es ist interessant, dass sie nochmal quasi sich als Künstlerin erklärt. Genau.
Und ihren Vorwurf an den Mattes finde ich eigentlich ganz gut. Sie lesen doch auch nur Twitter, weil sie von Ulf Poschert mal wieder gepeitscht werden wollen. Und so lesen wir alle Twitter. Wir warten auf den nächsten Ulf Poschert Tweet, über den wir uns dann aufregen können, weil er uns mal wieder gepeitscht hat. Und das hat sie ganz gut transferiert. Weil so hat der Mattes das vorher auch gemacht, muss man ganz klar sagen, diese Wellback-Kritik.
Jetzt, was ist denn damit gemeint? Der stellt sich als Christus dar. Vielleicht kann Petkovic uns dann nochmal Aufschluss geben.
Weil er sagt etwas sehr Wahres. Als Schriftsteller ist man irgendwie auch dazu da, um alles Negative zu nehmen und dann wieder nach außen zu tragen und der Welt zu präsentieren. Und er kann aber da nicht aufhören, sondern er muss sich im nächsten Satz direkt mit Jesus Christus vergleichen. Und ich glaube, das fasst Ulf Beck ganz gut zusammen, dass er wahre Sachen sagt, pointierte Sachen sagt, witzige Sachen sagt und dann aber noch mal kurz ausschlagen muss. Und vielleicht, sie hat er verfehlt, Herr Mattes, aber ich glaube, er will schon manchmal so einen kleinen Kinnhaken mitgeben, damit die Leute, ich weiß nicht, ob er immer nachprüfen will, ob wir noch wach sind, während wir lesen.
Nee, das will er überhaupt nicht. Sie ist da einfach nicht im Bilde, was Ulf Beck machen will. Er will tatsächlich so eine Genealogie herstellen zwischen dem Schriftsteller heute, der alles auf sich nimmt und Jesus Christus und das ist auch das große Thema aus Serotonin. Auch am Ende haben wir dann noch mal so eine Christusgestalt, die einfach aufplätzt. Und das ist jetzt gerade mal keine Provokation von Ulf Beck. Und das ist auch vielleicht das Interessante, dass man bei Ulf Beck immer so in diesem Modus ist, wo liegt die nächste Provokation und vergisst darüber dann einfach, dass die Literatur auch eine eigene Qualität hat und dass sie eine große Ernsthaftigkeit hat. Aber das ist jetzt auch gar nicht das große Thema dann dort.
Aber wäre ja witzig, wenn bei Ulf Beck dann der Beipackzettel da drin liegt, drüber lesen und nicht drüber reden. Also sobald du drüber redest, geht es schief. Vielleicht nicht ganz so gut für so ein literarisches Quartett, das als Argument dann mitzubringen, dass ich in der… Nee, ich rede nicht über Ulf Beck. Ich habe es zwar gelesen, aber ich rede da jetzt nicht drüber. Dann geht es schief, aber vielleicht wäre das so.
Also wie gesagt, es gibt keine gute Ausgabe eines literarischen Quartetts, wo sinnvoll über Ulf Beck geredet wird oder wo alle mal sinnvoll darüber reden. Wir hören jetzt noch mal diese Geschichte mit dem Islamismus rein. Das lässt also Mattes gar keine Ruhe.
Ich finde es auch wirklich gefährlich heutzutage, nicht zwischen Islam und Islamismus zu unterscheiden. Und das tut er. Er unterscheidet nicht. Beziehungsweise er sagt sogar, ich äußere mich nicht darüber, ich verteidige aber die Islamophobie und die Religion.
Da steht der Satz, ich verteidige die Islamophobie.
Nein, zumal er spricht schon, er spricht den Dschihadismus an. Und er spricht darüber, dass wenn es etwas gäbe, wie ein muslimisches Oberhaupt, wie den Papst, dann hätte sich das erledigt. Also man würde sie exkommunizieren. Er trennt schon. Und auch was die Redefreiheit betrifft, er sagt zwar, das muss gesagt werden können, aber an anderer Stelle meint er auch, es gibt Grenzen. Und es sollte nicht alles gesagt werden. Er ist auch da kein Fundamentalist der Meinungsfreiheit und der Meinungsfreiheitwillen.
Ich glaube, der Mathis liest das so. Der schlägt so die Seiten auf und liest dann so zwei Seiten und denkt, es gibt irgendwo auf der Welt Menschen, die sind doof. Und die lesen das auch. Und die muss ich doch jetzt mal schützen. Ich meine, diesen Vorwurf, der unterscheidet zwischen dem und dem nicht, ich bin mir sehr sicher, dass Ulbeck diesen Unterschied kennt. Und wenn er ihn dann nicht so macht, dass Mathis das akzeptiert, dass er gemacht wurde, dann ist das instrumentell so veranlagt. Dann ist da ein Wille dahinter und dann soll das auch zum Nachdenken anregen. Das kann man in einem geschriebenen Text, glaube ich, gar nicht zum Vorwurf machen. Vor allem nicht, wenn man den Autor mit reinsieht. Das kann man vielleicht bei Plasberger in so eine Nachtkritik. Die haben da nicht unterschieden zwischen und so weiter. Da hat aber Oma Erna auch zugeguckt. Er muss das nochmal gesagt werden. Aber ich finde hier, das ist irgendwie vorbei am Medium. Also Mathis hat, glaube ich, das Medium wirklich nicht ernst genommen. Buch, Text und so insgesamt.
Wird jetzt noch besser.
Es ist ja schon, denn er schreibt wörtlich, ich zitiere, ich spüre die Verpflichtung, die Islamophobie zu verteidigen, ob ich nun selbst Islamophob bin oder nicht. Denn das muss Teil der Meinungen sein, die man äußern darf, um man hat das Recht, eine Religion anzugreifen. Und ich finde, man hat das Recht, die Exzesse, die gewalttätigen Äußerungen einer Religion anzugreifen, aber nicht die Religion selbst. Das ist für Frankreich ein extremer Punkt, gerade im Moment.
Wenn Mathis meint, man darf Religion nicht angreifen, hat er seinen Punkt hiermit gemacht. Dem muss man nicht folgen. Und damit würde ich sagen, wäre das erledigt.
Ich würde dann aber auch sagen, dann kann Mathis einen Großteil seiner Rollen, die er gespielt hat, jetzt nicht mehr spielen. Denn die Literatur, die Deutsche auch, des 18. und 19. Jahrhunderts, besteht auch darin, die Religion, die Christliche, dann in diesem Falle generell anzugreifen. Und in Frankreich ist das noch viel vehementer. Und das macht jetzt auch Theodor noch mal klar.
Aber das Recht, eine Religion anzugreifen, geht in Frankreich zurück bis Voltaire, um jetzt das ganz große Fass aufzumachen. Geht nicht nur darum, Exzesse einer Religion, sondern ich glaube schon, dass es ein essentieller Bestandteil für einen Schriftsteller ist. Zu sagen, natürlich darf man eine Religion, also zum Beispiel der Protestantismus, wenn wir dabei sind, der kommt aber noch so was von viel schlechter. Also als Kulturprotestantin würde ich sagen, dann könnte ich jetzt auch anfangen und mich aufregen, dass, ich glaube er bezeichnet das als die größte Katastrophe.
Er sagt ja nicht mal, dass es eine Religion sei, also Protestantismus ist schlimmer als Atheismus.
Puh, das tut mir ein bisschen leid für 45 Minuten Sendung, dass sie sich jetzt mit der Frage rumschlagen, ob man Religion angreifen darf. Und was ist eigentlich ein Angriff, solange das in Wortform in zwei Buchdeckeln passiert?
Und da sieht man aber schon, wo wir da angekommen sind. Also man ist in so einem Unheizgelaber und man ist auf jeden Fall nicht bei einem literarischen Gespräch angekommen. Ich will jetzt aber auch nicht, weil ich das anfangs ein bisschen getan habe, das alte literarische Quartett allzu sehr verklären. Es war mit Sicherheit unterhaltsamer. Es war nicht immer geistreicher, denn ich habe mir gedacht, komm, nehmen wir doch mal drei Ausschnitte kurze aus der Diskussion damals, Will Becks Roman Elementarteilchen. Und da sehen wir, wie eigentlich Marcel Reich Ranicki total versagt.
Das am häufigsten in diesem Roman Elementarteilchen vorkommende Wort ist, ich bin davon überzeugt, gezählt habe ich nicht, aber den Roman gelesen aufmerksam, ist unanieren. Das ist auf jeder Seite zweimal, manchmal dreimal auf jeder Seite. Das ist kein Zufall, das zeugt von irgendetwas, der Roman ist.
Es zeugt aber nichts.
Jetzt zurück zu dem, also ich muss doch ein ein ein zu onani sagen, Entschuldigung, Entschuldigung, es ist doch, es ist nicht unbezeichnend, dass sofort ein Gelächter durch die Leute geht. In einer vereinsamen Gesellschaft, und darüber gibt es sehr viel Untersuchungen, Sie haben es vorher völlig richtig gesagt, ist die Onanie eine verzweifelte Form der Liebe. Und das ist in diesem Roman auch. Und beide Helden versuchen das zu überwinden. Und Frau Loeffler hat insofern, finde total unrecht, dass das ein Roman über Sexualität ist. Es ist ein Roman über Liebe. Und es gibt ergreifende Liebeszenen. Ich wehre mich dagegen, dass wir hier in so eine Kneipenstimmung kommen, dass das Wort Onanie sofort gelächter vor uns. Es ist ein Roman über Einsamkeit.
Ja, also, das ist ganz schön, dass Karasek hier sehr, sehr gut argumentiert und er macht das noch sehr viel länger. Und Karasek überrascht mich da, weil ich den sonst eher als den Schwächeren der drei in Erinnerung habe. Und Maseraj Raditzky aber versucht jetzt noch mal zu zeigen, ja, ich habe da schon was mitbekommen, Onanie und sagt dann auch noch mal, das war ja schon mal ein wichtiges Thema in der Kölner Schule Literatur 60er Jahre. Aber eigentlich kann er das nicht mehr so richtig dann deuten. Und das finde ich schon fabelhaft, dass Karasek da ganz stark auch mit Leidenschaft für Well-Beck argumentiert.
Ich bin deshalb so erregt, weil ich finde, dies ist eines der wenigen epochalen Werke, das ich je im literarischen Quartett zu vertreten hatte.
Ja, zu diesem ganzen Onanie-Kram und so ist, glaube ich, jetzt 2020 noch mal zu sagen, wir haben diese neue Bälle. Wir hatten das auch schon hier kurz mal angesprochen anhand japanischer Schauspielerin, dass wir in Hollywood relativ viele junge Frauen haben, denen man erstmal grundsätzlich unterstellt, wenn die einen Partner wollten, könnten die einen haben, weil die stehen Schlange, die Männer. Das wäre so das Bild, das man auf jeden Fall mit unterstellen muss, die dann aber von sich sagen, ich bin Self-Partnered. Also ich lebe schon in einer Beziehung mit mir selbst. Es gibt auf Instagram ganz viele Videos, wo so sehr bekannte und sehr hübsche Schauspielerinnen im Grunde jeden Tag ein Video von sich hochladen, wie sie mit ihrem Kater spielen, wie sie im Garten sind, alles aber immer mit sich, wo man nie einen anderen Menschen sieht, obwohl man weiß, da leben auch noch andere Menschen in der Haushalt.
Es wird auch von Me-Lationship oder Me-Love und Me-Time, all das.
Vor vielen, vielen Jahren, ich glaube 1992, 1993, irgendwann dann, hat Schömmacher auch dieses Minimal-Minimum-Buch geschrieben, wie Beziehungsgestaltung, nicht so im romantischen Sinne, sondern so grundsätzlich die Welt verändert sich. Und was bedeutet das eigentlich für die Beziehung? Wir haben jetzt gerade wieder Diskussionen, dass die Sorben ein besonders extremes Infektionsgeschehen da in Sachsen haben, also Landkreis Bautzen und so weiter, weil die eben ein, wie soll man sagen, großfamilienartiges Landleben haben, noch über die eigene Verwandtschaft hinaus, während wir im Gegenzug in den Städten gerade ein sensationell gutes Infektionsgeschehen haben, weil da einfach absolute Versingelung ist. Und das, was Ulbäck da geschrieben hat, vielleicht sollte man jetzt einfach noch mal neu in die Zeit holen. Ja, wenn da dreimal pro Seite von Ornanitisch die Rede ist, dann sollte man das noch mal als Schiffre sozusagen ernst nehmen und sich dann vielleicht, also ich hab noch nie einen richtigen Ulbäck-Text gelesen, keine Ahnung, was da drinsteht, aber...
Ich bin fast dafür, dass wir noch mal im Salon, mal nicht jetzt im nächsten schon, aber dass wir noch mal den letzten Roman von Ulbäck besprechen, Serotonin, der von Depression und Einsamkeit handelt. Dass wir vielleicht diesen Roman...
Wenn man das verkraftet...
.der sehr heiter auch ist und den Sarah Wagenknecht übrigens während ihrer Burnout-Phase gelesen hat, der ihr sehr geholfen hat. Also ein wirklich sehr interessanter Text. Wir hören jetzt noch mal gerade, um mal zu zeigen, dass Maserreich-Handzicki von dieser Art und Literatur nicht besonders viel Ahnung hat, hat eine Fehleinschätzung zu Elementar-Teilchen.
Der Roman hat nicht die Spur von Anschau- lichkeit in der Erzählung. Es entstehen keine, die Figuren sind alle ganz schwach gezeichnet. Und das Wichtigste, das ist ein Buch, verzeihen Sie das Wort. Ich weiß, es ist nicht wissenschaftlich definierbar. Es ist ein Buch ohne Charme. Es hat nicht eine bisschen Spur von Charme. Man liest es und man findet manche Seite.
Es ist ein Buch über unsere Zeit.
Der Bezug auf Figuren und Charme, das ist natürlich für dich als Filmkritiker, der sagt, wenn jemand kommt und sagt, der sieht voll gut aus als Schauspieler, dann ist gleich mal desqualifiziert.
Zumindest darf das nicht beeindrucken bei der Kritik. Und was er hier sucht, ist, er möchte eine Figurenausgestaltung haben, wie man sie bei Theodor Fontane finden kann oder vielleicht auch bei Flo Behr. Aber die kann ein Will Beck nicht liefern, weil er uns Figuren zeigt, die wie Abziehbilder sind. Es sind Figuren, die einsam in anonymen Wohnblöcken, in anonymen Wohnungen, anonymen Sex haben. Es sind keine Figuren, die sich dadurch auszeichnen, dass sie eine besondere psychologische Ausgestaltung, Dispositionen und viele Talente mit sich bringt. Also das ist wirklich so verrückt, um dann das Wort Charme reinzubringen, wenn man es mit einem Gegenwartshoman zu tun hat, der von Vereinzelung und von eigentlich nur noch käuflichem Sex handelt, dann muss man schon fragen, was für eine Kategorie, was man da, dann kann ich auch, also das ist wirklich, den Schwarz-Weiß-Film sich ansehen und sagen, schade, dass keine Farbe da ist.
Genau und das erinnert mich gerade, es kommt ja gerade eine neue Star Trek Serie, Discovery in der vierten Staffel oder so und die finde ich unerträglich. Ich habe mich gefragt, warum eigentlich und jetzt kam ich drauf, also jetzt die letzten Tage. Früher war es Star Trek immer, man schaltet das ein. Absolut Stereotype-Figuren, die einfach irgendwas machen und irgendeine Idee steht halt pro Folge im Mittelpunkt. Irgendein Raumschiff, irgendwas physikalisches passiert und in dieser neuen Discovery entwickeln die plötzlich diese Persönlichkeiten so krass und es ist denen auch ganz wichtig als Autoren, dass sie jetzt natürlich das schwule Leben im Raumschiff nochmal zeigen und dann sterben die Partner einander und können doch wieder belebt werden und irgendwie so und der eine kann nicht loslassen und die ganze Zeit dieses Dawson Creek-mäßige, was ich immer gut fande, dass es bei Star Trek nicht stattfand und deswegen gucke ich jetzt lieber Expanse oder sowas als diese neue Discovery-Scheiße, die sie dahingelegt haben, genau wegen, weil da saß schon Reich Ranitzky irgendwie mit in der Redaktion, er hat gesagt, wir brauchen mal Figuren ausgedacht. Genau, wir brauchen mal Figuren. Schleim ist das.
Echte, echte Figuren, große Figuren. Ich würde sagen, wir machen jetzt mal das andere so eher im Schnelldurchlauf. Also sie sprechen dann über drei weitere Bücher. Da ist einmal Elif Schafak, Schau mich an. Das ist ein Buch, eine Liebesgeschichte zwischen einem kleinwüchsigen und einer sehr, sehr dicken Frau. Und auch hier noch einmal hören wir, wie die Kabarettistin ihren Punkt mit reinbringt.
Fast schadenfroh und trotzdem auch total empathisch. Also man schämt sich und muss aber doch wieder lachen. Und dann denkt man auch über die eigenen Sehgewohnheiten und die eigenen, den eigenen bösen Blick, den man manchmal auch auf andere Menschen automatisch wirft.
Den aber auch sie hat. Das finde ich spannend. Das ist das Interessante mit dem Glotzauge. Sie ist gnadenlos. Sie sagt, dieses hässliche Kind mit den Glotzaugen. Und das finde ich fantastisch an dem Werk, dass es nicht, und das passiert leicht, Menschen, die dick sind, die vom bösen Blick betroffen sind, mit einer höheren Moralität gesegnet sein, aufgrund dieser Leiterfahrung. Damit bricht es, weil das, finde ich, ist ein sehr gefährlicher Gedanke, ein Denken, was heute vorherrscht. Und das tut sie nicht. Ich finde, Empathie erzeugt es dadurch, dass es wenig Empathie zeigt für diese Figur. Sie ist gereizt. Das hat mir schon sehr gefallen, weil wenn man heutzutage irgendwas mit Body Positivity, wenn man die Plakate sieht, jetzt mit den Curvy Models, warum lachen die immer so debil, als wäre Schwermut nur den Anorektikern vorbehalten. Und so ist sie nicht. Die ist gereizt, die ist keine zwangsläufig sympathische Figur und das macht sie so sympathisch.
Sie hat sich also ganz gut vorbereitet auf die Sendung. Sie hat die Pointen vorher dann sich zurechtgelegt und bringt sie dann unter. So machen es eigentlich die Profis und ja, sie ist auch ganz schön, wenn sie dann irgendwas noch aus dem Buch zitiert, spricht sie das auch noch wirklich mit ihrer Kabarett-Stimme, dass man wirklich den Eindruck hat, das was ihr gefällt, das hat sie fast selbst geschrieben. Ja, das ist dann ein bisschen problematischer, wenn wir eben über Petkovic sprechen. Sie hat eigentlich gar nichts dazu zu sagen, nur dann noch mal so am Ende ist ihr was ganz wichtig. Also wir haben es hier mit einem Roman zu tun, einer türkischen Autorin, die inzwischen in London lebt, die Welterfolge gefeiert hat. Wir haben sie also jetzt nicht mit irgendwie einem kleinen Roman zu tun, der den Kein und Aber irgendwo entdeckt hat, sondern das ist jetzt schon ein größerer Name. Und deswegen ist jetzt dieser Satz so besonders unnötig, der von Petkovic kommt.
Eine Sache muss ich noch sagen, ist es wahnsinnig wichtig, dass wir eben auch andere Arten von Autoren lesen und dass Repräsentation wichtig ist und dass wir nicht immer nur den westlichen Blick aufsetzen. Und das hat mich gefreut.
Wenn gleich welche in der Türkei irritiert sind, ach, sind wir gar nicht mehr Westen, haben wir gar nichts mit damit zu tun, sind wir jetzt nur noch die Orientalen. Denn der Roman arbeitet auch mit solchen orientalischen Mustern sehr stark in der Erzählung. Ja, ein nicht schlechter Roman, aber auch kein besonders guter. Aber du siehst dann einfach, dass hier nicht über Literatur gesprochen wird, nicht darüber geschrieben wird, sondern einfach die Frage der Repräsentation nochmal auftaucht. Es ist ja schön, dass wir das auch mal vorhaben. Das hat man immer schon im literarischen Quartett. Das war nie nur deutsche Literatur. Da hat man auch immer über den Tellerrad geguckt, gerade nach Lateinamerika sehr, sehr stark. Viele große Romanen in den 90er Jahren aus Lateinamerika kamen. Ja, das hindert sich aber nicht daran, dann einen sehr westlichen Autor mitzubringen, nämlich Dom de Lillo. Das ist ein alter amerikanischer Schriftsteller, der hat jetzt einen ganz schmalen Roman veröffentlicht. Die Stille. Und es geht darum, dass es plötzlich ein Stromausfall in Amerika gibt, und der schildert dann ganz kleine Szenen, die zwischen Menschen stattfinden. Und ja, dazu sagt sie Folgendes.
Er beschrei, es ist ein Buch. Eigentlich ist es ein Büchlein. Es ist wahnsinnig dünn. Und ich habe es auch mitgebracht, weil ich ein Herz für meine Mitstreiter und Mitstreiterinnen habe. Und ich wollte euch nicht durch tausendseitige Wälze durchquellen. Und habe dieses kleine, aber feine literarische Werk mitgebracht. Don De Lillo war für mich am Anfang meiner Lesereise wirklich eine Offenbarung, weil ich hatte sehr geradlinige Romane immer gelesen. Und dann dieses Postmoderne, dieses Spielen mit Raum und Zeit, das war neu für mich. Ich war relativ jung, ich war Anfang 20. Und ich dachte mir damals, ah, so kann man Romane auch schreiben. Es hat mich wahnsinnig gefreut. In diesem Buch geht es um zwei mittelalte Ehepaare. Das eine ist in seinem New York City Apartment und bereitet sich auf eine Super Bowl Party vor, das Finale des American Footballs. Das andere Ehepaar ist im Flieger von Paris nach New York. Und auf einmal gehen alle elektronischen Geräte aus. Man weiß nicht, was passiert. In der Wohnung ist außerdem noch ein Student der Physik, der mit Einstein-Zitaten um sich wirft. Ich hab eine Sache gelesen in meiner halbherzigen Recherche, die mich sehr froh gemacht hat. Angeblich haben die Lektoren versucht, Donde Lillo davon zu überzeugen, Pandemie und Virus reinzubringen. Aber er hatte das Buch davor geschrieben und er hat sich strikt geweigert.
Das hat leider gelungen. Es ist Ihnen leider gelungen, Seite 84, Frau Petkovic.
Ich wäre auch ganz kiek angestrichen.
Wirklich? Das ist mir entgangen. Vielleicht wäre ich nicht so gefeuert. Das ist wirklich peinlich, aber gut, es ist mein erster und letzter Auftritt im literarischen Quartett.
Was steht denn da auf Seite 84, wenn das nur auf einer Seite kurz vorkommt?
Es steht da auch Corona. Also es geht darum, dass man ja jetzt einiges schon erlebt hat, unter anderem auch diese Pandemie Corona. Also das hat er da mit reingebracht. Und darum ging es jetzt da. Da hat sie nicht gründlich gelesen. Und ja, dieser Roman ist abscheulich schlecht. Ich finde es wirklich skandalös, dass sowas erscheinen darf. Die Herrschaften im Quartett sehen das aber bis auf Theodor. Vollkommen anders. Wir hören jetzt aber mal, was Ulrich Mathes jetzt erst mal zu diesem Roman zu sagen hat, nämlich das ist gar kein Roman, steht aber drauf.
Es ist kein Roman. Es ist eine Novelle. Es ist eine unerhörte Begebenheit in der göttischen Definition. Es ist oder es ist von mir aus eine Short Story. Es sind alle Figuren sind angerissen.
Sie sind von mir aus Charaktermasken.
Ey, wenn ich in so einer Sendung wäre und dann kommt einer und sagt, das ist kein Roman, das ist eine Novelle. Was soll ich denn dann sagen?
Ja, dann bezieht er sich dann da auf Goethe. Unerhörte Begebenheit, zeichnet eine Novelle aus. Da könnte man sagen, vielleicht ist das der Stromausfall. Möglicherweise, also ein Verlag, schreibt gerne Roman drauf, weil immer wenn Roman draufsteht, verkauft es sich besser. Man kann nicht einen Verkaufserfolg erzielen, indem man dort einfach Novelle draufschreibt oder nichts draufschreibt. Deswegen immer, wenn Roman draufsteht, muss das noch nicht gleich bedeuten, dass es ein Roman ist, dass Ulrich Mathes aber dann auch noch sagt, das ist vielleicht auch, es ist eine Short Story. Und dann wirft Petkovic noch ein impressionistisches Bild und dann sagt Mathes noch, ja, es sind Charaktermasken. Also ein Begriff von Marx. Man merkt einfach, es ist an sich schon etwas sehr Sinnvolles, wenn man eine Literatursendung veranstaltet mit Literaturkritikern. Und das ist eben sehr, sehr traurig, dass das nicht mehr stattfindet. Und wir erleben dann solche Unsinnstebatten. Und das waren ja wirklich jetzt noch die Highlights, die ich hier präsentieren konnte. Und vielleicht jetzt noch mal zum Abschluss das Missverständnis überhaupt noch einmal jetzt Petkovic in Höchstform.
Freue ich mich auch so, dass Frau Eckhardt gesagt hat, ihr habt die Liebe gefehlt. Und ich glaube, genau das will Dondelelo sagen, weil die Figuren reden ja nicht miteinander. Die sagen ja einfach Worte vor sich hin.
Frau Eckhardt hat gesagt, ihr habt die Libido gefehlt.
Das ist ja ein Untertitel.
Manchmal ist es dasselbe.
Dann hast du schon gewundert.
Nein, es hat mir auch nicht gefehlt. Ich habe es ja dann in diesem zweiten Anlauf.
Ja, es ist so ein bisschen wie Weihnachten mit der Familie, oder? Es sind viele Leute am Tisch. Also jetzt nicht dieses Weihnachten, aber sonst viele Leute am Tisch. Onkel hört nicht mehr so gut. Tante will auch gar nicht so richtig sich beteiligen. Aber dann reden so alle aneinander vorbei und dann muss man sich wieder verständigen. Ach so, der hat das gesagt. Libido, Libi habe Liebe, was? Das ist also eine Gesprächsführung auch, eine Nicht-Gesprächsführung von Thea Dorn, die man sich kaum mit antun kann. Ich würde sagen, wir verzichten jetzt auch auf das dritte Buch. Das ist auch eins, das überhaupt nicht lesenswert ist von Minka Pradelsky. Es wird wieder Tag. Da bin ich dann mit Ulrich Mathes einer Meinung, dass das Thema wichtig sein mag, aber wir es einfach mit einem stilistisch ganz, ganz schrecklichen Roman zu tun haben, den Thea Dorn aber dann in höchsten Ton loben kann. Was wir hier erleben, ist eine Sendung, die weder Entertainment bietet, noch wirkliche Literaturkritik, geschweige denn literaturwissenschaftlich irgendwie haltbare Aussagen. Und wenn das alles nicht vorhanden ist, dann muss man sagen, das ist einfach zu wenig. Die Sendung ist zu kurz für die ganzen Bücher, die besprochen wird. Die Gäste sind uninteressant oder unqualifiziert. Die ganze Sendung hat überhaupt nicht die Stimmung, die Atmosphäre von damals. Ich würde sagen, man stampft das Ganze ein oder muss es komplett neu denken und auf alle modernen Marotten verzichten. Und das ist ja etwas, was wir jetzt auch in anderen Formaten erleben, dass man dann mal sagt, auch mal könnte man so eine Quartett-Version machen. Es gibt auch, glaube ich, irgendwie sowas im Öffentlich-Rechlichen zu Serien. Muss man aber auch eher sagen, könnte auch den Titel Idiotentreff tragen. Das ist alles so furchtbar, wie das gesamte Kulturfernsehen in einem so desolaten Zustand ist, dass ich finde, hier müsste jetzt das Öffentlich-Rechliche, gerade weil wir diese Debatte haben, mal von der besten Seite zeigen und müsste neue Formate entwickeln. Und diese Formate wären ja alle günstig. Die Leute, die man da einlädt, die bekommen lang nicht die Honorare, einer Helene Fischer oder Andrea Berg, wie das bei Silbereisen ist, die bekommen auch nicht solche Lizenzgebühren, wie das bei DFB und FIFA der Fall ist und all diesen anderen Sportübertragungen. Man könnte mit wenig Geld wirklich gute Sendungen machen. Und da gibt es ja auch Podcasts, die beweisen, dass das so geht. Da muss man ja sagen, ist ja ein ganz schnell produziertes Format, wie zum Beispiel Kats, in dem du ja auch zu Gast warst im Filmpodcast, viel, viel interessanter, in dem was dort alles gesprochen wird. Da passiert viel mehr, könnte man sagen, das filmen wir auch noch ab. Und das senden wir dann auch um 23 Uhr an dem Freitagabend. Als dieser Unsinn, der hier läuft und der nur noch deshalb funktioniert, jetzt mal, weil mal dieser Eckart da hat und mal irgendwie alle noch mal reinschalten, wird sie irgendwas Böses sagen, macht sie noch mal einen schlimmen Witz. Und dann passiert das noch nicht mal, sondern sie ist eigentlich die, die am besten vorbereitet ist in dieser Sendung, dass man sagen kann, br. Werd ich das doch jetzt hier endlich? Es hat keinen Sinn mehr. Dem Buchhandel ist es eh egal. Die Zeiten sind längst vorbei. Im alten literarischen Quartett war es so, da haben die ein Buch empfohlen oder verrissen. Und trotzdem hat es sich gut verkauft. Das hat lange nicht mehr etwas Ausschlag geben, dass wenn hier ein Buch verrissen oder gelobt wird.
Ich finde eh jetzt über deine völlig berechtigte Kritik noch hinaus, also literarische Kritik oder Kulturfernsehen. Es gibt für Menschen, die wie ich keine Romane lesen, trotzdem ein Bedürfnis über das literarische Leben Bescheid zu wissen. Ich fand das immer gut, dass die FAZ zum Beispiel eine Rubrik literarisches Leben hat, wo es über die Buchrezension hinausging. Und ich finde, das muss so eine Sendung auch bieten. Also du bist fürs Beerdigen, ich finde, auch fürs Beerdigen, aber dann gleich wiederbeleben mit allen Risiken, die das bedeutet, nämlich dass man immer noch Fernsehen macht und so. Ja, es ist billig. Ich habe hier zum Beispiel gerade meine Presseclubs Teilnahmzettel. Man kriegt dann so einen riesigen vierseitigen, muss man dann unterschreiben und hier und da und am Ende kriegt man 600 Euro und das finde ich völlig angemessen, dass man nämlich für eine Stunde, die man vor der Kamera ist und zwei Stunden hin, zwei Stunden zurück irgendwie dann so einen Tagessatz irgendwie da halt Entschädigungen bekommt. Es ist ja auch ein Sonntag. Ich finde, man könnte wirklich jetzt ausgehen von so einer Preisgestaltung zu sagen, pro Gast rechnen wir mit 600 Euro plus Transfer, also man kommt dann irgendwie bei 1000 Euro pro Gast raus, 4000 Euro plus das ganze Fernsehzeug, was dann irgendwie pro Minute 600 nochmal Euro kostet, sodass man ja so eine Sendung eine Stunde gut gestalten kann und sich dann wirklich mal darauf konzentriert, was wollen wir hier eigentlich? Und die FAZ zum Beispiel als, wo das FöHTOR ganz lange zwölf Seiten hatte und völlig klar war, also da können wir alles machen, da machen wir erst mal acht Seiten Rezension, dann stellt man zehn Jahre später fest, liest gar keiner, die Leute interessieren sich dann doch mehr für das andere, gewisse etwas irgendwie, das was Podcasts zum Beispiel bietet, Persönlichkeit und so. Und dann könnte man sich wirklich mal fragen, worum geht es eigentlich in Literatur? Um das Buch? Wenn wir jetzt sagen, lest mal das Buch, setzen wir dann voraus, dass alle wie in so einem Seminar das Buch vorbereitet haben und nur dann Sendung bekommen.
Nein, in der Regel ja gar nicht. Also oft reden sie ja über Bücher, die gerade erschienen sind, die wenigsten werden es gelesen haben.
Genau, da hat man nämlich jetzt gerade in dieser Pandemie, in dem Kulturmedienbetrieb, also der reflektiert, stellt man sich die Frage, wie gehen wir eigentlich damit um, dass wir eigentlich einen Rezensionsbetrieb haben, aber gerade nur Veranstaltungen stattfinden, zu denen nur Rezensenten hingehen können. Also du hast eine Ausstellung von irgendwas, die wurde ja vorbereitet. Pandemiesicher kann man aber nur die Rezensenten hinbringen, nämlich jeden Tag drei. Die nimmt man dann wirklich ans Händchen und führt die da durch. Und das entscheidet eine ganz komplizierte Frage für die Redaktion. Die Redaktion hat sich nämlich immer gefragt, besprechen wir eigentlich die Theaterstücke und die Ausstellungen, damit die Leute dann da hingehen? Oder besprechen wir die Ausstellungen und die Theaterstücke, zu denen die Leute nicht hin können? Und das sind ganz unterschiedliche Ansätze. So und jetzt haben wir es eben, dass wir in Salzburg Premiere von irgendwas haben, bei denen die Rezensionen nicht davon ausgehen können, wenn ich das jetzt aufschreibe, ist morgen da die Hütte voll. Dann gehen die alle hin und wollen das sehen, sondern es kann ja keiner hingehen, es ist ja Pandemie und so. Und jetzt muss man eine Kulturberichterstattung machen, die selbst wieder Kultur wird, nämlich anstelle der eigentlichen Kultur. Also der Rezensionen, so wie Gerhard Stadelmeier, muss jetzt ein eigenes Werk schaffen, das sich aber inhaltlich dem eigentlichen Werk, das thematisiert wird, unterwirft. So und das muss ich niederschlagen, auch in so Literatursendungen. Man muss in Literatursendungen, finde ich, und deswegen war das dieser letzte Ausschnitt, der war wirklich grandios. Petkovic betont, dass in einem Buch die Menschen aneinander vorbei reden, während sie dann feststellt, ach, wir haben ja in der Sendung auch aneinander vorbei geredet. Ich habe sie ja völlig missverstanden, liebe Durst, nicht liebe gesagt. Ja, und genau das muss aber einprogrammiert werden in die Sendung, dass wie Reich Ranicki man zwar über ein Buch spricht, aber eigentlich gegen die anderen, die in der Sendung sitzen oder mit ihnen, je nachdem, wie die die Sachlage ist. Aber dieses Gefühl kann sich ja pro Buch dann neu entstehen. Aber es ist doch genau die Kontroverse, die sich in dem Gespräch entfaltet, das Entscheidende, und nicht so sehr die Textgrundlage oder doch die Textgrundlage, wenn sie es hergibt.
Dann müsste es auch ein ganz anderes Gespräch sein. Dann müsste es dann wirklich das Fachgespräch sein. Da würde ich sagen, das ist wiederum im Fernsehen vielleicht nicht gut aufgehoben, dann eher Deutschlandradio dafür. Da gibt es ja solche Formate. Da haben wir stärker diese Textgrundlage, dann geht man da auch noch mal literaturgeschichtlich ran und und und kann ausführlich zitieren. Das findet natürlich in so einem Streitgespräch nicht statt, aber es muss etwas eigenständiges dabei rauskommen. Du hast es gerade sehr schön auch angesprochen mit Stadelmayr, Gerd Stadelmayr, Theaterkritiker der FAZ gewesen. Dessen Kritiken las man, auch wenn man sicher war, ich werde das Stück nie sehen, weil es in Hamburg ist, da fahre ich nicht extra hin, aber man las es, weil sie sehr gut geschrieben waren. Sie hatten selbst einen Unterhaltungswert. Sie waren selbst ein bisschen Theater auf Papier.
Die besten Kritiken von Stadelmayr hatten die schlechtesten Theater als Grundlage, weil dann konnte er sich richtig austoben. Da war einfach, also da blieb nichts heile danach. Da war einfach verbrannte Erde, wenn Stadelmayr einmal darüber herzog. Und das muss so ein Anspruch sein, dass man sagt, dass man niemals sagt, das war ein schlechtes Buch, das legen wir zur Seite, oder wir streiten uns so sinnlos darüber, welche Begriffe bedeuten irgendwie was. So wie wir das von dem Schauspieler gerade gehört haben. So völlig Bananen, wo wir noch mal so den eigenen Stolz, ich bin ja ein selbst denkender Leser, ich wehr mich jetzt gegen den Autor, und dann kämpft man da irgendwie seine Persönlichkeit durch. Sondern das muss dann irgendwie groß integriert werden. Und da sehe ich, glaube ich, ganz großes Potenzial, denn diese Literatur, und das ist, glaube ich, ganz wichtig, die wird auch gemacht für Menschen, die sie nicht selber lesen, die aber trotzdem in der Welt leben, in der diese Literatur stattfindet und auch Wirkung entfaltet. Denn manchmal wird der Literatur doch ein paar Sachen verhandelt. Ja, wenn man Thea Dorn bei Markus Lanz mal darüber reden hört, wie sie über eigenen Texte spricht, wie ihr Vater starb und so weiter und so fort. Ja, in Pandemie-Zeiten, mit der Einsamkeit, wir haben das hier alles thematisiert. Dann liegen da einfach unendliche Schätze drin und die müssen auch gehoben werden. Und dann kann man nicht einfach nur einfach so ein Buch da hinlegen und sagen, reden wir über das Buch, sondern muss man die Sendung entsprechend gestalten. Und ich finde, das hat Reich Ranitschke halt immer entsprechend gemacht. Man konnte Reich Ranitschke widersprechen, wenn man in der Lage war, Reich Ranitschke zu widersprechen. Die Gründe dafür gab es natürlich.
Aber es waren auch immer Gäste da, die das erst mal konnten und die man auch angreifen konnte. Also Reich Ranitschke konnte dort die alle sehr hart angreifen. Es ist einmal bei Löffler, denke ich, zu weit gegangen. Da gab es ja auch diesen Bruch. Aber sonst war das auf jeden Fall in einer Weise, dass man sagte, ich muss nicht Angst davor haben, dass der andere gleich anfängt zu weinen. Und wenn man natürlich eine Gäste-Konstellation da hat, wo man schon so gleich sagt, ja, ich bin ja eigentlich nur so ein kleiner Leser, dann kannst du jetzt auch als Großkritiker gar nicht da sitzen und sagen, wie kommen sie zu einer solchen Auffassung? Das ist ein scheußlicher Roman, weil derjenige das gleich so warnt, ach so, ja, aber ich bin nur ein Leser. Also das ist so, was man aus der Familienfeier auch so kennt. Ich schnapp irgendwie auf, jemand sagt, ja, das war ja so ein schöner Film. Ich weiß, er war sehr grässlich und dann muss ich jetzt nicht dahingehen und der Cousine, die jetzt einmal im Jahr im Kino war, die sagt, das war ein ganz guter Film und ich kann, ich muss dir dann nicht eine Standpauke halten, wie ich das jetzt dir halten würde, wenn du jetzt mal wieder ein Michael Bay Film.
Das wollte ich gerade noch sagen.
Dann würde ich natürlich sagen, Stefan, du irrst einmal wieder.
Wir haben ja bei Kats sehr ausführlich über das Gewerk von Michael Bay gesprochen. Und da fiel es mir wieder auf, dass ich ja vielleicht, ist das selten, es kommt mir jedenfalls selten vor, dass Menschen, so wie ich, einfach sagen, ich liebe André Rieu und ich vergöttere Michael Bay. Und wenn irgendwer was dagegen sagt, dann denke ich mir nur, ja, ich weiß und die Kritik kenne ich auch schon, nur das kratzt nicht an meiner Persönlichkeit. Ich identifiziere mich nicht auf diese Art und Weise. Ich kann trotzdem noch Michael Bay auch morgen noch toll finden, auch wenn ich heute ein tolles Argument gehört habe. Und wir haben ja, Christian hat ja ein paar Argumente gebracht und ich musste ja auch selber eingestehen, man macht sich mitschuldig an einigen moralischen Vergehen, wenn man Michael Bay gut findet. So er hat ja Umgang mit den Frauen als Figur im Film und so. Und das kann man halt alles machen, nur, also ich habe da mittlerweile halt ein ganz dickes Fell und ich kann mich auch nicht dran erinnern, dass ich irgendwann mal gekränkt war, wenn so ein Super-Hipster auf Twitter mal wieder meint, ah, Stefan und André Rieu, was für ein Scheiß. Nee, ich weiß doch, dass das alle blöd finden. Und so muss man auch mit Büchern umgehen. Bücher, die man richtig gut findet, da kann man durchaus mal alleine sein damit. Und das kann man dann trotzdem in so einer Sendung thematisieren, ohne dass man da gleich, ja und so, ich wollte ja nur und so. Das will man einfach nicht sehen im Lit, das ist ein Quartett. Man muss nicht Reich-Ranitzky kopieren, wenn man das heute macht, aber mit dieser Haltung kann man da schon mal reingehen, also in deren Sicht. Frohen Neustart, liebes ZDF. Wir haben hier schon mehrfach im August darüber gesprochen, dass Jeff Bezos, PJ und Zuckerberg also Amazon, Google und Facebook vom Kongress vorgeladen waren. Wir haben uns damals sehr gewundert, dass die Demokraten davon sprechen, dass es hier eine Innovation Killzone gibt, die ist mal abgeschafft gehört. Und die Republikaner nur wissen wollten, wie das jetzt ist in diesem Wahlkampf, warum wird da Trump da unterdrückt und so. Relativ albern. Dann im November nach der Wahl haben wir geguckt Zuckerberg und Dorsey vom Kongress, wo die Republikaner plötzlich aufgewacht und geschockt von ihrer Niederlage feststellen, dass Social Media macht uns ganz schön krank. Und damit haben sie tatsächlich krank gemeint, psychisch krank. Wir sind süchtig, es macht uns süchtig, es ist so angelegt und so weiter und so fort. Wir haben also zweimal in diesem Jahr auf Kongressanhörungen geschaut, wo sich die Politik mit dem Silicon Valley auseinandersetzt. Und das Silicon Valley ist ein bisschen mehr als einfach nur irgendwelche Unternehmen, sondern das ist Adrian Daub und so weiter, das neue Machtzentrum und zwar sehr viel mächtiger als Washington und deswegen auch so entscheidend für uns, denn aus Europa kam nicht viel Auseinandersetzung mit dem Silicon Valley, bis jetzt im Dezember. Und man spricht zum Beispiel beim Social Media WatchBlog, das ich sehr empfehlen kann, kann man auch via Steady kaufen, vom Grundgesetz für die digitale Welt, das jetzt ansteht, mit dem Digital Services Act da vorgeschlagen wurde. Er beruht auf der E-Commerce-Richtlinie 2000, der DSGVO, Datenschutz-Grundverordnung und dem Netzwerksdurchsetzungsgesetz, das hier sehr beklagt wurde, allerdings eine ganz gute Anlage hat. Mit dem Digital Services Act kommt ein Digital Markets Act, der sich nochmal um die Monopolisten in Alterssprache kümmert. Wir müssen jetzt klären, was heißt eigentlich Monopol. Bisher hat Monopol immer gesagt, da nutzt jemand eine Marktmacht zum Schaden des Nutzers aus, insbesondere durch Preisgestaltung. Nun hier im Silicon Valley ist alles kostenlos, also Preisgestaltung schadet uns schon mal nicht. Das kann man so einfach nicht sagen, deswegen geht es ja auch nicht so sehr um Monopole, sondern eher um, neuer Begriff, Dominanz. Da könnte man ja vielleicht so fruchtbar machen, Dominanz und zwar brechen. Dominanz muss gebrochen werden, um wieder Innovationen von Start-ups zu ermöglichen, die nicht entweder durch Werbenkampagnen höhere Gehälter für die Mitarbeiter sonst wie zerstört werden, die man einfach alles aufkauft, weckauft und zerstört, sondern da anders umgeht. Es geht auch um viel mehr noch, als um die irgendwie Verflechtung von Datenschutz und Kartellrecht, was wir ja bisher auch schon thematisiert hatten, sondern es werden ganz neue Kategorien eingezogen. Die Maßstäbe klären wir gleich zum Thema Interoperationalität. Einsicht in Algorithmen. Du hast ja von algorithmischer Gewalt gesprochen. Gibt es da nicht Strategien dagegen? Und grundsätzlich haben wir es hier mit Gesetzen zu tun, die so sehr auf digitale Technologien abstellen, dass wir das hören wir dann gleich, dass wir die federführende Politikerin hören mit dem atemberaubenden Satz, wir haben lange überlegt, ob wir nicht die Firmennamen direkt ins Gesetz reinschreiben. Wir haben lange überlegt, ob wir nicht direkt reinschreiben, Google.
Das wäre absolut ein No-Wum, oder?
Das wäre ein...
Das hätte es nicht vorher gegeben.
Ja, das wäre auch aus Gründen, weil wir machen keine Lex-Dingster-Bums und so. Aber so weit gehen die Überlegungen. Also wir haben es hier nicht nur mit einem, es ist eh alles verloren und so weiter zu tun, sondern diesmal geht es ans Eingemachte EpiCenter Works in Österreich, die sich ja sehr um diese Mitarbeit da kümmern, da nochmal ein zivilgesellschaftliches Aspekt damit durchzubringen, und die sagen auch, das ist jetzt wirklich die Mutter aller Auseinandersetzungen mit dem Silicon Valley und in deren Sicht gehe ich nur mal kurz, bevor wir dann in die Pressekonferenz kurz reinschauen, mal kurz ein. Die Digital Service Act könnte, das ist ja erstmal der Gesetzesvorschlag der EU-Kommission, der muss dann von Parlament und den Mitgliedsstaaten, da ist der Lobbydruck dann entsprechend groß, nochmal modifiziert werden, aber es könnte sein, so ist jedenfalls der Wunsch und die Anlage der EU-Kommission, dass in Europa demnächst schwarze Listen für Geschäftsmodelle geführt werden, die geächtet sind, beispielsweise das Bevorzug eigener Dienste in eigenen Diensten. Also man bietet eine Google-Suche an und deswegen sagt man, na wir haben doch auch noch einen Musikdienst, dann voten wir den mal immer hoch in unsere eigene Google-Suche. DSA und DMA, also Abkürzung für Digital Service und Digital Markets Act, bedeutet zum einen Geld-Sanktionen und zwar bis zu 10% des weltweiten Umsatzes, was im Falle von Apple durchaus bedeuten kann, 27 Milliarden Dollar Schadensersatz. Sondern neben diesen Geld-Sanktionen ist auch ein Mechanismus für Zerschlagungen mit drin. Es könnte also sein, dass es für Europa spezifisch legislative Aktionen gibt, die sagt WhatsApp ist hier in Europa ein eigenes Unternehmen. Das ist nicht verflochten mit Facebook, sondern es steht in Konkurrenz zu Facebook mit eigenem Management und so weiter. Es geht um Smartphone Betriebssysteme ganz konkret. Wer darf da Appstores darauf betreiben? Wer darf dort die NFC-Schnittstelle benutzen, also Hardware benutzen? Können wir es zulassen, dass Apple einfach sagt, bei uns geht nur Apple Pay und nicht, was weiß ich, Deutsche Bank Pay, solche Sachen. Darf man, nur weil man das Betriebssystem anbietet, eigene Dienste bevorzugen. Das hatten wir schon mal vor Jahrzehnten mit Microsoft. Die sagten, wir haben Windows, also gibt es ja auch unseren Browser dazu. Und dann kam Europa und hat gesagt, wie wär's denn mal mit einem Firefox Browser oder sowas? Und dann hat man das. Und ganz neu, Interoperationalität. Wenn man ein Datensilo hat, gehören einem dann die Daten oder bleiben die eigentlich beim Nutzer? Und wie weit muss man dem Nutzer entgegenkommen, wenn er sagt, ich möchte gerne meine ganze Freundesliste und meine bestehende Kommunikation rüber zu ThreeMar oder wohin auch immer haben. Dann natürlich ganz groß, das hat Frank Rieger, gestern gab es einen neuen Alternativlos-Podcast, kurz thematisiert. Entfernung illegaler Inhalte ist durchaus auch als Einfallstor zu verstehen, dass man von staatlicher Seite sagt, da werden wir schon Grundgesetz schreiben, dann auch zu unseren Gunsten. Wir sagen jetzt, was hier gelöscht gehört, worüber nicht gesprochen werden darf, wenn es gelöscht ist, oder wo es klare Beschwerdegewege gibt, wie wir den Nutzer darüber aufklären, was hier gesperrt wurde. Und, das ist wirklich sensationell, die Justizjahre dieser Unternehmen könnten demnächst selber persönlich haften für Sachen, die da nicht ordentlich hinhauen. Das ist neu, denn bisher war es so, dass Unternehmen irgendwas machen, und dann heißt es, ja, da kümmert sich das Justizjahr drum, und das macht es dann irgendwann mal, und keine Ahnung. Und was, wir müssen jetzt 25.000 Euro zahlen, weil der Landesdatenschutzbeauftragte von Schleswig-Holstein sagte, dass demnächst kann es durchaus sein, dass jemand ins Gefängnis kommt, wenn durch, was weiß ich, Mopping das zu verhindern gewesen wäre, hier ein Mord passiert, dann ist dann nämlich ganz schnell mal Beihilfe oder sowas. Also in deren Sicht geht es ja wirklich ans Eingemachte, wenn die Justizjahre persönlich haften müssen. Anderes Szenario, die Typen sitzen alle in Amerika, hier in Europa passiert irgendwas und plötzlich trauen die sich nicht mehr nach Deutschland einzureißen, weil die dann hier sofort verhaftet werden, weil es eben solche Vorfälle gab. Also in deren Sicht ist diese persönliche Haftung, das haben wir beim Diesel-Skandal auch schon gesehen, wo Manager plötzlich im Gefängnis sitzen und so weiter. Dienste müssen ab sofort halbjährlich, also müssen nicht ab sofort, das ist der Gesetzesvorschlag, der jetzt die nächsten zwei Jahre diskutiert wird.
Darf ich mal gerade eine Rückfrage stellen? Du hattest das jetzt mit Frank Rieger angesprochen. Wie sähe das denn aus, dass der Staat sagt, gut, jetzt entscheiden wir mal, was für uns geht und was nicht geht? Also wir haben ja gewisse Dinge, die stark tabuisiert sind, oder wir haben ja auch grundgesetzliche Sachen, gegen die nicht verstoßen werden. Gewaltandrohungen werden ja gerade bei Twitter schon sehr, sehr stark geahndet, übertrieben dann auch. Also wir haben ja schon diesen Fall gehabt, dass jemand ironisch schreibt, kommt ein Paar aufs Maul, und dann wird man plötzlich gebannt, weil es als Scherz oder als Zitate eines Hip-Hop-Leads gemeint war.
Genau. Wenn dieser Gesetzesvorschlag so durchgeht, wie für eine EU-Kommission angelegt, bedeutet das für die Unternehmen, beispielsweise sie müssen halbjährlich eine Einschätzung über ihren eigenen Gefährlichkeit für die Gesellschaft abgeben. Da wird z.B. von signifikanten systemischen Risiken gesprochen. Da könnten wir alles drunter fassen, was du jetzt beschrieben hast. Also Aufruf zu Gewalt, Manipulation von Wahlen. Das hatten wir bei Twitter in Deutschland auch schon. Menschen sagen, die Bundestagswahl ist am 17. Oktober. Dabei war sie am 23. September. Und es könnte ja Leute dazu verführen, dann nicht zur Wahl zu gehen, weil sie dachten, der wäre später. Damit hätte man diese Wahlen eingegriffen. Diese Twitter-Accounts wurden reihenweise gesperrt. Das war erst mal nur angedroht, im Sinne von, beim nächsten Mal wirst du richtig gesperrt, aber man war dann erst mal weg vom Fenster. Und wir haben natürlich das große Thema Terror und so weiter und so fort. Und je nachdem, wie diese Risiko-Selbseinschätzung ausgeht, die erst mal eine Berichtspflicht der Unternehmen bedeutet, könnte es durchaus sein, dass da so eine Art, wie nennt man das denn? Da kommt dann so ein Verbindungsoffizier ins Spiel. Also so eine Schwerpunktstaatsanwaltschaft, die so eng mit Facebook zusammenarbeitet, dass das auch schon politische Bande ist und man sich gegenseitig darüber informiert, woher wieder was passiert und dann schwarze Listen geführt werden. Wir haben ja auch aus Basis von anderen Urheberrechtsgesetzen und so weiter die ganzen Thematisierung von Filtern, Upload-Filtern, die also schon Sachen finden, bevor sie überhaupt veröffentlicht werden. Es hat bisher technisch noch nicht besonders gut funktioniert. Die ganzen Videos aus Christchurch und so mussten wirklich manuell gelöscht werden. Also da saßen wirklich Menschen da, haben auf Christchurch als Begriff gewartet und dann diese Posts einfach pauschal gelöscht. Das wird natürlich alles sehr viel raffinierter und es kann durchaus sein, und da würde ich Frank Rieger als Gefahr und Potenzial erstmal beipflichten, es kann durchaus sein, dass man hier, wie soll man sagen, so ein inhaltliches Sieb oder so mitinstalliert politischerseits in Form von Signalwortlisten oder Verhaltensauffälligkeiten oder wie auch immer, die dann dazu führen, dass illegale Inhalte entfernt werden, bevor das jemand sieht. Und das kann zugunsten eines Unternehmens sein, Urheberrecht, zugunsten des Staates, Terror, da fällt natürlich ganz schön viel drunter, wenn man das will, ohne dass man von außen mitbekommen kann. Siehe China. Siehe China, genau, das ist vorbildhaft dafür, ohne dass man von außen mitbekommen kann, was passiert. Allerdings auch vorgesehen ist, dass Forscher besondere Zugänge ins Backend erhalten, das heißt noch nicht komplette Algorithmentransparenz. Aber wenn konkrete Fragestellungen entstehen, dann sollen die auch beantwortet werden können durch Forscher, die dann über die Zugänge, die normale Nutzer erhalten, wirklich mal reingucken können, um beispielsweise Wahlkämpfe zu untersuchen. Weil Wahlkämpfe werden sowieso untersucht, jetzt finden sie digital statt und es liegt natürlich auf der Hand, dass man sich das auch mal genau anschaut. Auf der anderen Seite, Werbung wird verpflichtend so transparent, dass man selber sich darüber informieren kann als Nutzer, warum man welche Werbung angezeigt bekommt. Also wenn man auf Instagram alle drei Bilder eine Werbung sieht, muss da irgendwo ein Link drin sein, wo klar ist, weil du gestern bei Amazon oder wo auch immer das und das gesucht hast, kriegst du jetzt diese Werbung angezeigt. Also so tiefschirfend wäre das dann. Der Ansicht, wir haben es hier mit ganz vielen Novellen, nicht nur einfach Romanen zu tun, um das von eben auch zu greifen, sondern hier sind wirklich neue Sachen dabei.
Also buntenerhörten Begebenheiten.
Genau, das ist nicht nur Semantik, es sind hier unerhörte Gegebenheiten, die hat es noch nie vorher gegeben. Und das muss man nochmal vergleichen, das ist jetzt die EU-Initiative und bisher haben wir nur auf Amerika geguckt, was die Politiker dort machen. Jetzt haben wir zum ersten Mal, dass wir auf europäische Politiker gucken können, was sie machen, während in Amerika auch solche Bemühungen da sind, allerdings wird das dann auch den Richtern überlassen. Wir hatten ja hier schon thematisiert dieses Jahr, wie in Amerika eigentlich so Vetocracy-mäßig alle sich selber auf den Füßen und im Weg stehen und da gar nichts passiert, während allerdings die Richter, beispielsweise die Staatsanwaltschaften in 36 amerikanischen Staaten jetzt Google wegen der bevorzugten Eignerdienste Kartellrechtsverfahren anhängig haben, über die dann einfach Richter befinden. Und das, was Richter dann da sagen, ist dann dort auch Gesetz. Also das muss man dann so sehen. Es sind also sehr unterschiedliche Handgehensweisen an dasselbe Problem. Und wir kommen jetzt zu der großen Pressekonferenz, die dazu gab. Und danach schauen wir nochmal in eine Online-Diskussion der Grünen, die man gerne auch als Podium gemacht hätte, aber wie es halt so ist. Es ist Pandemie, man macht das dann online und es ist wieder so ein typisches Video, was eigentlich die großen Fragen behandelt, aber nach drei Wochen 300 Leute auf YouTube gesehen haben oder sowas. Also wieder typisch. Wobei man sagen muss, diese Pressekonferenz von Vestager als Marktkommissarin haben wir jetzt auch nicht so viele gesehen. Also hier sind wir auch weit im vierstelligen Bereich noch. Naja, zum Anliegen, und Vestager hat es gleich am Anfang gesagt, da ist sie ganz deutlich und so ein bisschen historisch geworden.
Ich habe mich gefragt, wie man eine Methaphore geben kann, denn diese zwei sind ziemlich komplexe Proposale. Und das Beste, was ich mir vorhin gedacht habe, war das erste Traffic Light, das in den Straßen eine Anordnung brachte, das in den USA in Cleveland, Ohio war. Das wurde als eine Antwort auf eine große technologische Verletzung der Invention der Autos.
So, wir haben immer gelacht über die Datenautobahnen, was wir in dem nicht betrifft. Nein, genau richtig. Wir haben jetzt Datenautobahnen und da fahren auch schon Autos und Schwerlasttransporter und kaputte Schwerlasttransporter und Gefahrguttransporter, aber nirgendwo in der Verkehrsampel.
Und das ist das, was die Digital Services Act alles darum geht.
So, digitale Straßen und wir wollen es absichern. Und jetzt haben wir glaube ich das erste Problem, deswegen gehen da auch die Alarmsignale bei Frank Rieger an. Wie sichert man das digitale ab? Das digitale sehen wir ja nicht. Wir haben ja nur unseren Bildschirm, wir wissen ja nicht, was dahinter passiert. Ganz anders als in der analogen Welt. Wenn wir durch so ein Rewe gehen, wir sehen sehr wohl, wo schon ein bisschen Schimmel am Gemüse ist und wo die Milch ausläuft und so. Und das wird uns ja alles verschleiert. Das heißt, wir wissen ja gar nicht, wo ist es hier eigentlich gefährlich. Also wer entscheidet, was hier gefährlich ist und wie die Sicherheitsmaßnahmen aussehen.
Aber im Straßenverkehr wissen wir, wie es läuft oder warum irgendetwas so ist. Oder wir können uns manchmal vielleicht über eine Ampelschaltung noch wundern, wer die so merkwürdig eingestellt hat. Aber sonst ist es doch sehr transparent.
Genau, wenn wir auf der Autobahn fahren, den Drängler auf der linken Spur, der mit Lichthupe und so da durchrauscht. Diese Kategorie haben wir alle dieselbe und wir wissen genau, das ist der Bösewicht hier. Der muss mal rausgezogen werden. Das sehen wir alles im Digitalen nicht. Wir wissen nicht, wo kommt die Werbung her, was passiert her, warum hat mir der Algorithmus das ausgewählt. Wir wissen einfach nur, 80 Prozent der YouTube-Sägesachen werden über den Algorithmus gesteuert, über die Liste, Empfehlungen hier und so. Bei TikTok noch viel krasser, da setzt man sich ja gar keinen. Da kommt ja nur noch algorithmisch einfach das nächste Video. Da kann man ja wirklich nicht darauf vertrauen, dass jetzt das aktuelle Video des besten Freundes und so weiter da auftaucht, nur weil er eins gemacht hat. Also in deren Sicht Twitter natürlich auch. Alles ist ja ganz komisch, wir verstehen nichts, alles ist algorithmisch irgendwie getrieben. 500 Signale entscheiden darüber, was Amazon uns anzeigt. Was sind das für 500 Signale, in welcher Gewichtung stehen die miteinander? Also hier sehen wir einfach die Drängler nicht. Den Gefahrgutstransporter, der schon brennt und der längst schon aussortiert gehört, das sehen wir einfach alles nicht. Und in deren Sicht liegt hier auch die Entscheidung nahe, dass wir jetzt kollektiv sagen, die Politik entscheidet das für uns. Nur da müssen wir wirklich der Politik vertrauen, dass sie uns nicht genauso verarscht wie die Silicon Valley, weil dann könnten wir es auch lassen. Wer uns dann verarscht, das darf nicht die Frage sein, wer uns hier verarscht, sondern wir möchten, dass die Politik uns nicht veralbert. Und in deren Sicht kommt es einfach darauf an, dass alles zivilgesellschaftliche Engagement, das wir haben, also der CCC, Epicenter Works, Max Schrems, der da im Nachhinein guckt, ob die Gesetze eingehalten werden und so weiter, dass das alles gut funktioniert. Naja, Anliegen Nummer drei. So, also Sachen müssen etwas schneller passieren als bisher und man muss darüber informiert werden, was da passiert. Und da kann man sagen, da greift jetzt schon so ein bisschen die historische Erfahrung, die man einfach hat, beispielsweise mit diesem Google Urteil in Spanien und so weiter. Da gab es ja dann auch viel Widerstand zur Frage, also überlassen wir es jetzt erstens den Unternehmen selbst zu entscheiden. Also der Risikobericht soll jetzt demnächst von Google kommen, darüber wie gefährlich Google ist, wie viel Kontrolle über diesen, also haben wir dann so eine Art BaFin nur noch, die sagt, das ist aber toll, was uns die privaten Wirtschaftsprüfer da aufgeschrieben haben, die gleichzeitig die Bilanzen schreiben für diese Unternehmen. Also ist das so ein Konstrukt, wo wir sagen, ne, das ist sinnlos oder haben wir es dann mit einer ernsthaften Auseinandersetzung zu tun? Werden Berichte angefertigt darüber, was gelöscht wurde? Wer kriegt diese Berichte und so weiter?
Und ganz wichtig auch, dass die User die Möglichkeit haben, sich zu erklären, denn das ist ja oft was fehlt, dass einfach irgendwas gelöscht wird. Man weiß nicht so genau, was habe ich eigentlich verbockt. Und dann hat man auch kaum Möglichkeit, Einspruch zu erheben. Oder dauert jetzt halt sieben Tage oder einen Monat, bis man wieder darf, wenngleich es eigentlich schon geklärt ist, weil es sich um was anderes, ein Zitat oder sonst was, handelte.
Genau, wer kriegt eigentlich den Einspruch? Da stellt sich ja die Frage, bisher ist es ja so, klar, man hat ein Einspruchsrecht in Deutschland, nämlich ein europäisches, und man kann dann einen Brief, der juristisch eindeutig ist, auf Englisch an den Irländischen Datenschutzbeauftragten schicken, von dem man weiß, der hat nur zwei Mitarbeiter, und da liegen schon 20.000 Briefe. Also in der Hinsicht, ja, Gesetze haben wir das schon, aber wie gut funktioniert es eigentlich? Also bekomme ich jetzt in Hessen eine Stelle, die mir Facebook-Sachen klärt oder sowas, wenn auf Instagram irgendwas passiert? Na ja, das muss jedenfalls, also da macht sie jetzt Druck, das muss alles viel schneller geschehen, wenn da was zu regeln ist und dann aber auch transparenter. Da stehen sich schon zwei Sachen im Weg. Weiteres Anliegen. Es ist natürlich sehr herausfordernd, kann allerdings auch zu großen Dingen führen, denn diese Aufklärungspflichten haben ja immer, die sind ja immer doppeldeutig, die gehen ja nicht, da geht es ja nicht nur darum, dass ich mich jetzt als super interessiert herausstelle und dann das wirklich lese. AGBs zum Beispiel, warum gibt es AGBs? Nein, nicht damit ich die alle lese, sondern damit klar ist, was gilt, wenn beispielsweise Verbraucherschützer die lesen, für mich. Also hier kann man auch eine Gegenorganisation aufbauen, die wirklich als Ombudsman auf Seiten der Nutzer steht, vielleicht auch von den Nutzern finanziert wird, kann man sich ja durchaus vorstellen. Ich wäre gerne bereit, es gibt verschiedene Initiativen, Organisationen, die sich so zusammenfinden, wo sich einfach zehn Juristen sagen, wir setzen uns jetzt hier hin und schreiben was, Freiheitsrechte oder so in Deutschland, wir schreiben jetzt hier Verfassungsbeschwerden, und zwar für den Nutzer, weil er es erstens nicht alleine kann und weil es über sich ihn selbst hinausgeht. Er ist ja nicht alleine betroffen, sondern es sind ja alle betroffen. Und dass man sowas jetzt organisiert bekommt. Also wenn das als Anlage so mit drin wäre, dass man Algorithmen Transparenz für einen informierteren, interessierteren Teil des Publikums macht, der dann gleichzeitig stellvertretend als Anwalt oder wie auch immer in der Auftritt, das finde ich mal gut. Und dieses fünfte Anliegen, was ich...
Momentan klicken wir ja auch alle einfach alles möglich weg, möglichst weg, dass wir uns nicht damit beschäftigen. Jetzt gerade gibt es ja wieder diese Sachen. Man öffnet die Seite und kann dann noch mal eingeben, wie viel soll dann getrackt werden und und und. Und das ist ja auch wirklich nach dem Prinzip des Nutchings dann angelegt, dass also Feuer rot leuchtet, was gerne das Unternehmen hätte, was man alles, nämlich dass alles irgendwie verfolgt wird, dass die am liebsten noch nach Hause zu einem kommen können. Und das sieht immer so aus, als sei das das Normale, was jetzt einfach einfach anzuklicken ist und dann irgendwo leicht grau unterlegt, kann man dann sehen, nee, nur das in sehr eingeschränkter Variante. Wer macht das schon? Und ich habe mich ja selbst schon dabei ertappt, dass ich dachte, gut, ich würde ab sofort, glaube ich, im Monat fünf Euro zahlen, wenn ich nie mehr was anklicken muss. Und wegen mir können sie dann alles tracken. Also einfach, ja, das klingt jetzt ganz, ganz furchtbar, weil wir immer über diese Themen reden. Aber bisweilen ist man so genervt davon, wenn man wirklich viele Seiten gerade öffnet, schnell irgendwas sucht und jedes Mal klickt man sich wieder dadurch. Muss jetzt immer noch mal schauen, dass man auch ja nicht alle Tracker anklickt. Das ist etwas, was auch einfach an einer Praxis vorbeigeht. Und wenn es selbst mir schon so geht, dass ich sage, oh Gott, ich habe eigentlich keine Lust mehr darauf, dann weiß ich ja, dass Leute, die gar nicht für Datenschutz oder so sensibilisiert sind, sofort sagen können, macht was er wollte damit, aber lasst mich bitte nichts mehr klicken.
Genau, und das ist wahnsinnig knifflig, weil man kann natürlich diese Entscheidung auslagern in eine Ombuds-Stelle, die für ein, so sagt, liebes Unternehmen, übertreibst mal hier nicht, die mit denen ausverhandelt, was sinnvoll wäre als, ja, kannst du gerne machen, anzuklicken und was wirklich raus muss. Gleichzeitig kann diese Ombuds-Stelle allerdings immer nur stellvertretend sein, denn die Einwilligung, die muss beim Nutzer bleiben, das war auch bei der Datenschutz-Grundverordnung ganz wichtig, dass man ihn, obwohl er diese AGWs niemals liest, niemals aus der Verantwortung entlässt, weil danach wäre er raus. Und wir wissen nicht, wie sich die Ombuds-Stellen entwickeln, wenn Facebook weiß, wir müssen eigentlich nur die überzeugen, nicht alle Nutzer, sondern wir müssen eigentlich nur die angreifen, sozusagen.
Das kann man mit ein bisschen Geld zustecken.
Genau, und da besteht nämlich eine große Gefahr und deswegen muss die letzte Entscheidung, also die konkrete Einwilligung, beim einzelnen Nutzer bleiben und trotzdem brauchen wir dazwischen eine informierte Stelle, die im Sinne der Nutzer das alles noch mal hin und gerade biegt und das sind ganz große Herausforderungen, die da juristisch gemacht werden müssen.
Das heißt aber, egal was kommt, die nächsten Jahre, vielleicht Jahrzehnte werden wir weiterhin, wenn wir eine Homepage öffnen, irgendwas auf OK klicken müssen, bestätigen müssen und so weiter. Also es wird nicht so sein, dass wir uns wieder durchs Internet bewegen und das nicht permanent machen müssen.
Ja, weil in dieser Liste sind ja alle deine Rechte aufgeführt. Du kannst verhindern, dass du kannst verhindern, dass du kannst verhindern, dass wenn du das alles anklickst, ist es halt bestätigt. Dann hast du es aus der Hand gegeben. Aber der Klick wird glaube ich bleiben, weil es ist also solange deine Rechte bleiben, da auch Widerspruch einzulegen. Solange du ein Recht auf Widerspruch hast.
Das wäre nicht eine Möglichkeit, dass man gleich den Korridor so eng macht, dass es einfach nicht geht. Also das sind ganz ganz viele Dinge, die ich jetzt dort freiwillig zu oder aus Unwissen zustimmen kann. Dass die einfach nicht möglich sind, wie ja auch bei anderen Dingen. Also Unternehmen würden gern so vieles, aber da hat man ja auch ganz enge Korridore. Und da kommt man gar nicht in die Frage, ja geht das auch noch, sondern es geht nicht.
Genau, das könnte man auf zwei Arten machen. Zum einen juristisch. Man kann einfach definieren und sagen, diese Daten dürften niemals, selbst unter, das erkennen wir ja so vom Artikel 1 oder so, nicht mal der Einzige kann einwilligen, dass seine Würde jetzt nicht mehr gilt, sondern die Menschenwürde gilt einfach immer. Das ist allerdings juristisch schwer zu machen, weil du hast auch in der Datenschutz-Grundverordnung schon ein berechtigtes Interesse formuliert. Also Unternehmen können ein berechtigtes Interesse formulieren hinsichtlich, also wenn du uns diesen Cookie verwehrst, können wir dir die Seite leider wirklich nicht anzeigen. Manchmal kann man das auch begründen, dass es dann einfach wirklich nicht geht. Ja, wie bei Google Maps, also wenn du uns nicht sagst, wo du gerade bist, dann können wir dir keine sinnvolle Google-Karte anbieten. So, weil dann zeigen wir dir irgendwas in Afrika und dann funktioniert das nicht. Also es gibt immer berechtigte Interessen, weshalb das immer in der Entscheidung des konkreten Einzelfalls ist, also immer in so eine Liste muss, der du am Ende zustimmen musst. Technisch gesehen kann man das allerdings einschränken. Das machen ja Smartphones, die bieten das zumindest bei Apple und Android sehr gut an, dass man einfach sagt, diese App darf niemals meinen Standort benutzen. Egal welches berechtigte Interesse Instagram jetzt glaubt zu haben, mein Nutzererlebnis zu verbessern, indem sie wissen, wo ich bin. Also Zugriff auf den Standort kriegen sie nie. Diese technische Einschränkung kann einerseits das Betriebssystem pauschal machen, oder, und das ist einer der interessantesten Konflikte, den kommen wir nächstes Jahr zu 100% darauf zurück, Facebook gegen Apple gerade. Facebook hat kein eigenes Betriebssystem, sondern ist darauf angewiesen, dass es auf Smartphones läuft, wo so ein paar Sachen erlaubt sind. Und jetzt sagt Apple einfach, naja, das ist bei uns alles nicht mehr erlaubt. Kannst dich nicht mal darauf verlassen, dass das alles funktioniert. Und jetzt macht Facebook schon ganz große Kampagnen, dass sie sich nämlich Small Businesses nehmen, von denen ja 300.000 oder so weltweit, darauf angewiesen sind, dass sie mit Facebook Kontakt zu den Kunden halten. Und dann sagt Facebook jetzt, Apple zerstört das Business dieser 300.000 Unternehmen, weil sie uns nicht mehr erlauben, alles auf dem iPhone machen zu dürfen.
Das heißt, diese ganzen Shopping-Erlebnisse, die ja immer stärker werden, die auch bei WhatsApp ja stark ausgebaut werden sollen, auch Werbung bei WhatsApp, all das ist ja immer noch in den Kinderschuhen oder noch gar nicht erprobt.
Ja, ein eigener Button, mit dem man bezahlen kann. Dieser große Vorteil bei Amazon, dass man einfach irgendwas auswählt und sagt, mit diesem Button bestätige ich, dass ich das kaufen und geliefert haben will. Genau diesen Button will jetzt auch Instagram zum Beispiel für sich, weil die dann einfach sagen können, also Leute werden daran gehindert, was bei Instagram zu kaufen, weil sie dann, nachdem sie irgendwas toll fanden, auf eine Seite umgelenkt werden, wo plötzlich Kreditkarte abgefragt wird. Und man fragt sich so, welcher Seite bin ich denn gerade, vertraue ich den überhaupt und sagt dann so, nein. Wenn Instagram diesen ganzen Zahlungsprozess abwickeln würde, hätten die Menschen viel mehr Vertrauen, dass das schon irgendwie dann hinhaut, am Ende, wie bei Amazon. Nur dazu müsste Instagram eben Zugriff auf Adressen, Kreditkarten usw. haben. Und diese ganzen Zugriffe kann man sich natürlich so einmal holen und dann immer sozusagen in Hinterhand haben, wenn man es braucht. Aber da geht man sozusagen übers eigene Metier hinaus. Und das macht ja Facebook ganz viel auf fremden Betriebssystemen. Wir sind schon mal vorinstalliert, wenn du dir ein Telefon kaufst, dann ist die Facebook-App da schon mal drauf und so was. Und genau da wird jetzt Facebook ganz schön die Luft, also wirklich die Luft zugedreht. FIFA hat das jetzt ganz toll beschrieben mit diesem. Da wird einem einfach der Sauerstoff genommen. Und das macht eben Apple im Sinne des Nutzers. Klar, die haben damit ein eigenes Geschäftsmodell, dass sie Privacy voranstellen. Aber das ist schon, wenn man sich es mal wirklich überlegt und im Einzelnen so ist das schon im Sinne des Nutzers. Und da kommt Facebook ganz schön hinten dran. Und in deren Sicht gibt es da ganz viele Entwicklungen, die da gerade so in sich greifen. Dieser Digital Services Act ist sozusagen einer, der jetzt diesen Zeitgeist mal aufgreift. Nachher klären wir nochmal kurz, ob das jetzt schon zu spät ist oder nicht, weil ich bin da ganz froh und mutig, dass wir eigentlich noch vor so einer großen Welle, auch wenn der Silicon-Valley schon groß ist, aber wir sind jetzt gerade nochmal vor so einer Welle der nächsten Innovationen, die dann nochmal wirklich die Schlinge enger ziehen um uns Nutzer. In deren Sicht sind wir zeitlich wahrscheinlich gar nicht so schlecht dran. Naja, nächstes Anliegen und das finde ich eigentlich richtig gut. Hier muss man ganz groß homogenisiert werden.
Aber wie es jetzt ist, haben wir ein ganzes Grad der Fragmentation zwischen verschiedenen nationalen Regeln in diesen Bereichen. Platz? Es ist also ein sehr positiver Einfluss für kleine Firmen, die sich in einem echten digitalen Single-Market aufschlagen können.
Das ist vielleicht das komplizierteste Unterfangen, weil sie darüber den eigenen Markt abschließen können. Sie haben die Lawyers, die sie ich gerade nannte, die zum einen die Gesetze verstehen und mitgestalten können als Lobbyisten. Und junge Unternehmen, wo drei Leute einfach eine Idee durchsprügeln, haben die nicht. Es gibt jetzt ganz viele Sachen, die diese Start-ups hindert, daran groß zu werden, beispielsweise, dass sie sich in Servern einkaufen, die von Google oder Amazon betreut werden, die sich dann dieses Geschäftsmodell genau angucken und relativ früh kopieren. Ist ja auch so ein großes Problem, das kommen wir dann gleich drauf. Oder aber, dass man es mit einer wirklich unklaren Gesetzeslage zu tun hat. Und diese Homogenisierung, die Verstacker hier anstrebt, widerspricht diesem Google- und Facebook-Sinne in der Hinsicht, dass sie es einfach machen wollen, übersichtlich, und eben nicht einfach die Menschen wollen Regulierung, weil das mit Facebook über die Strenge schlägt, und dann macht man halt irgendeine Regulierung. Nein, man macht jetzt eine ganz kontrollierte Regulierung gegen die Regulierungsansinnen von Google und Facebook. Und das ist glaube ich superschwer zu argumentieren. Ich kann mir gar nicht vorstellen, wie man das in einer Tagesthemsendung thematisiert. Dass man sagt, man macht eine Regulierung, aber nicht die Facebook-Regulierung. Also dass man nicht einfach diesen, ah ja, und Facebook wünscht sich ja auch Regulierung, was für ein tolles Unternehmen, sondern dass es hier Regulierung gegen Regulierungsansinnen steht.
Wir haben ja auch im Salon Brad Smith besprochen, den Microsoft-Anwalt, der sich auch natürlich Regulierungen wünscht, aber ein bisschen anders verstanden dann.
Ganz genau, so, und dann, das ist sozusagen das eine, um den Start-ups Hilfen zu geben. Und hier möchte man grundsätzlich auch den Markt mal im Blick behalten, was über Name eigentlich.
What is in here is an obligation to notify if you acquire a smaller company that will not meet the merger thresholds. As you will probably know, we have been working with this for quite some time in order to make sure that we will actually see these acquisitions. So this is one of the things that we do. We ask for a notification if if one of the the companies in the scope of this legislation, if if they acquire a smaller company, but will also proceed on the work that we're doing with with member states in order to have the national competition authorities to notify us if they see something in the marketplace and they wonder shouldn't someone look at this much closer.
So als vor einigen Jahren Facebook WhatsApp gekauft hat für 19 Milliarden Dollar, wurde das deutsche Kartellamt gefragt, ja und es geht einfach so, interessiert euch das gar nicht. Und das deutsche Kartellamt hat gesagt, nee wieso, wie viel Umsatz macht WhatsApp denn in Deutschland? Und dann haben wir die Antwort, null, null Euro, nee was soll uns das dann interessieren? Also da haben wir keine Kategorie, da wird bei uns nichts getriggert juristisch, das steht bei uns nicht im Gesetz, dass wir dann tätig werden sollen. Und gleichzeitig war allerdings eine Marktdurchdringung von 50-60% oder so gegeben, aber eben null Euro. Und in der Hinsicht ist da wieder die Frage, was bedeutet eigentlich Monopol, dass eine Preisgestaltung zum Nachteil des Nutzers stattfindet? Ja gut, das kann man halt beim Öl, bei Bananen und überall sagen, aber nicht hier. Und hier will man jetzt es sichtbar machen, wenn solche Akquisitionen stattfinden, also diese und auch kleinere dann natürlich. Thierry Breton ist der französische Dienstabummsminister, ich weiß gar nicht, Industriekommissar oder sowas.
Ja, der ja auch selbst aus einem großen Tech-Unternehmen kommt, der ja Mark Zuckerberg auch so eine kleine Standpauke hielt, das hatten wir im Juni oder Juli.
Genau, das ist kurz mitgebracht.
Da sagt er mal, der CEO ist verantwortlich, da braucht man nicht lange rumreden.
Genau, die Legende besagt, dass Vestager hier ein richtig hartes Gesetz haben wollte und Breton so ein bisschen lockerer machen und so. Deswegen hat er gar nichts groß beizutragen gehabt in der Pressekonferenz. Er hat nur so ein paar Sätze noch eingefügt. Wir wollen hier nichts blockieren, sondern uns einfach nur mal die Übersicht verschaffen, uns organisieren. Naja, es ist jedenfalls, wird von den Autoren behauptet, das richtige Gesetz zur richtigen Zeit, denn auch in Amerika gibt es jetzt einen Sinneswandel, den haben wir ja schon dokumentiert.
Jetzt ist die USA, wir, die Australier, die Kanadier, die Japaner sind ein Teil einer globalen Gespräche, wie man Dinge balance, denn das Wichtigste hier ist, mit welchem Größe die Verantwortung kommt. schiff, natürlich erst das Pandemie, dann die Klimaschutz, aber auch auf digitale Erreiche konzentriert, ist das kein Problem für unsere US-Kollegen. Sie sehen es natürlich anders, weil es ein anderer Markt ist und ein anderer Nation, aber ich denke, dass die Debatte sehr anders sein wird, als wenn wir das fünf Jahre vorhin getabelt hätten.
Also ein großer Sinneswandel in der Welt, auch in Amerika, das glaube ich. Das ist da auch so, die sehen das auch als Problem. Und die haben auch Angst vor der Größe dieser Unternehmen. Mittlerweile gibt es ja wirklich Bestrebungen, vor allem bei den Demokraten zu sagen, wir müssen es jetzt zerschlagen, und zwar nur, weil es so groß ist. Die Details sind so ein bisschen nebensächlich. So, es wird Sanktionen geben.
Und letztendlich die Verabschiedung. Denn keine Legislaturperiode ist besser als die Verabschiedung. Wir behalten das Land der Oregoner Prinzipien, das alle so gut kennen.
So, Europa macht jetzt eine Verordnung. Die gilt als Verordnung im Text, wie die Europäische Kommission sie schreibt, in den nationalen Mitgliedstaaten. Das ist keine Richtlinie, die dann erst in nationales Gesetz umgeschrieben werden muss. Trotzdem, die Sanktionen werden nicht europäisch eingetrieben, sondern in den Mitgliedstaaten. Das ist so ein bisschen komisch. Man fragt sich auch, was sollen das? Können wir jetzt nicht einfach mal all in gehen sagen, Europa macht, sowie auch die Strafen, die jetzt Google gegenüber und so in den Raum gestellt werden, einfach von der EU-Kommission ausgesprochen werden. Und das ist dann eben Geld, über das die EU-Kommission verfügt. Und dann habe ich hier bei den Grünen diese Diskussion da verfolgt. Das ist wirklich schlimm eigentlich. Wolfgang Kreisig ist Landesmedienanstalt Direktorenvorsitzender. Also die Landesmedienanstalten, die in den Bundesländern sitzen, haben selber noch mal als Direktorien jeweils, also die Direktoren zusammen, ihre kleine Gesprächsrunde, in der er gerade Vorsitzender ist. So, und der schätzt jetzt mal die Sachlage zum Digital Services Act, wie folgt ein?
Also wir meinen, dass es wichtig ist, dass all diese Maßnahmen, die ja sehr wichtig sind, nicht nur aus rein ökonomischer Gesichtspunkten reguliert werden müssen, sondern eben auch die Medienpolitik im Blick haben müssen und eben auch dadurch die kulturellen und nationalen Besonderheiten in der Medienregulierung.
So, er möchte also Zuständigkeiten bei sich belassen, weil es ja auch noch eine inhaltliche Dimension gegen den gibt. Also hätte man jetzt...
Wie sieht diese inhaltliche Dimension da aus, frage ich mich jetzt gerade, denn diese Angehörigen entscheiden ja jetzt nicht darüber, ob weiterhin deutsche Dramen aufgeführt oder publiziert werden.
Genau, und irgendwie fragt man sich so, hat er einfach Angst darum, dass seine Behörde dann abgewickelt wird? Ja, also das ist einfach da nicht mehr, keine Ahnung. Also die Leser, die ich so habe, ist, diese Landesmedienanstalten, wie zum Beispiel auch die Votans in den Zeitungen, ganz anders mit je, aber gleiche Problemlage, die kümmern sich immer noch ums Fernsehprogramm. Für Turnisten, die zensieren halt, was im Fernsehen passiert. Und dann kommt mal einer und sagt, Fernsehen, also die Leute gucken eigentlich Facebook, Twitter, Instagram und TikTok. Und wenn du dich da nicht drum kümmerst, bist du ein bisschen ab vom Schuss und dann kauft auch keiner mehr deine Zeitung. Und das haben die Landesmedienanstalten auch festgestellt. Ja gut, also klar, wir haben jetzt irgendwelche, keine Ahnung, Regelungen zum Fernsehprogramm, aber TikTok, keine Ahnung. Jetzt kommt die große EU und möchte da ein Gesetz vorschlagen. Und die stellen so fest, hätten wir uns mal drum kümmern müssen, irgendwie vor zehn Jahren. Ja, also völlig abgemeldet. Entsprechend kritisch sieht er das jetzt auch, dass die EU da kommt.
Deswegen muss, muss eine Regulierung oder kann nur eine Regulierung nur so aussehen, dass eben nationale oder ausreichend Spielraum bleibt für die nationalen Behörden, um Kultur und Medienvielfalt auch sicherzustellen. Und deswegen sehen wir den Ansatz auch einer europäischen Regulierungsbehörde tatsächlich sehr kritisch, weil wir einfach meinen, dass es gute Alternativen gibt. Also gerade wenn Sie die Ärger sehen, die ja jetzt auch an prominenter Stelle in diesen beiden anderen Initiativen genannt worden sind, ist die Ärger gerade auch die einmalige Chance, durch entsprechende Verfahrensabstimmung und eine enge Verknüpfung an diese Digital Services Act oder an die europäischen Institutionen da tatsächlich hilfreich zu wirken, sich abzustimmen, eine einheitliche Rechtsdurchsetzung sicherzustellen und gleichzeitig aber auch die Vielfalt der Nationalstaaten eben abzubilden.
Was für Quatschargumente. Ich finde, die sollten jetzt mit dem Fernsehen und dem Ratio dann untergehen und das mal Europa ins Regeln lassen.
Also ich muss jetzt mal ganz kurz fragen, der und seine Kollegen argumentieren dann mit Google und Facebook-Anwälten rum oder was? Du hast doch nicht im geringsten die Ahnung, also ich bin ganz entsetzt, also der redet wirklich darüber, als sei das jetzt irgendwie Facebook und Google, die würden jetzt auch ein schönes Theaterprogramm machen und da haben wir aber auch noch ein Wörtchen mitzureden. Da müssen wir auch schon mal gucken, dass auch deutsches Theater und vielleicht auch polnisches noch vorkommt. Das geht ja nicht, dass wir die nationalen Eigenheiten, also hat er mal bei TikTok reingeguckt oder Instagram oder irgendwas? Also das ist, ich weiß gar nicht von welchen kulturellen Inhalten geht es denn jetzt bei diesem Digital Service Act, also was meint er denn jetzt da gerade?
Ja, das sind diese Menschen, die haben noch nie selber ein YouTube-Video hochgeladen, die haben sich noch nie TikTok als App runtergeladen, sich das mal angeschaut. Die haben keine Ahnung, wovon sie sprechen, sie sehen ja einfach nur ihre politischen Fälle davon schwimmen und behaupten einfach, wir sind doch hier super gut aufgestellt, um mit Google und Facebook und wem auch immer zu verhandeln, was. Und dann gilt es, die nationalen Eigenheiten, kulturellen Eigenheiten zu beachten. Frag mal sich ein bisschen, wovon redest du?
Und das konntest du ja schon damals sehen, als Google alle Bücher digitalisiert hat. Dann haben die sich ja auch mit irgendwelchen Bibliothekschefs getroffen, die keine Ahnung von oben und unten hatten und gesagt haben, ja schön, dann haben wir das alles mal gemacht, wenn ihr das mal alles digitalisiert. Da waren ja dann so ein paar aufrechte Franzosen, gab es noch, die dann sich dagegen standen. Ich glaube, das war der Leiter der Nationalbibliothek in Paris, der bekam dann von Google Besuch und bekam auch noch so ein albernes Kaffeeservice mitgebracht und das ließ der dann einfach auf den Boden fallen, um den schon mal zu signalisieren. Mir konnte er diesen Spaß nicht machen. Aber sonst triffst du natürlich auch solche Leute, das war dasselbe auch mit dem Google Cast, die den Landkreisen alle noch mit Applaus begrüßt wurden, dass die jetzt mal schön die Straßen alle vermessen und so wäre das ja da auch. Und sobald Google denen noch 500 Euro gibt, dass damit die Theatergruppe noch gefördert wird, dann machen die ja alle Türen und Tore auf.
Genau, wir haben ja von Google diese große Bemühung, den Journalismus zu unterstützen, das kulturelle Leben. Hier werden irgendwelche Stipendien ausgeschrieben und so. Plötzlich hängt man da so drin und die Landesmedienanstalten glaube, irgendwie sie könnten da jetzt, nachdem sie 20 Jahre lang sich das einfach angeschaut haben und nichts getan haben, könnten sie jetzt, weil, oh nein, deren große Bedrohung ist nicht Google oder Facebook, sondern Europa. Also die machen jetzt Lobbying in Deutschland gegen Vestager und so, und das ist wirklich schlimm. Die Alexandra Gese ist im Europäischen Parlament DSA-Schattenberichterstatter. Also es gibt ja immer einen Berichterstatter, das ist derjenige, der wirklich zuständig ist, um für das Parlament dann den EU-Kommissionsvorschlag durchzuarbeiten. Also der geht dann zu jedem einzelnen Abgeordneten hin und fragt, hast du hier Änderungswünsche? Und dann schreibt er die auf, fasst die irgendwie zusammen, macht da einen Vorschlag draus, da wird das zuerst im eigenen Ausschuss zur Abstimmung gestellt und dann eben im ganzen Parlament. Und dann hat sich irgendwie zwei Jahre später oder so, es kann manchmal ein bisschen dauern, das Parlament entschieden. Da kommen dann immer so ein paar Sachen rein, wie die EU-Kommission hat gesagt, 6 oder 10 Prozent des Jahresumsatzes ist hier Strafe zu zahlen. Dann kommt das Parlament und sagt, wir wollen aber 12 oder so was. So in der Art. Und zu dem Berichterstatter hat jede eigene Fraktion noch mal einen Schattenberichterstatter. Mit der gleichen Aufgabe der Koordinierung, aber nicht mit dieser großen Sprecheraufgabe dann für das ganze Parlament. Und das ist, glaube ich, für die Sozialdemokraten oder die Grünen oder wer auch immer, die Alexandra Gese, die hier Mitte diesem Gespräch ist, mit dem Landesmediendirektorenchef. Und die sagt dann noch mal Folgendes.
Und ich habe die höchste Wertschätzung für die deutschen Landesmedienanstalten. Das möchte ich deutlich sagen. Aber der Kampf, Google gegen die Landesmedienanstalt des Saarlands, ich weiß, wie das ausgeht, ja, mit ein bisschen praktischem Realismus.
Praktischer Realismus ist eingezogen. Und das finde ich auch gut. Google gegen die Landesmedienanstalt Saarland, da wissen wir alle, wie das ausgeht. Da kommt es nicht gar nicht zum Kampf. Das ist einfach, wir strecken unsere Waffen wieder.
Das wird kurz gelacht irgendwo.
Genau, in deren Sicht hoffe ich, dass das Europaparlament sich hier ganz klar durchsetzt und sagt, diese Behördenleistung wird jetzt auf europäischer Ebene erbracht. Und hier gibt es nur eine Adresse für Google und Facebook und nicht 17.000. Gut, zu den Sanktionen. Westhager greift noch mal auf, um wie viel Geld geht es da. So, Google soll mal nicht kommen und sagen, wir haben in Europa aber nur so wenig Umsatz gemacht, deswegen nur so und so. Nein, der weltweite Umsatz wird herangezogen und dann wird gesagt 10% davon bei Verstößen. Bei der Datenschutz-Grundverordnung hat das ja auch schon ganz gut als Drohung und manchmal auch schon mit wirklich ausgesprochenem Schadensersatzanspruch funktioniert. Da sind sie ja auch im Prozentbereich des Jahresumsatzes. Also da geht es ans Eingemachte. So, dann.
Lass mich noch eine Zwischenfrage stellen. Diese Regulierungen, die wir jetzt auch alle wollen, inwieweit gefährden die denn auch vielleicht oder ermöglichen etwas für Leute, jetzt nicht Start-Upper, sondern ich nenne sie jetzt mal so Content-Kreatoren, wie zum Beispiel Podcaster oder YouTuber, die ja genau vor solchen Regulierungen auch sich oft fürchten, weil das für sie dann bedeutet, dass sie sich ganz vielen Dingen unterwerfen müssen, dass man dann zum Beispiel sagt, ja, aber hier keine Clips mehr zeigen oder so. Das heißt, haben wir da nicht auch eine ganz große neue Gefahr drin? Also ich sehe da ja zumindest bei unserer Politik in der Bundesrepublik überhaupt gar kein Interesse an diesen Sachen. Also hier guckt man, geht es den Verlegern gut und sonst bekommen die ein paar Milliarden, aber es interessiert sich ja hier niemand für Content-Kreatoren im Internet.
Also das Zauberwort heißt hier wahrscheinlich eins der vielen Inter-Operationalität. Die Frage ist ja, wenn ich von Twitter woanders hingehe, kann ich dann beispielsweise auf meine Follower-Schafft weiter zugreifen. Also so wie man sagt, also Inter-Operationalität wird ja bisher immer so im Sinne der Message thematisiert. Kann ich aus einem Apple iMessage-System eine Nachricht abschicken, die bei einem User ankommt, der nur Facebook-Messenger benutzt? Da stellt sich ja die Frage, kann ich eigentlich als YouTube-Creator, während meine YouTube-Fans auch alle Facebook-Accounts haben, kann ich eigentlich hier Botschaften loswerden, die nicht nur auf der Plattform, sondern die dann auch meine Facebook-Follower erreichen, selbst dann, wenn mich YouTube rausgekekelt hat und solche Sachen. Die wären natürlich alle erstmal zu klären, denn nein, in der Hinsicht, glaube ich, spielen Content-Creator erstmal keine große Rolle, jedenfalls nicht in diesen konkreten Fragestellungen, wie du es jetzt behandelt hast, aber es gibt da Content-Creator davon abhängig sind, dass der Service, den sie nutzen, ein großer ist, denn dieser Login über die Follower schafft. Also dass man einen YouTube-Channel aufmacht, weil man weiß, da sind einfach 60 Millionen Menschen in Deutschland mit einem Account, die einfach klicken können. Das ist anders als bei einer Webseite, wo man den Leuten erst mal erklären muss, wie man hier folgt, dann kommen die immer wieder zurück, keine Ahnung, am Ende bleibt einem nur ein Newsletter zu schreiben, weil E-Mail selbst ist, was funktioniert. Das ist ein zweites großes Gesetz, denn alles, was wir bisher thematisiert haben, betrifft den Digital Services Act und Services betrifft im Grunde alles, was online stattfindet, groß, klein, kreuz und quer, das ist sozusagen vertikal einmal durch die Landschaft geschlagen. Und dann gibt es ein Spezialgesetz, das kümmert sich nur um die Bergspitzen, nur da, wo die absoluten Könige der digitalen Welt, eigentlich nur Amazon, Google, Facebook und Apple und so, ja, also man könnte es fast namentlich eigentlich machen, wo die drin sitzen. Und das ist der Digital Markets Act, der für Gatekeepers abkommt.
Und wenn wir nun zum Digital Markets Act kommen, ist das unsere zweite Proposale.
Der Digital Markets Act spezifisch für Gatekeepers verwendet. Gatekeepers werden auf eine besondere Rolle in dem Markt verwendet.
So, das Google-Urteil ist jetzt sechs Jahre her, 2014 war es glaube ich. Da hat Spanien geurteilt, Google ist nicht einfach nur ein Publisher, sondern es gibt hier ein Recht auf Vergessen, das für die Zeitung nicht gilt, für Google aber doch. Und das Argument war wie folgt, Google hat eine eigene Form von Profilbildung, dadurch dass die Kreuz und Quer sich aus allen Publikationen was zusammensuchen und aufbereiten und auffindbar machen für jemand, der diesen Rechercheaufwand so nicht getroffen hätte, wenn es Google nicht gäbe. Das haben sich ja die beiden Google-Gründer immer gewünscht, dass jemand einfach zu Google geht, in das Suchfeld was eingibt und dann ist es wie recherchiert. Als hätte man tagelang recherchiert, findet man es einfach ganz schnell bei Google. Und diesem Anspruch, dass es Unternehmen hatte, ist dann merkwürdigerweise ein Gericht nachgekommen, in dem es gesagt hat, ja, das stimmt, ihr seid ein besonderer Publisher. Ihr seid nicht einfach nur eine Zeitung, die redaktionell entscheidet, dass dieser Typ irgendwie ans Tageslicht gezerrt werden muss wegen diesem und jenem Verhalten und dann aber auch vergessen wird, weil diese Überschrift, die ist eben nur an dem Tag des Ereignisses interessant und danach ist das Archiv, auch wenn noch auffindbar im Internet, aber es ist halt im Archiv, es taucht nicht auf Seite 1 auf. Und das macht Google eben anders. Bei Google gibt es keine Seite 1, sondern jemand trägt oben einen Namen ein und dann kommt ein Verhalten, das vor zehn Jahren mal aufsehen erregend und dann auch von öffentlichem Interesse war, wieder auf, obwohl es diesen Kontext, das es aktuell gar nicht gibt. Und diese Art von Profilbildung ist eigen. Und da macht Google was Besonderes und Neues und dem muss man Rechnung tragen. Und das hat Vestager aufgegriffen und gesagt, ne, wir haben es hier mit Gatekeepers zu tun, die wir nicht vorher schon in der Geschichte so fanden, sondern das ist jetzt eine eigene und eine neue Kategorie und für die machen wir jetzt ein Gesetz. So und hier definiert sie jetzt Gatekeepers.
Erstens sind Gatekeepers großartig, im Hinblick auf die Anzahl der Verlust, die Marktkapitalisierung und sie sind aktiv in vielen Mitgliedstaaten.
So, wie beliebt war eigentlich der Spruch, wir können jetzt alle im Internet teilnehmen, es gibt ja keine Gatekeeper mehr. Keine Redaktion entscheidet mehr das und so weiter. Genau, und jetzt kommt sie und sagt, ne, es gibt Gatekeeper, Google. Google steht zwischen den Zeitungsredaktionen und dem Nutzer. Und das ist einfach so, zur Hälfte steht er einfach dazwischen. Es gibt Gatekeeper zwischen, da strickt jemand irgendwas zusammen oder hat ein kleines Produktionsbusiness in China und dem Nutzer in Amerika, und das ist Amazon. Und Amazon überflügelt da auch alle mit 95% Marktanteil, wo dann Jeff Bezos sagt, es ist nur ein Channel. Es ist kein wirklicher Markt, das erinnerst du dich, es ist ja nur ein Channel online. Solche Sachen, und wir können ja wirklich sagen, dieses Gesetz nimmt zielt auf Unternehmen, die wir eigentlich namentlich können, nennen können. Und sie geht ja noch mal die Sachen durch, die Argumente, und die Namen, um die es geht, tauchen wirklich automatisch auf. So und wir interpretieren jetzt einfach was sie sagt. Google hat einfach dadurch, dass sie keine Ahnung, dass jeder Nutzer zu Google geht, wissen sie unglaublich viel über den Nutzer. Google weiß zum Beispiel, was in Zeitung am nächsten Tag steht, weil sie können ja einfach gucken, was hat denn die FAZ-Redaktion den ganzen Tag so gegoogelt. Und dann spezifischer, was ist, wenn Google jetzt mehr Wissen über eigene Konkurrenten hat? Also das große Problem, deswegen hat sich auch diese Klage schon angestrebt und auch das Urteil schon gesprochen. Google hat damals einen eigenen Shopping-Dienst gehabt, gleichzeitig konkurrierten aber in der Google-Suche viele Shopping-Dienste miteinander, aber nur Google, nur der Anbieter vom Google-Shopping-Dienst, nämlich Google selbst, wusste, was die Nutzer eigentlich wollen und konnte deswegen den eigenen Dienst bevorzugen, was sie auch getan haben. Also dieses, was sie hier so neutral formuliert, ist ganz konkret bezogen auf, in dem Falle Google oder auch Amazon. Amazon ist gleichzeitig der Marketplace, so heißt es ja auch, für viele andere Anbieter und Amazon weiß, was die Nutzer suchen und warum sie es bei anderen Anbietern kaufen und macht dann mit Amazon Basics das eigene Gegenprogramm. Also in der Ansicht ist das hier ganz gezielt auf eine wirklich echte Problemlage, die es gibt.
Also ist hier der Punkt, dass die Geheimdaten keine mehr mit der Daten, die sie von allen Unternehmen, die sie im Kampf gegen sie haben, verwandeln. Das bedeutet eine Datenwahl, die die Beparierung der Daten in den verschiedenen Geschäftslinien generiert. Zweitens ist Interoperability. Dies betrifft die Situation, wo ein Geheimdaten ein zusätzliches Service erfordert.
So, ein Beispiel wäre Apple Pay. Ah, will ich gerade nicht sagen. Ich sage einfach, ein Anbieter entwickelt eine Zahlungsmethode, nämlich das Telefon einfach an das Zahlungsterminal halten. Warum, nur weil Apple das Telefon hergestellt hat, kann dieser Dienst eigentlich nur von Apple angeboten werden. Die Schnittstelle zu dem NFC-Chip kann ja auch anderen Diensten zur Verfügung gestellt werden. Warum kann nicht die Commerzbank, Google Pay, Garmin Pay, warum können die da alle? Warum kann man nur mit Apple Pay auf dem Telefon bezahlen? Das wir sie hier geklärt haben.
Und ein interessanter Vorschlag ist ja, dass sie sagt, man müsste darüber nachdenken, dass man also Dinge trennt. Einmal brauchen jetzt zum Beispiel Suchmaschinen wie Google diese ganzen Daten, um die Suchmaschinen zu optimieren. Aber dürfen sie diese Daten auch verwenden, um damit dann selbst zum Beispiel einen Online-Shop zu machen, um zu wissen, gut ab morgen wird der Run auf Socken oder BHs oder was weiß ich noch größer sein oder Babynahrung. Und deswegen erweitern wir unser Programm und versuchen, die anderen nach unten zu verdrängen. Solche Teilungen klingen jetzt erst mal abstrus, aber die gibt es tatsächlich. Also ein Beispiel wäre BlackRock. Ich weiß nicht, wie gut das da wirklich gelöst ist. Zumindest ist es dort formal so und auch juristisch selbstverständlich geregelt. BlackRock hat ja immens viel Wissen dadurch, dass die überall beteiligt sind, aber dann nochmal besonders dadurch, dass BlackRock Teams ja zum Beispiel auch die EU beraten und dass die Einblicke haben in Staatsfinanzen und und und. Die könnten ja dieses Wissen nutzen, um damit zu spekulieren. Also die könnten das ja gleich an ihre Leute weitergeben, die Aktien zeichnen, da ist es ein bisschen komplizierter und sagen, ja hier sieht ganz schön schlecht aus in Polen, da könnt ihr schon mal gucken. Da gibt es ganz klare Trennungen und es gibt dann solche internen Polizisten, die wirklich überwachen, dass keine Kommunikation zwischen diesen beiden separierten Bereichen stattfinden kann. Das heißt, das ist denkbar und es ist auch schon umgesetzt.
Klar, im Bankensektor, ich meine Goldman 6 berät Griechenland, wie man beim Euro eintritt und haben deswegen vorher das Wissen darüber, dass sie jetzt im Euro beitreten, was für viele Unternehmen eben das eine oder andere bedeutet. Dann kann man auch seine Investitionsentscheidungen festmachen. Wir haben diese Form von, sie sprach ja von Datensilo. Also wenn ihr schon Datensilo macht, dann richtig, und zwar auch intern. Sie wissen bei der EU-Kommission, dass das immer schlecht funktioniert. Wenn man zum Beispiel Facebook sagt, ja, ihr könnt Instagram und WhatsApp kaufen, dann dürft ihr diese Daten, die ihr habt, also die Nutzerprofile des einen Dienstes, dürfen nicht gleichzeitig jetzt auch die Nutzerprofile des anderen werden. Also da ist Interoperationalität sozusagen intern ausgeschlossen. Drei Jahre später sagt Facebook einfach, ja, wir haben deine E-Mail-Adresse hier in Beiden gefunden, deswegen matchen wir jetzt einfach mal deinen Facebook-Messenger und deinen Facebook-Profile-Account. Und da ist man ganz schön enttäuscht worden bisher auch. Und da hat ja auch Zuckerberg jetzt die Fragen, die ihm da immer gestellt wurden, nicht besonders gut beantwortet, bis hin zu, also wirklich arrogant, das haben wir ja auch gesehen, wie er hier in Europa aufgetreten ist. Und in deren Sicht schlagen die da jetzt ordentlich zu. Genau, wir hören mal weiter. Sie hat noch einen weiteren Aspekt, wo wir auch wieder ein Unternehmen rausfinden, was sie für eine neue Erklärung für die NfZ-Solution finden können. Ja, also da war jetzt die ganz konkrete NfZ-Ship, der im Apple-iPhone drin ist. Da nimmt sie genau alle Schlagworte, Ranking und so weiter. Das ist einfach auf die Gugelsuche bezogen. Da braucht man gar nicht groß drum rum.
Kann man es denn auch noch weiter beziehen auf zum Beispiel Spotify? Da gab es ja jetzt dann auch in den vergangenen Wochen immer mal wieder bei kritischen Podcastern einiges zu lesen, zu hören, auch bei Twitter, dass naja, diese Spotify Originals selbstverständlich auch obengerenken werden. Natürlich eine Verdrängung leisten, natürlich nicht mehr dafür sorgen, dass wir es da mit einer offenen Plattform zu tun haben, wo einfach der oben kommt, der am beliebtesten noch ist oder am meisten gehört wird oder am neuesten ist, sondern dass dort auch, ja, wie eigentlich ist, mit einem proprietären Markt zu tun haben und das ja deshalb dann auch durchaus skandalös ist, dass das Öffentlich-Rechtliche so stark mit Spotify kooperiert.
Genau darauf zielt es ab, glaube ich. Spotify ist ein ganz hervorragendes Beispiel für, weil am Ende willst du vielleicht tatsächlich, bei Google ist das ja auch so ein Problem, wie gehst du mit eigener Werbung in deinem Programm um? Ja, wenn du einen Podcast hast, der Werbung macht, musst du dann an Spotify Geld zahlen, so wie du bei Apple auch an Apple Geld zahlen willst, wenn in deiner App Werbung ist oder kannst du das nicht auf eigene Faust sozusagen machen, ja? Und sagen, na, zwar erreichen wir dich nur über Apple, den Nutzer, aber das heißt ja noch nicht, dass man diese Stellung da so ausnutzen kann. Also in der Ansicht ist Spotify da wahrscheinlich ein sehr wichtiges Beispiel demnächst. Die sollten sich das auch genau anschauen, was da passiert, genau wie Amazon. Also sie argumentiert hier genau das Amazon-Problem.
Because for instance this example that I took about the use of data, that you cannot use the data of the people that you compete with just because you can.
So, und so wie es hier auf Amazon bezogen ist, betrifft es eben auch wirklich auch Apple Pay.
And that is also a very important element of fair competition.
So, und dann kommt Breton und sagt nochmal, ja, Gatekeeper-Definition ist vor allem an Größe orientiert. Das ist aber nicht der ausschlaggebende Punkt.
This is not, and we will never say here, as I said, of course, we believe that this company or that company are too big. We don't say that here in Europe. We respect companies. But we say that the bigger they are, the more obligations they may have to fulfill what is important to us. In other words, what it is, is to give clarity.
Das finde ich ziemlich gut, denn das schließt an, weil er sagt, das machen wir in Europa nicht. Wo wird denn das gemacht? Allein mit größeren Angaben. Das ist in Amerika. Das ist Elizabeth Warren, die auf einer so Pressekonferenz ganz genervt. Diese Details, was für ein Scheiß. Das Unternehmen ist zu groß, sagt er. Und das einfach als Argument nimmt. Und das macht ihn wirklich Angst am Silicon Valley, weil da können sie dann auch nicht dagegen lobbyieren. Größe ist nun mal Größe. Marktkapitalisierung, Umsatz und so weiter. Da kann man dann auch nicht mehr mit irgendwelchen Spezifika kommen. Hier macht man auch diesen etwas auf gewisse Einzelheiten abziehenden Ansatz. Breton, noch mal auch wieder beschwichtigend. Allerdings finde ich das ganz gut, denn er dreht das Vorzeichen so ein bisschen. Um was geht es eigentlich?
Nicht hier, nicht auf dieser Seite der Welt. Man hört nie andere, natürlich Margaret und ich, das zu sagen. Das ist nicht gegen, sondern für. Es ist für unsere öffentlichen Bürger, es ist für unsere Demokratie, es ist für unsere Unternehmen, es ist für Innovationen, es ist für unsere Konpetition und nicht gegen irgendjemand.
Das finde ich eine sehr gute Herangehensweise. Einfach sagen, wofür dieses Gesetz ist. Für Demokratie, für Marktwirtschaft, für Unternehmen. Und zwar nicht die großen, sondern dann für die Chancen der kleinen Unternehmen und so weiter. Vielleicht kann man diesen positiven Dreh, positiven Sinne von das Vorzeichen umgedreht, so ein bisschen beibehalten in der öffentlichen Kommunikation. Das bekommt den allen, glaube ich, sehr gut. So, wann greift dann der DMA, also der Markets Act im Vergleich zum Services Act, wann ist man Influencer, hier wird die Größe mal kurz genannt.
Bigger size, bigger responsibility. I don't want to be too big to be wrong. We will also also in terms of condition of course the number of, for DMA, the number of customers, same thing if it's B2C, 10% of the European population, and if it's B2B, 10.000 of these customers.
So, also wenn du ein Service für Einzelmenschen als Nutzer bist, dann müssen es 10% der Europäer müssen bei dir einen Account haben. Das trifft also auf Facebook, YouTube und so locker zu. Twitter nichts, glaube ich, weiß ich nicht. Also 10% Schwelle oder wenn du Unternehmen als Kunden hast, 10.000 Unternehmen. Wer weiß, Slack und so, die kommen ja da wahrscheinlich ziemlich zügig dran. Shopify, wahrscheinlich auch. Vestager erklärt hier noch, das ist atemberaubend.
Wir haben darüber gesprochen, ob wir die Unternehmen, die wir denken, in diesen Versammlungen nennen. Es sind drei Mitgliedstaaten mit einem Plattform-Service, 45 Millionen aktive Kunden pro Monat, 10 000 jährliche Kunden pro Monat. Wir haben uns entschieden, dass es die Unternehmen selbst gibt, die sie identifizieren. Deshalb wäre es für uns hier primitiv, das und das und das zu sagen, und definitiv nicht das und das und das.
Wenn ich mich nicht verhört habe, wir hören den Anfang nochmal, dann hat sie hier wirklich eine krasse Überlegung. Sie haben halt wirklich überlegt. Sollen wir um den heißen Kleid drum rum reden oder sagen wir einfach, das ist ein Gesetz gegen Google, Amazon, Facebook.
Und dann argumentiert sie so schön, aber die erkennen sich dann darin und sie werden dann auch feststellen, dass sie vielleicht nicht in allen Punkten Überschneidungen haben und dann müssen wir auch noch mal schauen, wie wir dann damit umgehen. Aber sie sagt ihnen ganz klar, das geht um euch. Sie hätten mit die 45 gerade mal da aufschreiben können.
Genau und jetzt hat man den Kriterienkatalog, bei dem die Unternehmen erst mal selbst sagen müssen, falls sie nicht dazugehören wollen. Und dann findet eine Untersuchung statt, bei der die EU-Kommission statt feststellt. Ihr habt zwar gesagt, ihr seid keine Gatekeeper, aber nach unseren Kriterien seid ihr Gatekeeper. Also kommt hier dieses Gesetz. Dass wir jetzt überhaupt eine Gatekeeper-Definition haben, ist schon mal sensationell. Also es ist gar nicht, wir haben es alles noch im Ohr, wie sie da saßen, guck und so. Wir haben Marktanteil von 45 Prozent. Das ist jetzt nicht dominant und wir sind ja ganz klein. Und wie Zuckerberg da vorlegte, also die größte Suche ist Google. Der größte Videoanbieter ist YouTube und so. Und sich da ganz unter den Scheffel stellt und so. Und hier einfach zu sagen, nee Leute, ihr seid jetzt mal eine Gatekeeper.
Die Amazon hat ja auch so eine schöne Definition. Also wenn man die gesamte Wirtschaft nimmt, was alles gehandelt wird, dann sind wir nur ein ganz, ganz kleiner Teil davon. Ja klar, dann ist Marketplace, spielt keine Rolle.
Also in der Ansicht ist das ganz, ganz großartig. Und die Überlegungen gehen natürlich, also sagen wir mal so, hier sitzen natürlich junge und ältere Leute. Also der Cheffe, der jetzt die Fehlerführung hatte, heißt Prabhat Agarwal. Klingt zwar nicht deutsch, aber es ist ein Deutscher. Genau wie auch bei der Datenschutz-Grundverordnung. Jetzt habe ich seinen Namen vergessen, der Deutsche, der auch Kabinettsleiter von Junker wurde, dieser Professor, Jura-Professor und so weiter. Also diese hohe, das sind ja alles wirklich wichtige Leute, die das machen. Und das sind immer alles wieder Deutsche, in dem Fall jetzt auch. Und die haben natürlich erst mal so ganz viele Ideen. Und da werden sehr viele rausgekegelt, bevor es dann hier wirklich zu einem Gesetzesvorschlag kommt, den die EU-Kommission in dieser Form, wie wir es jetzt haben, als Vorschlag in den Raum gestellt hat. Also das ist jetzt der Vorschlag der EU-Kommission. Und die Alexandra Gese kommt hier noch mal drauf zu sprechen in diesem grünen Panel. Was hatte man sonst noch für Ideen? Und zwar bis hin zu, wir haben auch darüber abgestimmt im Europaparlament und haben eigentlich hier schon eine Meinung zu formuliert. Und das ist wirklich krass, was man eigentlich unvorstellbarerweise so fasst. Aber was man tatsächlich so als könnte man mal machen, sollte man mal machen, wofür man sich entschieden hat.
Jetzt kommt das DSL nächste Woche. Wir haben im Europaparlament zweimal im Rahmen von Eigeninitiativen darüber abgestimmt, ob wir ein Verbot von personalisierter Werbung wollen. Und das Europaparlament hat zweimal gesagt, ja, wir wollen das. Ich weiß aus Gesprächen mit der Kommission, dass das angedacht worden ist. Mein letzter Stand ist jetzt, aber Herr Agarwal, bitte vielleicht noch was zu sagen. Freue ich mich drauf, dass es nicht kommen wird, dass es nur diese Opt-in, Opt-out Möglichkeit geben wird, wo uns die Verleger schon gesagt haben, das ist für uns keine Option, weil Google und Facebook bekommen die Einwilligung immer irgendwo und wir dann eben nicht. Das wird uns massiv schaden.
Also die wollten jetzt tatsächlich personalisierte Werbung verbieten. Das wäre ja, also ich kann mir gar nicht vorstellen, dass dafür gestimmt wurde.
Nee, du hättest dann auch nur noch den Screen Estate eigentlich, also nur noch die Werbefläche als Fläche im Sinne von sie wird halt genutzt, so wie Werbefläche in der Stadt, aber nicht mehr dieses spezifische Zugeschnittensein auf. Irgendwas hängt immer im Hals, egal. Und sie kommt noch mal mit den Zahlen um die Ecke. Was bedeutet das eigentlich für diese Unternehmen, wenn man denen das nähme?
Das ist das Geschäftsmodell der großen Plattformen. 98 Prozent der Einnahmen von Facebook basieren auf digitaler, verhaltensbasierter, personalisierter Werbung. Daher kommt der Reichtum, daher kommt die Macht von Facebook. Nicht, weil das ein besonders innovatives Unternehmen wäre, sondern weil sie einmal eine gute Idee gehabt haben und die jetzt so ausschlachten, indem sie diese Daten über uns sammeln und uns manipulieren. 78% des Umsatzes von Google kommt genau hierher. Und gemeinsam kontrollieren diese beiden Unternehmen mittlerweile 84% des globalen digitalen Werbemarktes.
Ja, und da ist vor allem über diese Personalisierung so gewachsen. Also da ist einiges Potenzial, um den das nicht herauszuhalten.
Also mir ist es wirklich schleierhaft, dass das eine positive Abstimmung ergeben hatte. Also weil ich mir von Anfang an gedacht hätte, da würden jetzt gleich Leute sagen, was sie wollen.
Zwei Mal sogar.
Da kriegt man nie eine Mehrheit für. Zwei Mal, ja.
Genau, zwei letzte Clips, die ganz aufschlussreich sind. Zum einen, wie hat dieses grüne Panel begonnen? Der Moderator findet am Anfang deutliche Worte.
Der DSA kann deswegen wohl ohne Übertreibung, aber mit leichtem Pathos als der zentrale Battleground der europäischen Digitalpolitik bezeichnet werden.
So, und dann Tabea Rösner, die kürzlich noch in Mainz Oberbürgermeisterin werden wollte und für die Grünen medienpolitische Sprecherin ist, hat als allerletzten Gedanken in diesem Panel Folgendes gesagt.
Ja, also wenn ich mir die Diskussion anhöre, ich fände es ja wirklich mal charmant zu sagen, wir nehmen ein komplettes Verbot vor, weil wir in der Vergangenheit an vielen Stellen uns immer wieder schwer getan haben, als Politik auch das Treiben der großen Plattformen einzuhägen. Und wir kennen seit Jahren die Knackpunkte, ob das der haarsträubende Umgang mit Nutzer-Daten ist, mit wettbewerbsrechtlichen bedenklichen Übernahmen oder mit Ausnutzung der Marktmacht. Von daher fände ich ja mal ein richtig striktes Vorgehen. Ganz spannend, muss aber natürlich nicht zwangsläufig sein. Nur ich wahrscheinlich schon enttäuscht, wenn es nur eine Opt-out-Regelung gäbe.
Wäre doch mal charmant, alles stillzulegen.
Ja, wäre glaube ich auch ein gutes Geschäft für die Influencer. Denn das sind dann so mit die letzten Figuren, an die sich die Unternehmen direkt richten können. Da können die sagen, ok, wenn ich bei denen Werbung schalte, dann habe ich hier den 18-Jährigen, der gerne Sport treibt und Hip-Hop hört. Weil es von einem sporttreibenden Hip-Hopper hier gerade alles lanciert wird oder irgendeine anderen Influencerin. Für die Influencer wäre das eine goldene Zeit, die da noch bevorstünde.
Ja, das ist durchaus möglich. Das ist ja auch Leola Port, von dem haben wir schon viele Ausschnitte aus Podcasts gehört. Der sagt ja auch, Leute laden halt meine Podcasts runter. Und wenn dann Unternehmen zu mir kommen und sagen, der macht ungefähr so 8 Millionen im Jahr Umsatz, aber die machen halt auch Vollprogramm jeden Tag 8 Stunden und so. Und der sagt halt, ich kann ihnen jetzt einfach mal sagen, was wir für ein Angebot machen und was wir so hören aus unserer Nutzerschaft, wer sich bei uns meldet. Und das sind halt irgendwelche IT-Leute, die sich auskennen, die gutes Einkommen haben und so weiter. Und sie müssen halt jetzt überlegen, wir haben hier 70.000 Downloads für diese und jene Sendung, wollen sie da werben oder nicht? Und dann überlegen die Unternehmen halt. Ja, und dieser Zugriff auf jeden einzelnen Nutzer, der ist da gar nicht so ausschlaggebend irgendwie, sondern das ist halt, klar, wenn das als Angebot da ist, will man es natürlich wissen, wir sind ja alle neugierig, aber das hindert, also dieses Verbot davon, sich das genauer anzuschauen, sondern wirklich sagen, okay, wir gehen mal in das Klientel, das wir bei dem oder jedem Influencer vermuten und werben da einfach, da wäre man wahrscheinlich in der Werbewirkung nicht so sehr weit weg, als wenn man das jetzt durch irgendwelche Algorithmen leiert, in der Ansicht, warum nicht, ja, einfach mal stilllegen, den ganzen Scheiß. Hat man sich allerdings nicht so durchgerogen, aber jetzt geht die Lobby-Schlacht los, wir werden das nächstes Jahr detailliert beobachten, vor allem in diesem Podcast und die Unternehmen aus dem Silicon-Valley wissen, dass es hier jetzt schon zwei Abstürkungen im Europaparlament zu diesem Thema gab und man da zweimal dafür votiert hat, personalisierte Werbung zu verbieten. Also dieses ganze Silicon-Valley Geschäftsmodell und in deren Sicht Happy Fighting, würde ich sagen. Ich wünsche allen Beteiligten viel Spaß.
Da könnte es etwas ernster werden, aber es gibt ja auch noch Konzerne, denen geht es richtig gut und da ist auch kein Ende abzusehen. Und da würde ich sagen, wir sprechen jetzt mal über Disney. Da gab es den Investor Day im Dezember und Disney hat dann mal so erzählt, was sie vorhaben, wie sie sich verändert haben und auch was sie schon erreicht haben. 2019 gab es diesen Investor Day und da haben sie ihren Investoren verkündet, wie sich das verhalten wird mit Disney Plus, welche hohen Erwartungen sie haben. Sie haben gesagt, also bis 2024 erwarten wir 60 vielleicht sogar 90 Millionen Abonnenten bei Disney Plus. Und das ist ja dann für die Investoren ein Grund, mehr einzusteigen oder weiterhin das Geld zu geben. Das ist eine Veranstaltung, die ist öffentlich, also die kann man bei YouTube sehen, dauert so knapp vier Stunden, ist ja durchwachsen, interessant.
Ja, es ist keine große Disney Show. Ich hätte gedacht, es ist so ein bisschen.
Na ja, ein bisschen. Wir werden das gleich hören. Aber jetzt 60 bis 90 Millionen hat man erwartet bis 2024. Jetzt schreiben wir das Jahr 2020, also ein Jahr später. Wie viele Abonnenten hat Disney Plus? 86 Millionen. Das heißt, die haben jetzt schon die Spitze erreicht von dem, was sie in fünf Jahren erwartet hätten.
Aber dieses Jahr wurde einiges beschleunigt. Wir haben es besprochen, Pandemie. Und Disney hat dieses Jahr aufgrund nicht erfolgter Film, Drehleistungen, nicht geöffneter Freizeitparks und so weiter fünf Milliarden Miese gemeldet. Also in der Hinsicht ist das große Erfreune Rede.
Davon war jetzt keine Rede. Es war ein bunter Tag, den die dort veranstaltet haben. Aber man hat selbstverständlich jetzt nicht hier gesagt, aber eigentlich geht es uns gerade sehr schlecht, sondern man hat eigentlich, man hat davor zurückgeschreckt zu sagen, zum Glück hatten wir Corona, denn alles läuft gerade so gut für unsere Streaming-Dienste. Das hat man nicht gesagt, aber eigentlich suggeriert man das in jedem Moment. Und man hat jetzt eine neue Prognose gewagt. Bis 2024 will man bei Disney Plus 230 bis 260 Millionen Abonnenten haben. Plus noch, wenn man Hulu dazurechnet, also PayTV von Disney, auch inzwischen digital, dann möchte man insgesamt 300 bis 350 Millionen Abonnenten bis 2024 haben und das sei doch eine schöne Aussicht auf den Shareholder-Value.
Schaffen die locker, habe ich wirklich keine Sorgen. Mir fällt gerade auf, es gibt ja eine Pflichtveranstaltung, wo sie über ihr Minus reden müssen, das sind ja die Investor Calls, die immer noch, damit das juristisch glatt läuft, über Telefonkonferenzen gemacht werden. Die sind also maximal unattraktiv, was die Shows als Veranstaltung angeht. Die stehen aber trotzdem in der Welt, die sind nämlich auch öffentlich. Die müssen auch geöffnet werden. Das ist ganz interessant, sich diese Facebook Investor Calls anzuschauen, weil da kommt am Anfang immer dieses, und dann kommen aber Fragen an Mark Zuckerberg und er erzählt da immer ganz schön interessante Sachen eigentlich. Und vielleicht hat Disney das auch diesmal ein bisschen größer gemacht und das auch Investors-Dings genannt und so, um denen was gegenüberzustellen, weil diese 5 Milliarden Miese, die sind halt wirklich krass. Also ich habe selten von Unternehmen gehört, dass man mal 5 Milliarden Miese in einem Jahr macht. Das ist dann irgendwie tüssend grob, kriegt es mit dem Stahl wirklich nicht hin und so. Und dann gibt es dann mal so ein richtig krasses Jahr, wo sie alles abschreiben. Also in der Ansicht hat Disney auch einen ganz schönen Rekord aufgestellt hier. Und es lag irgendwie dann doch nahe, wenn man jetzt so drüber nachdenkt, dass man da jetzt so ein Augen zu und durch nach vorne Ausblick jetzt gibt.
Ich lasse jetzt mal die ganzen Namen weg, die dort auftauchen. Ich werde es nur sagen, wenn es Bob Iger höchstpersönlich ist, der ehemalige CEO, der da auch noch mal einen Auftritt hat, weiterhin eine wichtige Rolle bei Disney spielen wird. Wir hören jetzt mal, da sage ich Ihnen dann noch Bob Chappick. Der sagt etwas, das ist doch um was ganz anderes geht, Stefan. Dieses Geld und so, jetzt hör doch mal.
And more than 1 billion people have identified themselves as true fans with a deep emotional connection to our brands.
Ja, das ist aber so ein bisschen creepy.
Ja, sehr, sehr. Und jetzt möchte man natürlich auch noch die Tradition ein bisschen wachrufen. Jetzt kommt Musik zum Einsatz und wir erinnern uns an Walt Disney.
In his words, we keep moving forward, opening new doors and doing new things because we're curious and curiosity keeps leading us down new paths. And I strongly believe it is this perpetual willingness to constantly challenge the status quo.
Ja, das tut Disney wirklich nie, den Status quo verändern, sondern eigentlich immer herrschende Verhältnisse bestätigen. Das ist die Ideologie aller, aller Disney-Filme. Und hier wird nochmal so getan, als sei Disney in irgendeiner Weise revolutionär. Nein, war es nie auch schon, so wollte es nicht. Zeit nicht höchstens zeichnerisch, aber nie ideologisch inhaltlich für den Film. Und man sieht dann aber auch in der fortlaufenden Präsentation, dass es erstmal gar nicht um Stories im Sinne von guten Geschichten geht, sondern gute Erfolgsgeschichten werden da erzählt und vor allem gute Erfolgsstrategien. Ich habe jetzt mal rausgegriffen, wie man sich in Indien aufstellt. Und in Indonesien ist das dann ganz ähnlich. Wir hören da mal rein.
Mit einem schnellen, wachsenden Mittelklasse und einer hohen, diskretionären Spende ist Indien eine erhebliche Marktwahl.
Haben jetzt viel über die bekannten Namen gesprochen, als wir uns jetzt hier über Vestager unterhalten haben. Na ja, die können eigentlich schon mal langsam Disney mit rein nehmen, denn das wird das nächste große Ding. Die steigen ja wohl auch bei der Bundesliga mit ein, wenn ich das da richtig verstanden habe, bei der Konferenz, bei ganz, ganz vielen Sport-Events. Und was sie machen, um sich als Plattform zu etablieren, ist zu kooperieren mit regionalen Inhalten. Das heißt, sie schauen, was gibt es da eigentlich in Indien? Okay, da gibt es ein Konvolut an Bollywood-Filmen. Die kaufen wir mit auf. Wir nehmen noch drei vielleicht schwächelnde Sender, die aber wichtig sind dazu und bieten dann so ein Gesamtpaket an. 7, 99 Dollar oder was auch immer. Und dann können wir uns dort platzieren und können damit auch alle anderen verdrängen. Also das sind eigentlich ganz große Verdrängungsstrategien, die hier angedacht werden. Und das funktioniert nicht nur damit, dass man jetzt sagt, wir haben tolle Disney-Filme, die wollt ihr doch sehen. Und wir machen ganz viel Neues, sondern es bedeutet auch, dass man schaut, was funktioniert da gut. Und wir verstehen uns als Plattform. Wir haben die Infrastruktur und kombinieren das Ganze und gehen dann bis hin zum Cricket-Event, was ja eigentlich mit Disney immer gar nichts zu tun haben sollte.
Ja, also Fußball ist ja in Deutschland so ein bisschen mit Daseinsvorsorge irgendwie. Es wird ja immer so unter der Hand irgendwie als... Und deswegen sind ja auch die Öffentlich-Rechtlichen da dabei. Solange die natürlich nur die Apps machen, die dann auf dem Fernseher neben anderen Apps zur Verfügung stehen. Also so wie jetzt Smart TV machst du halt an. Und dann ist ja so YouTube, Amazon, YouTube, was gibt's noch? Keine Ahnung. Und dann halt so Disney Plus als eine App unter vielen. Da würde ich sagen, ja, dann ist es halt eine App unter vielen. Und dann stellt sich die Frage, sollte jetzt in der Disney Plus App auch anderer Content mit drin sein? Und ich sage, nö, weil dann kann man ja die App eine weitergehen und finde das dann da. Wenn es dann allerdings irgendwie, und das haben wir ja bei Facebook auch gesehen, dass sie plötzlich so ein Portal anbieten, also so ein Bildschirm, den man sich zu Hause hinstellt. Also wenn es so in die Richtung geht, dann wird es natürlich knifflig, weil dann greifen wieder andere künftige Gesetze, wie wir gerade so gehört haben. Also in der Hinsicht, mal gucken, wie sie sich da so entwickeln. Welche Rolle sie auch auf Smartphones zum Beispiel spielen.
Zum Beispiel, und Sport ist ganz, ganz wichtig. Das denkt man hier gar nicht, denn Disney kennt man vom Kino und kennt man jetzt durch diese Streamings. Aber ESP heißt das, glaube ich, dass dieses Sportprogramm von denen ist extrem wichtig, expandiert. Und wir hören mal rein, wie sie sich da auch noch erweitern wollen. Und da kommen wir auch wieder in den Plattform Kapitalismus.
Die ESPN, ABC, ESPN Digital und ESPN Plus Kombination ist eine einzigartige Reach-Maschine. Eine Maschine, die uns ermöglicht, Sportfans best-in-class Produktion und Storytelling zu bringen, wo sie sind. Über unser Portfolio erreicht ESPN mehr als 200 Millionen US-Sportfans in einem Monat. Das ist im Vergleich zu dem totalen Abstand von Google und Facebook. In 2019 und für das 10. Es ist ein sehr wichtiges Thema für uns. Es ist ein sehr wichtiges Thema für uns.
Ja, junge Leute spielsüchtig machen, kann man da auch sagen. Mir ist ja diese ganze Spielsucht gar nicht so klar gewesen. Es gab ja von Böhmermann jetzt auch so ein Video über diese ganzen Glücksspiel-Hainis, die es da gibt. Wie heißt der Knossi oder was? Der das mal kritisch beleuchtet hat und auch dieses merkwürdige Gesetz, das ist Schleswig-Holstein, weiter ein... Es ist ein sehr wichtiges Thema für uns.
Es ist ein sehr wichtiges Thema für uns. Es ist ein sehr wichtiges Thema für uns. Es ist ein sehr wichtiges Thema für uns. Es ist ein sehr wichtiges Thema für uns. Es ist ein sehr wichtiges Thema für uns. Es ist ein sehr wichtiges Thema für uns. Es ist ein sehr wichtiges Thema für uns. Es ist ein sehr wichtiges Thema für uns. Es ist ein wichtiges Thema für uns. Es ist ein wichtiges Thema für uns. Es ist ein wichtiges Thema für uns. Ich glaube, dass man einen unfunktionalen Charakter plötzlich hat, wo es auf YouTube um mehr geht als nur ein schönes Bild von einem tollen Körper oder so. Also das darf vielleicht so ein paar schlummernde Möglichkeiten stecken, weil das sind ja dann immer mal Leute, die dann gleichzeitig, was weiß ich, eigentlich das Business haben, die irgendwelche Nahrungsergänzungsmittel noch zu verkaufen, und weil sie selber so tolle Freizeitsportler sind, die plötzlich sich dann von einem Jahr auf einen Ironman vorbereiten können und den dann auch erfolgreich absolvieren, will man dann nicht von denen noch irgendetwas kaufen und so. Es ist ein wichtiges Thema für uns. Es ist ein wichtiges Thema für uns. Es ist ein wichtiges Thema für uns. Es ist ein wichtiges Thema für uns. Es ist ein wichtiges Thema für uns. Es ist ein wichtiges Thema für uns. Es ist ein wichtiges Thema für uns. Es ist ein wichtiges Thema für uns. Wir haben jetzt YouTube für Musik, YouTube für Kinder. Wie wärs denn mal mit YouTube für Sport? Das ist glaube ich das nächste, was so kommt.
Angeln ist ja schon ganz groß auf YouTube.
Angeln schafft alles.
Ich glaube aber, was du da ansprichst mit diesem Wettkampf, den du gerne beobachten willst, das ist ja generell dieses Challenge-Genre, das es ja für alles gibt. Also wie viel kann ich essen, wie viel kann ich kaufen, wie viel kann ich sonst was machen. Und das gibt es dann auch dort, dass man einfach zwei Leute, die nicht jetzt deshalb interessant sind, weil sie eine Nation repräsentieren oder so, sondern einfach weil sie zwei Leute sind. Der eine ist ein bisschen anders als der andere. Und denen schaut man dann zu, wer kann was schneller, besser oder länger. Ja, also ich kann das ja gar nicht nachvollziehen. Ich sehe mir nie Sport an. Ich sage immer, wenn ich mir Sport ansehen würde, dann natürlich nur Boxen, weil es das ehrlichste von der Welt ist. Also wenn, dann muss man sich wirklich gegenüberstehen und auch zuschlagen. Das finde ich großartig. Ich gucke deswegen auch gerne Boxfilme, weil das da einfach szenisch schöner eingefangen ist, als jetzt so ein recht lahmes, so ein Boxkampf mir anzusehen im Fernsehen. Aber wenn, dann muss es schon martialisch sein.
Du bist halt ein Sportanfänger. Weißt du, die richtige Raffinesse kommt dann, wenn du Jan Frodeno siehst, wie er nach fünf Stunden zwei Minuten schneller vom Rad gestiegen ist als letztes Jahr bei dem gleichen Wettkampf. Und du daraus deine persönliche Erregung ziehst. Vielleicht könnte es dies Jahr klappen mit dem Rekord, nicht nach acht Stunden und drei Minuten, sondern acht Stunden und eine Minute durchs Ziel zu kommen.
Nein, ich will natürlich die Gewalt, das Körperliche, das Fleischliche, das Blutige mitunter. Also wenn, dann das. Also wie ein wilder Stier, Rocky, all das will ich im Sport werden erleben. Aber das andere ist für mich so ein bisschen, wie mal spazieren gehen am Rhein. Aber dieses Sportwettending ist, glaube ich, ein ganz, ganz schlimmes Phänomen unserer Zeit. Es hängt sicherlich damit zusammen, überhaupt diese ganze Glücksspielindustrie, dass es kaum ein noch glaubhaftes Aufstiegsversprechen gibt. Und dann bleibt nicht viel mehr als das Glücksspiel, dass man es vielleicht dadurch schaffen könnte. Und das ist doch sehr, sehr finster. Und man sieht ja gerade, wie auch Politiker das weiter vorantreiben, indem sie dieser Lobby immer mehr Freiräume geben, wahrscheinlich sich auch ordentlich korrumpieren lassen, sonst würden sie das vermutlich nicht tun. Man fragt sich ja immer so ein bisschen bei so Bewertungsportalen oder generell bei Filmportalen, IMDb oder auch Rotten Tomatoes. Was ist denn das da immer so mit den Zahlen? Film hat 7, 6 Punkte bekommen, 50.000 Leute haben abgestimmt. Und interessant ist, dass jetzt hier, um den Investoren schmackhaft zu machen, wie toll das Programm ist, genau darauf Bezug genommen wird. Wir hören mal rein.
The FX batting average in user ratings of the Internet Movie Database on a scale of 1 to 10 is among the best in US television at every elite level. 7 out of 10 stars and above, 7 and a half and above, 8 and above and 8 and a half and above.
Es ist ein wichtiges.
Länder bekommen auch dann nur den eingeschränkten Disney Plus Service. Bei anderen wird das gekoppelt, aber darum soll es jetzt mal nicht gehen. Denn ich weiß ja, Stefan will vor allem wissen, wie geht es dann mit Star Wars weiter?
Als alter Trekkie will ich das natürlich wissen.
Mit überwundenen Möglichkeiten für weiteres Innovation, hochwertige Storytelling und cinematische Erfahrungen, wie nie vorher.
Ja, Stefan, es gibt zehn, zehn neue Star Wars Serien. Man sagt sich Mandalorian hat ja gut geklappt. Jetzt wollen die zehn Serien machen. Sie stellen die dann vor. Man vergisst danach wieder alles. Irgendwas mit Anime, irgendwas mit Mystery, irgendwas mit Lando, dann drei Nebenfiguren. Die kannten sie bislang noch nicht. Die sind aber eigentlich ganz wichtig und da können wir noch mal eine Vorgeschichte erzählen. Außerdem wird es 15 Pixar-Serien geben, 15 Disney-Zeichen-Animationsserien, Zeichentrick-Animationsserien, zehn Marvel-Serien und außerdem dann Filme. Und dann wird immer gesagt, the best for the consumer.
Es ist einfach eine Sensation.
Es ist so abschäulich, wenn du das siehst. Also ich kann meinen Disney-Hust dann noch mal bestätigen, aber ich muss sagen, so schlimm hätte ich es mir nicht vorgestellt. Also man bekommt dann im Minutentakt irgendeine neue Serie dort angetreten, die als etwas Neues beschrieben wird, was sie in Wahrheit gar nicht ist. Und dann geht es wirklich nur darum, dass man sagt, gut, wir haben hier so ein Zugpferd. Da können wir mal schauen, wie viel kann man da noch dranhängen und wie viel zieht dieses Pferd noch mit. Und das ist dann eben Star Wars. Und dann hat man dort zehn Serien. Ich frage mich wirklich, wie kann man nur seine Zeit damit verschwenden? Denn wenn doch eines diese Pandemie jetzt gezeigt hat, wir haben so großartige alte Filme und die gilt es doch jetzt wieder zu entdecken und mal zu sehen, was eigentlich Qualität ist.
Also soweit würde ich jetzt nicht gehen, aber Mandalorian war so langweilig für mich, dass ich mich dann dabei erwischt habe, wie ich die Making-ofs The Mandalorian noch richtig cool fand. Weil die haben das ja nur vor so einer LED-Leinwand gedreht und so. Und das fand ich technisch einfach wahnsinnig interessant, wie das so ging. Weil das ist so die, wünsche ich mir dann auch als Holodeck für zu Hause. So in 30 Jahren, wenn ich da mal in so ein Altenheim ziehe oder so, dann will ich da auch, dass die Wände einfach aus LED-Panelen bestehen und ich mir dann anzeigen lassen kann, was ich will. Und so hat John Favreau das gemacht, im Mandalorian storymäßig und so. Ist das alles so lame? Also ich bin echt mal gespannt, ob da vielleicht, na gut, ich meine, wenn die so viel auf den Markt werfen, vielleicht ist ja mal irgendwann was dabei. Aber es juckt mich nicht in den Fingern, muss ich ehrlich sagen.
Aber jetzt habe ich was für dich. Du liebst doch Abenteuer. Du willst doch sehen, wie Menschen an ihre körperlichen Grenzen gehen. National Geographic, der auch ein Channel von Disney. Und die haben jetzt auch was Neues.
Wir sind ohne Frage in einer extraordinary Zeit.
Was wir mit dem Disney Plus-Audiensteen erfreuen.
Habe ich mich auch schon satt gesehen. Das sind diese typischen, wir zeigen dir mal ein 4K-Video bei YouTube, dann wird dann eine Landschaft gezeigt und okay, okay, ihr seid ein Baum.
Und was machen sie jetzt? Sie setzen auf Stars. Sie sagen, okay, wir müssen auf Stars setzen, wenn wir Stars irgendwie durch die Lande schicken, durch solche atemberaubenden Landschaften in 4K, dann könnte es funktionieren. Netflix hat das auch funktioniert, ich weiß nicht, versucht, ich weiß nicht wie erfolgreich, mit Zac Efron. Den hat man auch einmal um die Welt geschickt. Und jetzt tut man das bei Disney mit Chris Hemsworth, der ja auch wahrscheinlich Stahl zerbeißen kann oder so. Also der muss dort extreme Trainings auf sich nehmen und Will Smith. Die beiden hat man jetzt dort verpflichtet für den Kram. Welcome to Earth heißt das bei Will Smith. Und ja, ich werde es mir auf jeden Fall nicht ansehen. Kommen wir jetzt zum Chef, zum ehemaligen Chef von Disney, Bob Iger, auch schon so eine Legende und der sagt jetzt noch mal, was ihm besonders wichtig ist. Denn wir hätten ja jetzt den Eindruck gewinnen können, 15 Filme und Star Wars Serien und all das. Da geht es ja nur noch um Quantität. Nein, weit gefehlt.
Also wir wissen ja, wie Disney funktioniert im Sinne von, wer entscheidet darüber, welche Serie es ist. Es ist nicht wie bei Netflix, sondern da kommt das Fernsehgremium zusammen und macht das irgendwie. Und man kann schon richtig sehen, unter welchem Stress und welcher Eile, die einfach nur abnicken oder nicht und nur noch nach Signalen im Script und so weiter entscheiden, wie das da passiert. Dann lässt man nochmal hier so ein Algorithmus drüber laufen und sagen, also das hat, so eine Figur hat bei dem letzten Mal 7.5 or above Sterne gegeben. Also baut man wieder so eine Figur ein. Also ich erwarte eigentlich auch nur Blödsinn da. Das ist ganz schön angelegt auf Blödsinn.
Ja, nochmal Bob Iger, denn er sagt jetzt hier, was er eigentlich mit seinen Filmen angeblich erreichen will.
Wir, dass wir eine noch stärkere Verbindung mit unseren Konsumenten bieten werden. Ich glaube, sie wollen eher um sich selber kennenzulernen, sondern sie wollen die kleinen Sublties, also die kleinen Zwischentöne, das Subtile, das was dann wirklich überraschend ist, aber nur ihnen selber auffällt. Nicht im Sinne von das ist der Held für die ganze Welt, sondern sie haben etwas erkannt, was nur sie glauben, erkannt und verstanden zu haben. Das hält sich hier. Und davon sind die genau auf der anderen Seite. Ich glaube, der Ford hat Recht.
Er hat absolut Recht. Und das ist auch so ein Frühstadium von Ideologiekritik, dass man ja ganz schnell überwunden hat, dass man einfach nur glaubte Filme sind da, um Bedürfnisse, die es in der Masse gibt, einfach mal schnell zu befriedigen. Und da hat man sie. Nein, es gilt neue Bedürfnisse, neue Begehrlichkeiten zu schaffen. Deswegen sagt der Sijek, das Kino ist die ultimativ perverse Kunst. Das gibt uns nicht, was wir begehren, sondern das sagt uns, was wir begehren sollen. Und hier wird jetzt nur noch angedeutet, wir erweitern ein bisschen die Perspektive. Das heißt, wir werden es gleich noch erleben, mehr Diversity, also mehr Identifikation. In so einem ganz schlicht verstandenen Sinne stattfinden kann und mehr dann eigentlich nicht und dann kommt genau das bei raus. Alle fanden Mandalorian toll, machen wir doch zehn Serien da raus, ach und hier das war noch eine süße Figur, die hat sich auch gut im Shop verkauft, dann kriegt ihr auch nochmal irgendein eigenes Feature und so funktioniert Disney und das traurige ist, dass offenbar Leute sich auch schon so sehr an diese mindere Qualität gewöhnt haben, dass ihnen das alles recht ist und dass sie das auch sich immer noch als was Neues verkaufen lassen und das ist wirklich amüsant, du erlebst fast nichts Neues dort. Also die sagen, so ein paar Feigenblatt-Projekte gibt es selbstverständlich, sie machen was mit NBA-Stars, ein paar Biopics und so was, aber es geschieht eigentlich nichts Neues, das zeigt auch dieser nächste Clip. Eine Komödie, die man vermisst hat, im Dutzend billiger, macht man jetzt noch mal als Multikulti-Komödie und verkauft als was Neues.
Das ist auch völlig Missverstand, worum es da eigentlich geht.
Der König der Löwen, ein Film, den ich besonders hasse und auch da gibt es was Neues.
Wenn es um das Thema Drama, Komik, Aktion, Emotion, Musik, für die ganzen Zuschauer weltweit, ist es vielleicht nichts wie Der König der Löwen. Nach dem 1, 6-Billiard-Dollar-Success des 2019 Reimaginings sind wir in der Entwicklung auf einen inspirierten Prequel der Art, der diese eignen Charaktere wiederum besitzt.
Das ist genau der Fehler, den ich an Michael Bay auch... Das ist einfach der größte Fehler, den man so macht, dass man sagt, okay, Transformers, also machen wir noch einen Transformers. Sondern ich will, dass Michael Bay seinen Kopf anstrengt und mir eine neue Idee präsentiert. Und ich will dann nicht nochmal, wie er sagte, revisit the characters, dass ich die noch mal besuche in einem neuen Kontext und so weiter. Nee, die sind dann einfach abgeschlossen. Die habe ich dann gesehen und ergründet. Okay, Simba, Mufasa und so weiter, alles schön und gut. Next. Also da würde ich sozusagen, würde ich fordern, NEXT und nicht nochmal. Also ich verstehe das auch nicht. Das ist wirklich... Und das ist das durchgehende Prinzip.
Ich hatte mal angefangen aufzulisten, was es alles schon gab und was sie jetzt wieder rebooten, prequellen, sequellen und sonst was. Ich habe es dann aufgegeben. Wir könnten jetzt eine ganze Stunde nur Titel aufführen, die wiederkommen. Und Barry Jenkins ist der Regisseur. Das heißt, das ist der Regisseur von Moonlights, wurde ja gerade gesagt. Also ein Film, bei dem man dachte, ach ja, da wird ja mal ein bisschen was Neues gewagt. Da wird nochmal mit Farbe, Belichtungen anders gespielt. Da wird ein bisschen andere Hollywood-Asthetik gemacht. Zugleich hat man ja dort eine schwule Geschichte erzählt. Den Film muss man jetzt nicht übermäßig loben. Er ist gut, aber ist sicherlich kein Meisterwerk. Aber das wäre jetzt so ein Regisseur, bei dem man sagen würde, okay, der zeigt ganz viel, der kann richtig viel. Und dem müsste man jetzt so ein kleines bis mittleres Budget weiterhin immer geben, so alle zwei Jahre. Und dann macht er einen sehr guten Film. Vielleicht ist auch mal ein Meisterwerk dabei.
Ja, das verstand ich nämlich auch nicht.
Man kauft den jetzt ein und jetzt ist der Erfüllungsgehilfe für irgendeine Riesenproduktion. Das ist absolut lächerlich. Das wäre, wenn du einen Literatur-Nobelpreisträger hast und sagst, wollen sie nicht vielleicht die Talia-Buchhandlungen in Deutschland leiten.
Genau, das habe ich jetzt, als ich für Katz so ein bisschen nachgelesen habe, was hat so mit der Beigel-Bay-Biografie auf sich. Der hat damals Bad Boys gedreht. Das war er selber 28 Jahre alt oder so, Will Smith, noch Fernsehstar. Auf der Kinolein war er noch nicht gesehen und hat das zusammengebaut als Skript. Dann hat er gesagt, wir machen das jetzt. Dann gab es ein paar Action-Szenen, die waren zu teuer für die Produktion. Er hat selber noch sein eigenes Geld reingesteckt. Will Smith ist die ganze Zeit mit Michael Bays Porsche rumgefahren, weil es dafür auch kein weiteres Budget gab. Da fragt man sich, wenn das das erfolgreiche Kriterium ist, warum gibt man ihm dann plötzlich 100 Millionen und er erwartet dann irgendwas? Dann ist doch klar, dass Michael Bader einfach durchdreht und sagt, dann kaufen wir jetzt 80 Tonnen Benzin und zünden das an. Das hat er dann auch fünf Jahre später gemacht in Pearl Harbor. Er hat vier Schiffe nebeneinander gestellt, hat einfach 40 Tonnen Benzin angezündet und ist mit drei Flugzeugen umgeflogen, um das zu filmen. Diese Szene taucht dann dreimal in dem Film auf, in verschiedenen Zeitpunkten. Man fragt sich ein bisschen, hat sich halt ausgetobt. Dann Transformers. Transformers war damals in dem Jahr, als es erschien, der erfolgreichste Nicht-Sequel-Film, den Hollywood hervorgebracht hat. Was hat man daraus für einen Schluss gezogen? Machen wir auch ein Sequel draus. Da frag ich mich so ein bisschen, wenn die doch Erfolgskriterien haben, nämlich ein junger Regisseur vielleicht ein bisschen zu wenig Budget geben und dann eine neue Idee, also sag mal mal eine Idee, die alle schon im Kopf haben. Transformers gab es bisher noch nicht als Film. So, dann überlegt man sich doch nicht, was machen wir jetzt als nächstes mit diesem Transformer im Film, sondern welches Spielzeug haben wir denn bisher noch nicht? Was könnten wir denn jetzt mal gebellt geben? Also was hat man vielleicht noch nicht gesehen? Stattdessen arbeiten die sich dann an diesem Transformers-Scheiß ab.
Aber das ist risikoscheu, denn du kannst natürlich mit so was einen Riesenflop produzieren. Wenn Transformers nicht angekommen wäre aus irgendwelchen Gründen, und das passiert ja großen Regisseuren, dann hast du einfach Geld verbrannt. Und das sind ganz sichere Banken. Ich möchte mal eine Analogie herstellen. Disney funktioniert eigentlich wie die deutsche Autoindustrie. Warum sollen wir uns jetzt mit E-Mobilität, mit was weiß ich, alles darum... Ja, das haben die jahrelang einfach vor sich weggeschoben. Solange noch die Verbrenner laufen, solange machen wir noch einen noch größeren SUV. Und da sind nochmal 100 PS drauf und der kann auch noch automatisch dies und das öffnen. Aber eigentlich produziert man einfach immer nur irgendeinen Spritfressen.
Genau, und das ist sehr gut, wie du das sagst, denn man kann es noch übertreiben im Sinne von... Zu VW gehören ja sehr viele Marken, zum Beispiel Seand und so weiter. Und jetzt hat man ja eine Zulassung für verschiedene Modelle, kann dann aber eine andere Karosserie drüber bauen. Und es gibt beispielsweise bei Mercedes gab es das Problem, die konnten dann irgendwann, da hatten diese Probleme mit dem Kühlstoff, den sie hatten für die Klimaanlage. So, der war dann nicht mehr zugelassen für neue Modelle. Also hat man ein altes Modell, das schon zugelassen war, genommen, hat sich dann genau angeschaut, was ist denn hier zugelassen, hat eine neue Karosserie drüber gebaut. Da ich sag, das ist der neue Mercedes. Dabei war das nach Zulassungsjuristerei ein alter Mercedes. Und genauso ist das bei den Filmen auch. Ey, die Sachen haben wir alle schon zugelassen gekriegt. Sozusagen auch beim eigenen Management. Gibt's auch eine sehr lustige Szene. The Rock, ne? Also der zweite Film von Michael Bay. Hab ich bei Katze auch kurz erzählt, aber ich erzähl's hier nochmal. Michael Bay, die drehen diesen Film und dann sagt Michael Bay, so, Klappe für heute, ihr habt alle Feierabend, ich hab einen Termin. Und Sean Connery fragt ihn so, was hast denn für einen Termin? Ist doch 12 Uhr Mittags, wir können doch jetzt noch 3 Stunden filmen. Also ja, ich muss zum Management von Disney, weil die produzieren ja hier. Dann sagt Sean Connery, ich komm mal mit. Dann fahren die da zusammen hin und alle sind so total, ey der echte Sean Connery steht gerade bei uns hier im Büro und so. Und dann ist es natürlich wie zu erwarten, die als Management sagen, toller Film, wir wollten nur kurz hören, wie es so läuft. Sean Connery hat ja gesagt, es läuft super, also viel Spaß weiterhin und Meeting war beendet. Also da hatten wir sich da noch nicht mehr getraut, irgendwas zu sagen, wenn der alte James Bond da mit dem Raum steht.
Ist halt der Bond.
Genau, und so hat sich Michael Bay da auch den Freiraum entsprechend geschafft. Da hat er gesagt, kannst du ruhig mitkommen, wenn du willst, würde mir helfen.
Denn das ist immer so, also das müssen wir ganz klar sagen. Es gibt ja diesen schönen Text von Martin Scorsese über Marvel, seine Kritik aus dem vergangenen Jahr. Dieses Spannungsverhältnis gab es immer, das kann man in den 50er Jahren auch genauso beobachten. Aber es gab noch ein Spannungsverhältnis, sagt Scorsese. Und das hier ist hier nicht mehr. Sondern man hat hier einen Konzern, er sagt, hier ist das Geld, mach genau das, was wir wollen und da wird auch nicht mehr groß rumdiskutiert. Sonst tauschen wir dich aus. Das ist ja auch jetzt in den vergangenen Jahren immer passiert. Gab es mal irgendjemand, der eine eigene Idee hatte, wird sofort ausgetauscht, darf nicht weiter stattfinden. Und man fragt sich ja jetzt bei all diesen Präsentationen, welche Rolle spielt denn da noch das Kino? Wir haben jetzt nur über Streaming immer gehört und die sagen auch alle nur noch, ja, der wird veröffentlicht, aber die sagen nicht mehr, wo wird der veröffentlicht? Und man muss sagen 2000. 2021 war das schlimmste Kinojahr überhaupt. Also es war sowieso ein schwieriges Jahr. Fürs Kino war es echt ein ganz schlimmes Jahr. Wir erleben Kinosterben und es wird 2021 noch schlimm weitergehen. Wir können schon ahnen, wohin das führt, wenn wir uns jetzt hier diesen Clip von Disney anhören.
Das ist natürlich eine große Wette. Ich hab jetzt auch diese Ankündigung von Warner oder wer auch immer, dass wir jeden Film erstmal einen Monat für Streaming. Every Size, also das Handy ist für mich YouTube. Ich mach auf dem Handy kein Netflix an, kein Amazon Prime, um irgendwas zu gucken oder so. Das ist schon mindestens Fernsehen und die Fernsehs sind heute sehr groß. Hier hinter mir hängt ja auch so ein, weiß ich nicht, 55 Zoll oder so. Das ist ja dann schon, wenn man dann drei Meter davor sitzt, zwei Meter. Kleiner darf es dann wirklich nicht sein. Nein, Disney ist kein Kinobetreiber. In deren Sicht fällt ihnen das vielleicht leicht, da einfach abzulassen, solange die...
Und man muss sagen, Disney liebt das Kino nicht. Also das muss man hier ganz klar herausstellen. Also wenn nochmal irgendjemand kommt und meint, Disney ginge es irgendwo um das Kino, wenn die... das ist eine ganz klare Kampfansage. Das ist, pass auf ihr Kinobetreiber, wir machen Größe, aber die hängt nicht ab von eurer Leinwandgröße. Also wenn ihr schließt, dann machen wir das mit unseren Streamingdiensten. Wir brauchen euch nicht.
Genau. Kino wäre dann schon, das sind die Regisseure selbst, Cameron, Nolan, Michael Bay, die ja zum Teil dann auch wirklich dieses IMAX Zeug da machen und so. Aber ja, ich meine, man kann es ja auch sehen.
Nolan hat sich ja auch schon sehr kritisch jetzt wieder geäußert zu diesem Warner Brothers Deal, hat gesagt, dieses BMAX oder HBO Max oder wie das heißt, das sei die schlechteste Plattform der Welt. So hat er sich ausgedrückt. Und was jetzt Disney natürlich tut als Unternehmen ist, nicht nur zu schauen, wer kann sich mit was identifizieren, was produzieren wir dann, sondern man versucht ja auch, die Kritik zu inkorporieren. Und jetzt kommt wirklich ein ganz schlagendes Beispiel für diese Wokeness, die man jetzt sich einfach einkauft.
Back in the beginning of 2019 I saw a news piece about a group of storytellers and artists from Nigeria and Uganda. Tolu Olofayeku, Ziki Nelson and Hamid Ibrahim founded an entertainment company called Hougali. Their dream was to bring African stories created by African artists to the world through comics and animation, highlighting the diversity of cultures, history and voices across the continent. I'm proud to announce a first of its kind collaboration as Hougali and Disney Animation team up to bring their original long-form series to Disney+.
Da haben wir also Kritiker, die machen was gegen Disney. Disney guckt sich das an und sagt, oh ja, die können ja was. Die kaufen wir jetzt ein. Die sind so erdrosselnd durch Umarmen. Und dann hat man auch zugleich noch dieses identitätspolitische, afrikanische Geschichte von aber auch afrikanischen Menschen und und und. Eigentlich ist das so ein Streaming Wakanda, dass man sich da aufbaut. Bei Wakanda hatten wir auch schon diese identitätspolitische Komponente, die ja sowohl von links wie von rechts prima lesbar war. Und da wir eh im globalen Kapitalismus so einen neuen Tribalismus erleben, das heißt, die machen da, dort, das, da, das. Jeder Film wird nochmal umgeschnitten. Die Inder wollen keine Zigaretten sehen, dann kommen die raus. Die Chinesen möchten nicht, dass Tibet thematisiert wird, da kommen die raus. Dann bekommen die aber nochmal fünf Minuten mit irgendeinem chinesischen Star. Das heißt, jeder bekommt das jetzt so angeliefert, wie es gerade passt, wie große Modekonzerne auch Schleier und Necaps anbieten für die entsprechenden Länder. Und das ist wirklich auch so ein Ende eines Disney-Universalismus, wenn es den jemals gab. Also man macht wirklich alles mit und macht das dann hier auch mal positiv gewendet. Guckt mal hier, ihr dürft bei uns auch mal am Katzentisch Platz nehmen, bekommt auch ein bisschen Geld von uns, aber dann seid ihr bitte lieb mit Disney.
Ja, also dass man mittlerweile bei Netflix schon so unterschiedliche Film-Szenen dreht, je nach Ausspielort und so, da bin ich mir noch unschlüssig, was das bedeutet, wenn man sich das überlegt, wie viel Potenzial da ist, sich einfach politisch zu unterwerfen, ist das natürlich echt ein Problem. Was ich mich bei Disney immer noch, also was ich mich da einfach frage, ist bei Netflix sieht man ja schon, dass manchmal Szenen bewusst für kleine Bildschirme gedreht werden. Also in Dialogen, große Köpfe, so wie man ja auch, was weiß ich jetzt, bei John Oliver oder so was, ja, das ist schon fürs Handy gemacht. Da ist einfach sehr viel mehr Kopf als jetzt so Harald Schmidt, der immer als ganzer Typ irgendwie dasteht und so. Und wenn das sich in den Filmen niederschlägt, sind die Filme wirklich nicht mehr geeignet für Kino. Weil das kann man nicht auch nur großen Leinwand zu sehen die ganze Zeit. Du hast dann die Poren der Nase und so die ganze Zeit so vor dir und das ist alles so ein bisschen zu nah dran. Und diese Vernet-Flexierung, wenn die auch noch Disney ergreift, dann ist glaube ich auch wirklich so ein... weil dann wird auch den Investoren gesagt, das ist jetzt nicht mehr fürs Kino und so weiter. Also dann sind glaube ich wirklich Finanzströme umgelenkt anhand von...
Auch die Schauspielerei ist ja eine andere. Man spielt ja für die große Leinwand viel reduzierter. Man kann da ja nicht mit Fernsehgesten geschweige denn, mit Theaterbühne-Gesten auftreten und gute Schauspieler wissen das ja und passen das auch entsprechend an, machen so gut wie nichts und wirken dadurch. Ja, es gibt allerdings noch Kämpfer für das Kino und die sind nicht bei Disney. Da ist zum Beispiel der Neville Neff, dessen Film Dune wäre ja auch in diesem Jahr angelaufen, wurde dann einmal verschoben, nochmal verschoben. Jetzt gibt es diesen schlimmen Deal mit AT&T und Warner Brothers, also Telekom und Warner Brothers, die das dann auch gleichzeitig als Streaming raushauen und nicht nur auf den Kinoschnaht setzen, denn Neville Neff hat in Variety einen wütenden Brief geschrieben und ein paar Sätze daraus habe ich eingelesen. Es gibt hier absolut keine Liebe für das Kino oder für das Publikum. Es geht nur um das Überleben eines Telekom Mammuts, das derzeit eine astronomische Verschuldung von mehr als 150 Milliarden Dollar trägt. Streaming kann großartige Inhalte produzieren, aber keine Filme von Dune Ausmaß und Größe. Dune ist mit Abstand der beste Film, den ich je gemacht habe. Mein Team und ich haben mehr als drei Jahre unseres Lebens darauf verwandt, ihn zu einem einzigartigen Erlebnis für die große Leinwand zu machen. Bild und Ton unseres Films wurden akribisch für das Kino konzipiert. Ich glaube fest daran, dass die Zukunft des Kinos auf der großen Leinwand liegen wird, egal was irgendwelche Wall-Street-Deletanten sagen.
Derzeit kann ja wirklich keiner ins Kino gehen, allerdings hätte ich auch bei James Bond warten, bis es vorbei ist, auch wenn es halt 18 Monate sind. Aber so ein James Bond altert ja nun mal besonders gut.
Er soll ja jetzt dann Anfang April anlaufen. Ich bin sehr gespannt, ob das gehalten werden kann.
Und bei Dune hätte ich da auch nichts dagegen, wenn man sagt, dass die Impfung so weit durchgeht oder im Sommer alle die Inzidenzen niedrig sind und man das Kino wieder aufmachen kann. Ich war ja auch ein Tenant und es hat ja auch geklappt.
Ich glaube auch nicht, dass sich in den Kinos welche infiziert haben.
Das nervt mich auch so ohne Ende, diese ewigen Diskussionen, als ob sich jemand im Museum Ludwig infiziert hat mit Corona. Es ist absurd, wie Politiker eine harte, harte Reaktion haben wollen. Wirksamkeit spielt da nur nebensichtlich eine Rolle. Und da unterleihen die Kinos am meisten. Dann kommen die Restaurants und dann kommt der Interesse.
Dann hat man immer noch nicht die Urlauber im Griff, wo ich gar nicht verstehen kann, dass das noch gestattet ist.
Ski fahren geht dann aber. Man dreht einfach die Webcam so in den Himmel, damit man es nicht mehr sieht.
Das ist unglaublich. Um dieses Kino-Disney-Kapitel abzuschließen, kommt jetzt eine Literatur-Nobelpreisträgerin noch zu Wort, die früher viel ins Kino gegangen ist, dann natürlich irgendwann nicht mehr gehen konnte, weil sie ja sich eigentlich nicht mehr gut in geschlossenen Räumen mit anderen Menschen aufhalten kann. Sie lebt ja sehr zurückgezogen in Wien. Die Rede ist natürlich von Elfriede Jelinek, die aber dennoch eine große Szeneastin ist und die hat im Cargo-Magazin so einen sehr persönlichen Text über das Kino geschrieben und auch da nur ein paar Sätze von mir eingelesen. Ich bin in Wien im achten Bezirk aufgewachsen und oft ins Kino gegangen. Keines dieser Kinos existiert mehr. Das ist wirklich so, als hätte jemand dort in der Gegend das Licht abgedreht. Im Kino läuft die Lebenszeit auf der Leinwand ab. Es läuft die eigene Lebenszeit ab und das geht irgendwie parallel. Die zwei Zeiten knurren sich an, aber sie tun einander nichts. Sie schmiegen sich sofort aneinander. Sie kommen gut miteinander aus. Film ist Bild in der Zeit, Zeit wird Bild, wir sind im Bilde.
Also ja, ich würde allerdings sagen, wenn man mitbekommt, dass jetzt auch gerade die eigene Lebenszeit abläuft und nicht nur der Film, dann ist es ein blöder Film. Also blöde Filme machen das immer so bemerkbar.
Die über die Zeit nachdenken lassen. Das ist natürlich schlimm, ansonsten ist das Fiktionale natürlich interessanter als das echte Leben.
So, dann schließen wir mit einem letzten Thema, denn es gibt ein Unternehmen, dem geht es sehr viel besser als Disney. Es ist vielleicht genau das Gegenteilunternehmen von Disney. Dazu gleich ein, zwei Clips, denn es gibt jetzt neue Raketen, also nicht nur auf einer Leinwand, sondern echte Raketen. Wir sehen hier eine eingeblendet und diese, und für den Fall würde ich sagen, falls ihr nur audio-mäßig, ich gucke mal, dass ich es dann eingeblendet kriege, denn in diesem Fall ist das ein Bild vom Januar 2019. Du siehst eine silberne Rakete mit einer amerikanischen Fahne drauf, das Licht kommt von rechts und unten steht ein kleiner Mann, als wollte man dir noch mal zeigen, die Rakete ist echt groß. Es heißt Starship und vielleicht findest du es genauso passend wie ich, dass Elon Musk darunter geschrieben hat, das ist kein Rendering, sondern ein echtes Foto. Ah ja, also ein No-Filter. Das ist No-Filter, genau. Packen wir es ein bisschen. Was ist denn das? Baut man das jetzt, aus welchen Gründen eigentlich? Soll das echt fliegen? Schnellt sich raus. Ja, das soll echt fliegen. Also, 100 Jahre nachdem Albert Einstein 1921 den Nobelpreis bekommen hat, für viele erschreckende Erkenntnis, das Universum expandiert. Es ist jeden Tag ein bisschen anders. Und wenn wir nicht Schritt halten, dann ist es irgendwann weg. Hat Elon Musk sich gesagt, ok, dann erkunden wir jetzt mal dieses expandierte Universum. Er will ja sowieso ein interplanetarisches Zeitalter. Wir brauchen dafür größere Raketen. Und jetzt hat er welche. Denn das, was wir hier sehen, ist ein Prototyp für eine Rakete, die in dem Falle tatsächlich, auch wenn das so aussieht, als wäre das die ganze Rakete, erst mal nur die obere, sagen wir mal die oberen 20 Prozent zeigt. Da kommt also noch eigentlich der ganze, was wir so kennen, die ganze Säule, der ganze Zylinder an Treibstoff und Düsen unten dran. Und dann kann man sich schon vorstellen, ok, das ist wirklich eine Rakete. Also der Mann ist tatsächlich so klein. Du siehst also hier wirklich eine ungefähr 20 Meter hohe Rakete unter die dann noch mal 80 Meter andere Rakete kommen. Also am Ende läuft es hinaus auf eine 122 Meter hohe Rakete. So eine hohe Rakete hat noch niemand bisher gebaut. Und nicht nur konnte man beispielsweise eine 110 Meter große Rakete, die Santorin 5 oder so, hochschießen. Dann war sie allerdings im Weltraum und verloren. Denn diese Rakete, die Elon Musk hier baut, die kommt natürlich auch wieder runter. Das war ja immer sein großes Ziel. Und er hat es mit diesem Starship auch erreicht. Es gab bisher mehrere Prototypen. Die letzte ist jetzt im Dezember geflogen. Und auf die kommen wir gleich zu sprechen. Es geht hier bei SpaceX jetzt darum, dass man bisher, und es sind jetzt wirklich schon Dutzende Raketen in den Weltraum geflogen, um die ISS sogar mit Personal auszurüsten, aber auch mit Material, um Satelliten hoch zu... Also es ist gerne alles dieses Starlink-Projekt mit 12.000 Satelliten, die da fliegen sollen und so weiter. Es gibt jetzt einen richtigen Serienbetrieb an Raketenabschüssen, um irgendwas hochzubringen. Sehr viele von diesen, wie heißen sie bisher, Falcon-Raketen von SpaceX sind auch schon mehrfach im Einsatz. Also ich glaube, im Durchschnitt ist man jetzt bei zwei Einsätzen pro Rakete, das heißt halber Preis, im Vergleich zu den bisherigen Modellen. Und jetzt hat man für dieses Starship, das völlig neu konzipiert wurde, das ist also nicht einfach eine Falcon 9 und dann eine Falcon Heavy und dann baut man eine Falcon 11, sondern das ist jetzt eine ganz neue Rakete, die auch einen ganz neuen Antrieb hat, nämlich eine Raptor-Engine, so hat man es genannt, der und die Falcon Heavy kam auf 22 Megawatt Newton, jetzt mit 65 Megawatt Newton pumpt, also die kann dreimal so viel Kraft aufwenden und das ist das Spektakuläre. Die Falcon 9, also die bisherige größte Rakete, die dann nur von der Falcon Heavy noch mal ein bisschen getoppt wurde, die hatte drei Meter Durchmesser und 70 Meter Höhe. Das Starship hat neun Meter Durchmesser und 122 Meter Höhe und allein der Nutzlastteil, also oben, wo man die Klappe aufmachen kann und Zeug reinbringen kann, da kamen die Falcon Heavy, also die wirklich größere Rakete, die SpaceX bisher gebaut hat, die auch alle anderen trompft, auf 63 Tonnen und jetzt im Spaceship kommt man auf 150 Tonnen, also man hat es also mehr als verdoppelt und das finde ich einfach spektakulär. Jetzt, glaube ich, kann sich das jeder vorstellen. Sie hat 1000 Kubikmeter Platz. 1000 Kubikmeter ist mehr als ein komplett entkernter Jumbojet, als eine Boeing 747. Also wir haben es hier wirklich mit viel Platz und viel Möglichkeit zu tun, wirklich Sachen hochzuschießen. Du hast uns ja schon mehrfach über den Weltraum aufgeklärt und auch über das Weltraumrecht und da fragen sich ja einige, naja, Weltraumrecht, reicht das nicht, wenn wir da 2050 drüber nachdenken? Und ich würde sagen nein, denn...
Müsste eigentlich das große neue EU-Projekt dann aufwärmen.
Also dieser kleine Teil, den wir da jetzt sehen, ohne die große Trägerrakete unten, die es dann bis zum Weltraum schafft, das Ding ist jetzt im Dezember Probe geflogen und im Januar schon steht der große Test an. Also jetzt geht es wirklich ramba zamba. Und diese Rakete ist jetzt darauf angelegt, wiederverwertbar zu sein. Und zwar bis auf die Hitzeschilde. Die sind in kleine Kacheln eingeteilt. Die kann man also gut achten und austauschen. Alles andere von der Rakete wird wieder zusammengeschraubt, vollgepumpt mit Treibstoff und dann wieder losgeschossen. Wir haben es also insgesamt mit der billigsten Rakete im Flugbetrieb zu tun, die jemals gebaut wurde in diesem Maßstab, vor allem bei SpaceX. Jede Rakete bisher war mega teuer und ab jetzt baut man eine Rakete und muss danach nur noch tanken, was sofort zu allen Synergieeffekten führt und bedeutet, die größte Rakete ist gleichzeitig die billigste. Also wir werden es jetzt mit Weltraumtourismus zu tun haben. Klar, das sind dann Leute, die müssen erst mal 20 Millionen für ein Ticket zahlen und so, aber das ist der Start. Und wir haben es mit unglaublichen Volumen an Sachen zu tun, die wir jetzt da hochschießen können. Also die ISS hat Jahre gedauert zu bauen, ab jetzt kann man die halbe ISS in eine Rakete reinbauen und hochschießen.
Und du glaubst, dass das auch für den Weltraumtourismus interessant sein wird?
Ja, also diese Kuppel da oben, wir sehen jetzt hier dieses Prototyp von 2019. Da gibt es verschiedene Modelle, die man auf die neue Trigger-Rakete stecken kann. Beispielsweise eine, die oben komplett aufgeht, sodass man auch große Sachen wirklich rein verladen kann. Und es gibt auch ein Spaceship mit Fenstern, Betten, alles, was man braucht. Also das ist alles angelegt, das muss nur...
Das wäre ja dann noch was für dich, oder? Du machst doch schon so Herz-Kreislauf-Training und all das. Das ist ja so eine gesunde Fitness, die man dann für so was braucht. Ich meine, ich würde wahrscheinlich sofort nach einer Minute einen Herzinfarkt bekommen.
Wir alle, glaube ich.
Weil für dich wäre das doch bestimmt was.
Ich glaube nicht, dass ich hier jemanden freimachen kann von irgendwas, sondern das ist einfach... Ja, also wir haben natürlich solche Kaliber, wie es Richard Branson oder so, die kommen jetzt auch in so ein gewisses Alter, wo es vielleicht nicht mal angesagt ist, im Weltraum zu fliegen. Aber der Wunsch ist da, in den Weltraum zu fliegen, das Kapital auch. Und jetzt sind eben auch die Möglichkeiten da, es tatsächlich zu tun. Und wie spektakulär auch, was jetzt so die Macher angeht, dieser Probeflug tatsächlich war, möchte ich anhand von drei Clips zeigen von jemanden, der einen wirklich guten YouTube-Kanal hat, nämlich der Everyday Astronaut. Ich weiß nicht genau, wie er mit echten Namen heißt, ich sehe immer nur Everyday Astronaut. Der macht wöchentlich irgendwelche Videos, wo er minuten, stundenlang erklärt, wie die Raketen funktionieren, wo ich jetzt auch viele von den Daten her hatte und so, wo das immer so richtig erklärt wird. Der auch selber mit Elon Musk immer mal widerspricht, ihm zum Interview trifft und dann auch wirklich so, dass es jetzt im Adrian-Daubschen-Sinne der Herrscher der Welt, und ich darf ihn glücklich, dankbarerweise interviewen. Da hören wir gleich zwei Ausschnitte. Aber hier mal, der Everyday Astronaut steht also auf einem Balkon, neben ihm so ein paar Kumpels, die auch Kameras dabei haben und so weiter. Und sie gucken sich diesen Start, diesen Probelauf von dem Starship im Dezember 2020 jetzt an. Und wir gucken uns genau die drei Momente an, um die es geht. Nämlich erstens, die Rakete startet überhaupt erst mal. Und dann macht sie ein tolles Manöver, da kann ich gleich noch was zu sagen, und landet, versucht dann wieder zu landen. Hier erst mal der Start.
Hier wir gehen. Da ist ein neues Flugzeugrekord, meine Freunde!
Also das ist jetzt Spaceship No. 8 oder so, achter Prototyp, der hier den Probeflug absolviert. Die ersten sind bisher immer nur so 30 Sekunden hochgeflogen und dann wieder gelandet, um mal zu gucken, wie das so in verschiedenen Formen auch dieser Größe, es geht ja wirklich um Volumen und so weiter. Also die Rakete ist jetzt im Durchmesser dreimal so breit wie bisherige Raketen. Das macht also auch sehr viel mehr Volumen. Und da hat sich Elon Musk so gedacht, ich will die ja wieder landen lassen und ich muss sie ja irgendwie abbremsen, wenn sie dann mit 30.000, 40.000 kmh auf die Erdatmosphäre trifft. Beim Space Shuttle, das kennen wir, die Tragödie hat am Ende dann nicht mehr funktioniert, ist dann einfach verglüht beim Wiedereintritt. Da hatte man so einen Winkel von 45 Grad, das musste irgendwie hinhauen. Bei dieser Rakete ist jetzt so, die ist so groß und die hat auch noch so Flügel dran, die man so steuern kann. Also sie sieht eigentlich fast so ein bisschen Steampunk mäßig aus. Und die ist auch aus Stahl gebaut und so und ist nicht aus irgendeinem tollen Carbon irgendwas, sondern sie ist halt wirklich, kommt so ein bisschen altbacken daher. Aber man kann sie nutzen durch ihr Volumen, um selber durch Luftwiderstand zu bremsen. Man muss sie nur gegen die Hitze schützen. Und dazu gehört das Manöver Bully, wie heißt? Bellyflop, genau, der Bauchflop, der Bellyflop. Sie fliegt also hoch und darf dann nicht einfach wieder runterfallen, vor allem nicht spitze nach unten, aber auch nicht einfach so, sondern sie muss navigieren, dass sie genau wie ein Fallschirmspringer mit den Flügel und den Bauch die ganze Länge der Rakete nutzt, um zu bremsen. Und dieses Manöver galt als, naja, keine Ahnung, es sind ja schon viele Drucke, die da so auf die Rakete wirken und die besteht ja nun auch nur aus normalem Stahl und so. Und jetzt sehen wir hier diese Superfans, die da bisher immer nur YouTube-Videos drüber gemacht haben. Oh, tolles Szenario, mal gucken, ob es funktioniert und so weiter. Und die sehen jetzt, wie es funktioniert und rasten entsprechend auch aus. Deswegen gucken wir uns jetzt das über Bande, wie die sich das angeschaut haben, was da passiert.
Oh, da ist es. Oh mein Gott, hier geht es.
Das ist der Bellyflop, Leute.
Wenn du in der Zeit im Weltraum bist und über kleine Düsen immer so Steuermanöver machst. Genau das hier macht die Rakete auch. Die hat da so kleine Düsen drin und bringt sich in diese Belly-Flop-Situationen, der sie einfach gerade und dann mit allem Luftwiderstand, den sie einsammelt kann, einfach so weit möglichst abbremst, dass sie dann wieder das eigentliche Landemanöver machen kann, sich nämlich in der Luft wieder aufzurichten, um dann senkrecht zu landen. Und zwar, und das ist der Plan, genau da, wo sie losgeflogen ist, damit man sie da einfach volltanken kann und wieder hochschicken kann. So, dieses letzte Manöver hat noch nicht funktioniert. Sie ist explodiert, aber Elon Musk hat gesagt, wir haben alle Daten gesammelt, die wir brauchen und... Das war ja auch der erste Versuch und das nehmen wir mal locker. Die Typen sitzen allerdings hier, haben schon gesehen, ey bisher, wir haben dran gezweifelt. Ist ja gerade das Triebwerk ausgefallen, aber was ist denn los? Ach nee, sie geht in den Bellyflop und so. Und die gucken sich die Landung an. Sie sind eigentlich relativ weit weg, aber die Druckwelle erreicht sie dann doch noch und da sind sie ganz außer sich.
Guys, this is actually looking like it's working.
Relight! Red! They lost the legend!
Ja, und jetzt weiß man auch, warum das für manche doch ein kleines Problem darstellt, wenn wir in diesem Jahr Böller und Raketenverbot haben und alle immer sagen, ja, ist doch eh Mist. Es gibt eine große Freude daran, was in die Luft fliegen zu lassen. Und ich sehe das heute mit einer großen Distanz und staune mir über die Jungs als über die Rakete, stelle ich gerade fest. Aber wenn ich doch an meine Kindheit mich erinnere, weiß ich, dass Silvester für mich das schon eine ganz große Sache war, möglichst viele große Raketen abzufeuern.
Genau, und die hier ist nun explodiert. Sie war sehr laut und sie haben die Druckwelle dort auch gespürt. Also die Kamera wackelt da kurz und die sind ja wirklich kilometerweit weg. Das ist schon ein Riesending, da hat man nochmal wirklich erspürt, wie riesig die Rakete wirklich ist. Diese Landung wird natürlich noch funktionieren, dass der erste Versuch dann nicht klappt, ja geschenkt. Also das war bei den anderen auch so, das wird ein ganz solides. Mittlerweile ist das ja auch bei den Falcon-Raketen langweilig. Die landen halt einfach wieder und stehen dann da bereit und können halt wieder benutzt werden. So, und zum Ausklang, weil wir starten jetzt ein neues Jahr. Und wir wollen ja mal wieder ein paar Sachen unter Kontrolle kriegen. Und der Elon Musk kriegt solche Raketen hier unter Kontrolle. Fragt man sich so ein bisschen, wie eigentlich? Und jetzt komme ich wieder in mein Fentum zurück. Da lasse ich mich von Adrian Daub auch nicht von abbringen. Ja, es ist ja ganz, ganz schlimm.
Also wir haben ja im Salon über Adrian Daubs Buch geredet und ich dachte, okay, jetzt ist auch bei dir angekommen, dass diese Elon Musk-Verehrung aufhören soll und kaum baut er eine Rakete, bist du wieder Fanboy.
So ist es, aber die Rakete ist halt da und sie funktioniert tatsächlich mit allem, was er sich vorgestellt hat. Die macht dann Bellyflop, dann segelt die auf ihrem Luftwiderstand darunter, wird entsprechend gebremst, so dass sie dann auch solide landen kann und das mit einer Rakete, die doppelt, dreifach, zehnmal größer ist das alles, was wir bisher hatten, in deren Sicht schon beeindruckend. Deswegen jetzt zwei Lebensweisheiten von Elon Musk zum Thema und das ist Rocket Science. Ja, also die Transferleistung zum, es sollte fürs Allgemeine auch funktional sein, also die muss naheliegen. Und die erste Lebensweisheit von Elon Musk ist, wenn ein Plan zu lange dauert, ist es vielleicht kein guter Plan.
Und die generelle Ansicht ist, wenn ein Design zu lange dauert, ist das Design falsch. Eine der grundlegendsten Errungen im Entwicklungssatz ist, dass es zu einem Design steigt, auch wenn es sehr kompliziert ist.
So, diese Rakete sollte eigentlich aus irgendeinem Carbon Zeug, keine Ahnung, hat er irgendetwas gelesen, das könnte klappen. Dann hat er seinem Team den Auftrag gegeben, bot mir mal eine Rakete aus Carbon und dann, wie ich sage, dauert noch eine Weile, den nächsten Monat sind wir fertig. Ich habe gesagt, nächsten Monat, dann nehmen wir jetzt doch Stahl. Also, da wurde die Rakete aus Stahl gebaut, damit sie entsprechend fliegt. Und sie hat ja funktioniert, haben wir ja gesehen. Und das finde ich, keine Ahnung, ob man da so pauschal rangehen kann, aber ich finde, das ist ein ziemlich guter Ratschlag, ehrlich gesagt. Wenn du zu lange grübeln musst darüber und es gäbe noch eine andere Möglichkeit, die theoretisch aber schlechter ist, dann sagen wir jetzt einfach, sie ist besser, weil sie schneller. Man kommt dann auch zu was. Also finde ich irgendwie eine gute Idee. Sollte man vielleicht immer mal testen, ob man das nicht so machen kann.
Wäre bei den Impfungen zum Beispiel schon mal ein guter Ratschlag gewesen?
Ja, bei den Impfungen. Alles, was das beschleunigt, ist pauschal gut. Und wenn Herr Spahn dann irgendwie am 28. sagt, das finde ich aber blöd, dass die am 26. schon geimpft haben, das war eigentlich nicht abgemacht, soll erst am 27. losgehen. Da muss man sich fragen, das geht so nicht. Geschwindigkeit ist hier King einfach. Also da kann man es schon mal sehr gut übertragen. Umso schneller die Impfung, umso besser, egal nach welchem Modus. So und die zweite Lehre finde ich fast noch besser, denn wir haben es hier mit Rocket Science zu tun. Das heißt, es ist wirklich, wirklich kompliziert. Und das schafft man auch nicht alleine, der Elon Musk hat die Rakete nicht alleine gebaut. Aber was bedeutet es für die Mitarbeiter an der Rakete, Rocket Scientist zu sein? Und Elon Musk ist hier ganz entschieden.
Er meinte, es ist nicht du. Jeder muss verstehen, wie all die Systeme im Fahrzeug funktionieren. So hat man keine Subsystem Optimisierung. Das ist natürlich das, was passiert. Man sieht die organisativen Fehler.
Wenn du eine Rakete baust, kannst du dir als Chefe des Ladens den Anspruch stellen, jeder Mitarbeiter kennt hier jedes Bauteil und weiß über alles Bescheid. Da kommt nicht der Einzelne und optimiert sein Spezialistentum und sagt, das wäre aber geil, wenn wir es so und so machen. Sondern nein, er fügt das gleich in dem Kontext der ganzen Rakete ein und versucht nicht, als so ein Gerangel mit, wenn du da ein paar Abstriche machst in deiner Abteilung, dann könnte ich hier mehr das und das machen. Sondern alle verstehen den Kontext. Und wenn einer von außen fragt, wer ist denn hier der Chef-Ingenieur, ich habe mal eine Frage, dann sagen alle ich. Und das finde ich richtig gut. Also das ist mal, das sollten sich viele Unternehmen, viele Organisationen, ja nicht Management-Ebene, das haben wir auch bei Netflix da gelesen, bei Retestings, so dieses, ja ich bin hier der Chef, der ich entscheide. Die da unten, die müssen das gar nicht wissen. Nee, man führt einfach mal alle Informationen an alle zu und dann guckt man, dass es hinhaut und der Anspruch ist, schade nicht dem Unternehmen, es geht dir darum, eine Rakete zu bauen und nicht einen Raketenantrieb zu optimieren, sondern der muss halt im Sinne der Rakete irgendwie, ja und dann wissen alle über alles Bescheid und das finde ich einfach, das ist gut. Überblick, Orientierung, Perspektive, Wissen und Gemeinsamkeit, ja Zusammenhalt, alles was wir uns hier wünschen. So funktioniert es glaube ich und so kann man dann sogar Rocket Science machen und zwar Raketen echt fliegen lassen, die dann auch genauso fliegen, wie sie fliegen sollen, obwohl sie noch nie eine Rakete so geflogen ist, wie sie da fliegen. In deren Sicht, so geht es.
Also du endest mit Optimismus.
Absolut.
Machen wir so, wir verweisen noch ganz kurz auf den Salon. Wir sprechen da auch über die Zukunft, nämlich über eine Zukunftsstadt, die aber schon Gegenwart ist. Shenzhen, eine Stadt in China, eine Smart City. Und da gibt es ein hochinteressantes Buch von Wolfgang Hirn.
Hast du schon gelesen?
Gemeinsam gelesen? Ich habe es schon gelesen.
Ah ja, ich habe es noch vor mir.
Okay, darüber werden wir gemeinsam reden. Und dann lese ich gerade die ebenso interessante Biografie über Henry Kissinger. Und da gibt es auch einiges zu erfahren, nicht nur was das 20. Jahrhundert betrifft, sondern vielleicht das eine oder andere auch, was wir auf die Gegenwart und Zukunft übertragen können. Und die anderen Texte stelle ich noch zusammen. Da lasse ich mir noch ein bisschen offen halten.
Genau, ich bin auch mal gespannt, was ich noch auswähle. Zur Auswahl ist mal wieder einiges. Zum Beispiel gibt es jetzt doch einen großen Wandel aus der Corona-Krise zu lernen im Sinne für die Klimakrise, aber nur im Sinne von, wir kriegen es nicht hin. Also wir haben jetzt an Corona gesehen, dass wir es mit dem Klima nicht hinkriegen. Und in Amerika stellt man fest, dass 50 Jahre Trickle-Down niemandem geholfen hat. Also sie werden auch jetzt Wirtschaftsmodelle überprüft. Und ob wir nach Trump in eine tolle Zukunft reinreiten oder einfach nur eine Fantasie gegen die nächste austauschen als politisches Publikum, ist auch noch so eine Frage, die man mal klären könnte anhand eines Textes. Also in deren Sicht liegt auch einiges parat, dass man sich dann mal anschauen kann. Deswegen, ich stelle es dann auch noch zusammen. Aber ich glaube, ich bleibe nur bei einem Buch. Nächste Woche im neuen Jahr.
Wunderbar.
So ist es. Gut.
Dann, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer, einen guten Rutsch. Vielen Dank für dieses Jahr und dann auf ein gutes 2021.
Genau, rutsch gut rein. Ich mach's gar nicht so pathetisch. Nächste Woche ist dann einfach Salon und nächsten Monat kommt der nächste Podcast. So ist es. Ringe hauen, Leute.